the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club strange new moves led to
fascinating positions at the US Women's
and US Open championships in St Louis
players try to remain unfaced as they
battle for a national title Carissa Yip
is hoping to boldly go into a new
frontier as us women's champ winning her
game to remain co- number one in the
women's section Manu Mishra doesn't
believe in no wi scenarios defeating his
opponent to transport him into clear
first will Front Runners continue to
prosper or will their tenure at the top
be shortlived day four of enterprising
chess coming up
[Music]
next
welcome back chess fans to day four of
the US Chess Championship and US wom
chess Championships held here at the St
Louis chess club we start a day in the
World Chess Hall of Fame as we are
waiting for the players to arrive and
start the battles over the chess boort
is the day before the rest day and
surely every player will leave
everything over the chess boort let's go
to the studio and start the
action welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club proudly presents the US and US
Women's chess championships the young
players have risen to the top as round
four is about to
start
hello and welcome everyone thank you for
joining us I kaarina yova and I am here
with yaser Sahan Kate as always a great
pleasure to be with you in studio and
calling all the action because it's been
great fun absolutely fantastic games and
the six-hour game yesterday between
Jennifer you and Talia cantes lot of
fight here well I tell you we needed to
recharge our batteries but what is going
on is we're having a sensation here at
the the US championships is one 14year
old has stolen all the headlines and
storm declare first and in the ladies
section we have two co-leaders tell us
our standings Kate let's start with the
ladies sure let's take a look so we will
start with the women's section we have
two leaders Karissa and be here janova
who are having a very good start to the
tournament so far two and a half points
out of three then we have a three-way
tie for a third place here Crush Anna
zatonski and Nazi p with two points so
far ashita esan still zero points she's
waiting for that lucky break today
absolutely and in the open section in
the open section we have one leader the
young abim Manu Mishra two and a half
points absolutely incredible start very
unexpected even for him as he told us in
the interview and then we have a two-way
tie for the second place Fabiano Karana
and Sam shankland with two points many
players at 50% in tell tell us about our
format K we the two national
championship we have two 12 player round
Robins which means each player plays
everybody else in their respective
section we play classical chess here so
the time control is 90 minutes for first
40 moves followed by 30 minutes for rest
of the game and a 30 second increment
from move one there are no draw offers
allowed players cannot agree on the draw
and a traditional scoring system one
point for a win half a point for a draw
and zero points for loss tell me about
the schedule and let me know that
there's a free day coming up absolutely
we have a very easy schedule one round a
day the coverage always starts at 1:20
p.m. Center time we have round we have
round four today and tomorrow there is a
rest day for everyone then another four
rounds another rest day three more
rounds and if necessary we will have
playoffs on October 18th marvelous and
Christian as always wonderful to have
you in studio I tell you we are
witnessing something remarkable maybe
historic AB this young man storming we
have great games we're enjoying
ourselves here in the news Studio it's a
lot of fun calling all the shots all of
their moves but the story is of that of
the 14-year-old ABI Manu Mishra he's
just having an incredible tournament so
far and let's take a look at how he got
to where he is in that leadership
position after three rounds as you can
see 2 and a half out of three he started
off with a draw against Jeffrey Shong
that was not easy but he didn't seem to
have a lot of problems in that game
either after that an incredible Victory
with the white pieces against Andrew
Tang that was really showcasing his
skill as well as his opening theoretical
knowledge and he showed that theoretical
knowledge in game three yesterday as
well with the black pieces what a wild
game that was against Robson and guess
what with that Victory he is right now
surpassing in the live ratings
2600 uh fed rating that's just an
incredible feature I have to say he's
the fourth youngest to do that after
John Burke prananda and the illustrous
way just an incredible feature for this
young man and I know how much that means
to him and to his family as well who has
been supporting him throughout his
career we have a lot of decisive games
as well I have to say for a classical
tournament take a look at this in the
ladies section we started off slowly one
decisive game out of six in round two
three decisive games and yesterday what
a bloody round that was four decisive
games eight out of 18 total that's a
pretty good percentage for a classical
tournament I have to say and what do we
have in the open section let's take a
look also started slowly with one
decisive game in round one in round two
two decisive games three decisive games
in round three that's what I call
Momentum right a trend of course of
course 27.8 I have to say these players
are ready to fight and I cannot wait to
call all the action with you guys and
maybe Talia could have won yesterday too
to make it five out of six Kate do the
honors tell our audience what they can
expect for the pairings for this round
four let's start with the l yes so let's
start with the women's section we have
really cool pairings today so we start
with esan playing Abraham and then right
here we have the key matchup the leaders
are playing each other Yip against toir
janova yeah obviously our Marquee
matchup is our two tournament leaders go
head to-head then we go with cantes
playing Lee for kashian playing U and
then another really cool match up the US
Women's Champions the former US women
Champions are playing each other P kid
against crush and then on the last board
zatonski playing Yen and in the open
section the open section Karana is
playing sh savian playing Dominguez
Shanklin playing so and then here we go
really important matchup Mishra playing
nant yeah that will be a nice one to
watch can the bad boy upset the newcomer
and the youngsters also playing each
other right then aronian playing Robson
and Jong playing tank and the players
have been fighting incredibly hard what
are they fighting for or let's start
with the ladies price fund they're
fighting for a very generous price Fund
in the women's section we have
$152,000 and the first place takes on
40,000 second place 30,000 third place
20,000 and each player receive price
money with a 12 place $44,000 and in the
open section in the open section the
price winner is
$250,000 and the winner here takes home
60,000 second place 45,000 and third
place 35,000 and again everyone receives
price price money with do 12 Place
taking home
$6,000 thank you for that as we see the
shots of the World Chess Hall of Fame
players are getting on their game faces
for this the fourth round and again
because it's the round before the free
day uh when I was fighting in these
chess uh championships I tell you I
really wanted to put everything I had
because I knew I got a day to recover
and I have I'm expecting a big round
it's great to see Ray Robson smiling
again he's been having a rough event so
far how disappointed he was in that
first round against Sam San and
yesterday as well he is showing it on
his face whenever he has a good game
especially in that round one and after
that to lose that position he was so
disappointed but today we see him
smiling we see him ready to get back
into this
tournament and uh speaking of Ray
suffering Alice Lee uh everybody's pre-
turn favorite why not she's had the year
of her life she's starting well with two
losses in a draw that's that's
extraordinary I I mean and again we talk
about confidence but her confidence has
been rattled right and Talia santes is
having a very nice tournament yesterday
she missed out on a win but still she
managed to or she made a draw so I think
today she has white pieces so she can be
hungry because she's saying that Al
she's seeing that Alice is not having
the best tournament yeah as they seeing
nzi uh waiting for arena and that's the
thing about this tournament once you
start losing games you know a Target is
on your back everybody's going to try to
win that game against you exactly and
when your confidence is shattered it's
very difficult to make those moves make
those decisive moves because we know how
difficult those decisions are especially
in a complex position especially with a
clock winding down and again we see Nasi
waiting for arena Crush
uh what we think is going to be a huge
game uh for both players but talk about
be and Carissa Yip Carissa Yip coming
from the world juniors in Mexico where
she played very very well beam's been
playing very well um what are you
anticipating in that match Christian oh
that's a big one and I have to say I'm
not going to call it as early as round
three but this could be a decisive one
for the final standings these ladies
have shown us that they're in great
shape in this tournament okay beg him a
little bit suspicious play in the middle
game yesterday after she got an early
gift in the opening against tatv right
she did allow tatv back in the game not
only with full compensation but maybe
with an even better position but she
defended accurately after that and one
thing about her game uh is that she
plays fast so this two players they also
play fast they don't go into time
trouble we've seen caresa yesterday with
50 minutes against uh Alice Lee's one
minute on the clock that actually played
into her Victory um quite uh a lot
yesterday but I have to say this one is
going to be very interesting this game
right here nazzi piz versus Irena Crush
two-time Champion against eight time
Champion is a clash of Champions exactly
seeing one E4 now uh Kate when I think
of Arena I am as black against one E4
I've always always considered her a
sicilian specialist the tricky part
about her Sicilians though is she's a
moving Target she's not just nidor nidor
nidor no she can mix it up with a can
are we seeing one E4 E5
D4 really
what no no D4 D5 C4 never mind oh sorry
you said4 was one you thought it was
one4 I was I was uh one file over
you scared me for a second yeah I scared
myself when I saw E4 E5 captures on what
what am I looking at Queen git accepted
with E4 and uh let me just pull that one
up on my board sorry I'm going to take a
look
here and where are you uh I see right
there uh for me whenever I think of the
Queen's Gambit accepted and of course I
played Queen's Gambit accepted through
much of my career career I've always
long felt that if you're going to move
your pawn and give up control over the
E4 square with the move D5 takes C4 I've
always felt that E2 E4 is where you were
going to try to get an advantage and uh
E4 came very very quickly so the capture
was certainly not a surprise uh for nzi
Knight F6 uh E5 Knight D5 Bishop takes
C4 is how
uh the theory goes I always like to play
Knight B6 in this specific position as
black uh I know today they're doing all
kinds of crazy things
um wow uh the is just e exploded and um
I think Knight B6 is still by far the
main line and I think we're going to see
Knight B6 for sure Knight B6 and now the
question is where are you going to put
the bishop go to B3 but also you can go
to D3 can never touch this Pawn as black
queen takes D4 Bishop to B5 and the game
is over right you're losing the queen so
these are the type of questions that
these two players are going to have to
answer these theoretical questions but I
have to say right now arena is thinking
so perhaps despite the fact that she may
be surprised at beginning her opponent
with the Queen's Gambit accepted Nazi
was ready for it and she was ready with
the most aggressive way in which you can
play against qga and that is move three
E4 taking the center and trying to pose
immediate problems for your opponent and
as we can see Knight to B6 Bishop to D3
is on the board exactly uh turning our
attention to our tournament co-leaders
Karissa Yip has essayed the scotch uh
variation this early D4 takes on D4
Knight takes D4 and again really I you
have to give Gary Casper off an enormous
amount of credit for Reviving The Scotch
E5 Queen Queen E2 Knight D5 and in this
exact
position excuse me the main move uh for
100 years and longer has been C2 C4
Bishop A6 and a long theoretical dispute
from this specific position ensues um
along with C4 there are moves like G2 G3
also essayed by Gary Kasparov and a move
that John Van a Grandmaster from Holland
really liked is this move H2 H4 why why
would you play H4 let's play a terrible
move for black just a ter absolutely
terrible move H5 what was the idea and I
just every time he showed me this I I I
cracked up C4 Bishop A6 the idea was to
play Rook H3 so you could play Rook A3
you see you started laughing right away
because it is so humorous that you would
play Rook H3 to A3 but ALS also the a
secondary idea behind the move H2 H4 is
sometimes you can play Bishop to G5 and
you just need to uh Square protected I'm
not a big fan of H4 myself what is the
theoretical value of this move if you
will it's more of a surprise weapon I
want to say and I've looked at this for
both white and black mostly for white as
a surprise weapon for my students uh in
fact begim played this move as well with
white p so we do have some files in it
the question is whether she remembers
what she needs to do because this is
always the question especially in this
type of sharp variations Bishop to A6 is
uh sorry not Bishop to A6 here because
you haven't played C4 to get ready for
this idea that you just pointed out with
C4 after the move A5 for example which I
do believe is one of the main lines I'm
not sure if she will be playing I think
we saw a move yes A5 and this in our
file is considered to be the best move
for for a black now if you go C4 Bishop
to A6 and now your idea with Rook to H3
Rook to a it's harmless right because
you're hitting the pawn instead of
hitting the bishop not necessarily
harmless but at least you still have to
make a move after that to take on A5 and
then you have to contend with all the
ideas related to Bishop to B4 check and
picking up the Rook so it's not that
easy to get this Rook to H3 Rook to A3
um in the position A5 C4 was played we
expect Bishop to A6
and now G3 is one of the main moves a B3
as well is another one of the moves and
that's why A5 is such a useful move
because especially after Knight to B6 at
some point you will have to defend that
pawn on C4 somehow and most likely you
will do that by playing the move B3 once
you play the move B3 I can always start
looking at ideas of A4 and opening you
up on the queen side so there's a lot of
details a lot of uh uh interesting ideas
has in the position and we're going to
have to wait and see who is the better
prepared player in this position it's
pretty obvious that Karissa definitely
has surprised her opponent right now
begim is trying to remember probably
something that she looked at long time
ago in terms of preparation Kate uh for
help me out here is Karissa known for
playing scotches at all I am not sure I
remember during the US junior girls she
played the central
right D4 move to though right so I think
maybe she's experiencing with like
different openings but Scotch is a very
nice opening to play you like it okay
and by the way we do have C4 I don't
think Bishop A6 was played I think
Bishop to A6 KN Knight B6 came Knight to
B6 right away that's uh one of the top
moves as well as well and another cool
idea with H4 is you can just push the
pawn right H5 H6 just just try to weaken
some of the squares there H5 is one of
the moves Knight to D2 you need to start
getting ready for the attack um against
the pawn on C4 somehow because you know
it's coming Bishop to A6 is not the only
weapon that I'm bringing to the table
but after that I'm also going Queen to
E6 reinforcing uh the threat on that
pawn and then once again whenever you go
B3 you have to be ready for these ideas
with A4 so I have to say I don't
remember EX exactly how white is finding
her uh footing in this position after
this move A5 and I don't remember
exactly the details of why H4 is
actually useful in this position so um
again a surprise weapon but if your
opponent knows how to deal with it as
with the black pieces then she's going
to be just fine all right and I just
want to check in on my pick to win the
event Alice Lee she's going up against
Talia Talia yesterday we know know she
had that win against Jennifer U so close
it turned out to be an incredible
defense by Jennifer she's a great
fighter that's amazing that you know you
are in a worst position and you manag to
just keep defending for four five hours
and then became five and six then you
get the theoretically drawn end game but
you still have to make sure that you
know how to defend it absolutely let's
jump in on the Talia versus Alice Lee
game it was a slav defense with uh
Bishop F5 Knight C3 again this has
become so topical this whole Knight H5
Bishop G6 grabbing the two Bishops now
c4 takes D5 that's a little bit of a
wrinkle a lot of the top players I've
seen playing Bishop D2 just keeping the
tension because they're not 100% sure
they want to make that trade C4 takes D5
Alice just thinking about it uh here
because either recapture C takes and or
E takes should give black an easy game
um I'm not sure I like this captures how
about you Kate do you like C honestly
I'm not very familiar with this opening
I'm either E4 player or London player so
I don't get these positions with white
but I feel that if um if black
recaptures with the E Pawn which I feel
is a little bit more um it's nicer
because you don't keep the same
structure it's a Carl's Bad structure
right and now you go Bishop
E6 Bishop D3
bishop3 a for white Bishop D6 for black
right that seems like a nice position uh
for for black like easy but I know Talia
is kind of familiar with this structure
because she's always been playing these
positions so I wonder what she plans to
do there coach I'm looking at this
position I see this bishop on C1 nor in
these types of structures in case Alice
was to recapture with the E Pawn I'm
used to seeing White playing Queen C2
Bishop D2 castles long
uh would you uh well it makes sense from
a theoretical perspective if you think
about it I have the two Bishops so what
do I have to do I have to open the
position this is one way to open the
position if you do allow me to maneuver
my knight to D6 that's or to E6 as well
Knight D7 Knight f8 Knight D6 then black
is going to be more or less fine that is
White's idea you need to create some
imbalance in the position give your
Bishops a chance to find their targets
yeah flourish and of course don't take
with a c Pawn uh that's I believe that's
quite a big mistake I have a feeling
after Queen to B3 I have ideas of Knight
to B5 Bishop to B5 I don't think you're
ready for uh taking with a c Pawn but
she's thinking about it my goodness
because I played uh The Exchange slav so
often when the light squared Bishops the
black has doesn't have the uh problem of
a light Square Bishop on C8 I didn't
think think that this was any problem
Queen B3 Queen B6 just uh the the
computer likes the two Bishops a lot
Bishop to D2 maybe try to it's all about
finding the footing on the C file right
so maybe not with Queen to B3 Queen
without Queen yes yes maybe I'll keep
this queen to A4 idea in my back in my
back pocket keep right so for example
I'm just going to put some moves let's
go Rook C1 let's go Rook C1 everybody
see who's first if you manage to Castle
in time and slow the position down then
you will be fine well here once again
we're talking about are we aspiring for
F34 Bishop on D2 looks stepid right
right uh no I don't think we're aspiring
for that no uh let's go Queen B3 now
okay Queen B3 Queen B6 uhuh so you're
not afraid of well even if you go
knight4 you go Knight D7 exactly even if
we go into these endings if I get to
play Bishop D6
I don't know King E7 but here's the
problem if I'm in Alice Lee shoes and
I'm sitting there going gosh I've
created a hole for myself right how am I
going to win this game it's going to be
very very hard to get uh a position
where I start playing for an advantage
is black but I'm not sure if she wants
necessarily to win this game either
right maybe she's just thinking about
hey I need to stop the bleeding right
now that's a typical strategy and I if
I'm not mistaken his coach is a very EXP
coach her
coach lender if I'm not I think they're
working together I don't want to
disclose too much but I do believe
they're working together so you know her
coach is a pretty classical player
classical coach as well so he probably
advised her hey you know just quiet
things down and perhaps that's why she's
thinking right now about taking with a
cwn keeping uh the structure symmetrical
and playing it like that I don't think
she is thinking too much about winning
she's thinking about equalizing with the
black pieces that's step number one and
if you do get the opportunities take
advantage of those but if you don't get
them just make a draw okay uh quickly
just checking in on the game uh of Nazi
and Arena Crush because they followed a
game I played in the US championship
against Demitri gervich back in the day
Bishop G5 F3 Bishop uh H5 these
positions you have to have a tremend
tremendous
awareness uh about the positions that
can ensue after E5 E6 these Pawn
sacrifices um there something position
they're going to disrupt Black's
position yes yes yes and you really know
you have to uh if you're going to allow
them you have to play them very very
precisely because you can just get uh
destroyed I at at the time that I played
these lines as as uh black boy every
moment I was very aware of the move E5
E6 and Kate where would you like to take
us what C I would like to look around uh
for all the games the women's section so
we have uh por kashian playing Jenny for
you okay ouring interesting idea with C4
here whoa our defending Champion
Jennifer you starting very poorly in the
tournament D2 D3 so this is all standard
stuff everybody plays Bishop C5 these
days B B7 fine C4 now that's way off the
Beaten Track move C4 the idea is to take
the D5 Square firmly under control when
you play the move C4 by the way it means
that you're not playing for C3 and D4
you're basically saying I'm going to
keep my Pawn on e4 well defended so that
the bishop is not going to be active C4
I don't but usually you don't want to
trade your pawns closer to the Center
for those who are further away right but
if black captures on C4 it's also making
a weakness on A6 yeah here I have to
stop and think because I really I'm
really unsure uh on the one hand I want
to make sure that E4 is really Granite
uh as solid as possibly can be so that
this bishop will never interfere on the
other hand if I take with the pawn take
with the bishop then I I'm uh leaving uh
the pawn on D3 is a a backward Pond of
sorts um I'm unfamiliar I'm on
unfamiliar Turf with this move C4 and
I'm really not sure how to recapture
let's let's start with Bishop takes what
how would it Go Kate do you know yeah I
think no I don't know but I think Bishop
take C4 is the idea because I could have
captured a day a move earlier right
instead of castling that would have
forced me to play Bishop takes C4 good
point so I yeah I'm assuming that you're
right that Bishop takes C4 is the idea
and now say I played the move D7 D6 just
protecting the pawn on E5 I wouldn't say
menacing but in some ways the move
Knight A5 will lead to the capture of
the bishop and that usually it's a no no
so I can play A3 to try to hide that
Bishop exactly and let's jump into the
center with the move Knight D4 so the
idea behind the move I just played is
similar to White's Strat
of just taking possession of the uh D5
D4 squ so Knight D4 you're welcome to
take it's not a bad move takes night
here and we're kind of getting a
imbalance where I'm playing for D5 this
bishop on B7 is dormant if I can play
the move D5 and opening open up the
bishop then I feel like I've equalized
so maybe we have to be a little bit more
Cy here yeah but it's definitely
interesting move the C4 just changing
the pawn structure and changing the idea
of the game from C3 D4 to something
completely different exactly uh edicate
me here a little bit on this one
Christian what is the name of the
line that uh we're seeing here in
atusa's game she played the move C4 does
that have a name morphe defense uh of
the arcan
Arch Angels Archangel yeah Archangel
okay so it is okay morphe's defense is
A6 right on move three so it's some sort
of a
hangel C4 line but then the bishop is
not on C5 it's on E7 so it's uh it's a
complete hybrid for sure yeah I don't
think it has a very stable name to be
honest I don't think I've ever seen this
position before I mean I told you I
wasn't on firm ground either I mean I
haven't seen this one before I have to
say and after Knight to C3 uh there is a
big decision that you have to make B4
and allow this Knight to leave for a
very long time on D5 or just simply take
on C4 and at least get some sort of a
compensation for the lack of space for
black you have some action on the B file
this Pawn on C4 maybe it will become
weak later on in the game as well and
you do have some pressure on e4
especially if white recaptures with the
D Pawn for example take you have ideas
of night to A5 Maybe not immediately
because you're losing the pawn on E5 so
it's a very complicated battle by the
way there's only one game that has been
played with a d Tak C4 in this position
and that game continued with Bishop to
C5 it was a game between a wander
langang and Joshua Shen so this position
has been seen but it's not as popular
for sure no it's uh really uh it's so
rare to see such unusual play in A Lopez
because that's
considered the oldest uh most uh
theoretical uh line uh in the world 500
years they've been playing the ru Lopez
let's take a look at the open section
and jump to our tournament leader Mishra
as he's going up against Hans Neeman and
if you had told me before the tournament
that this this game is deciding first
place I would have lost a big bet
uh let's take a look at what's happened
it's a um a Rosal Lio Sicilian with
Bishop B5 um made famous uh by Magnus
Carlson he was playing this against um
um Fabby couldn't think of his name
there for a second wow I mean our
defending Champion you're like what
okay who's that guy uh D2 D4 and this is
actually a very theoretical uh dispute
going on between these two as well and
finally Queen to B6 was played um nimon
actually spent a long time close to 15
minutes to play this move Queen to B6
which
is what was his choice a surprise I have
to say because this is one of the main
lines okay instead of Bishop to E3
sometimes white and actually most of the
times white plays the move Knight B D2
but B E3 is the second most played move
um and it's quite close to Knight B2 so
yeah both players should be very much
within their theoretical knowledge still
in this position Queen to C1 came after
Queen D6 what's the subtlety of playing
Bishop E3 prior to playing Knight
because I would play Knight D2 to get
rid of that Knight I mean this Knight on
e4 bothers me right this is the idea to
get ready for this queen to B6 to defend
with a queen on C1 you don't want to put
the queen on C2 because of Bishop to F5
right you don't want to put the queen on
that Dag so you're making space with
this last move Queen Bishop to E3 go
Queen to C1 and maybe not yet maybe
later on you're going to play either
Knight bd2 but also Knight to A3 in some
instances and especially if you do take
on D4 then I take back and then Knight
comes to C3 so there's that option uh in
the back of my mind as well with the
white pieces it's a wrinkle and
definitely we're going to have to wait
and see whether niman is ready for this
wrinkle all right let's uh continue our
Look Around the Horn for a moment we're
gonna go to the game of
Sam and laner uh we heard from Wesley so
yes the other day Wesley said you know
with the Berlin defense I I need to
learn some new new openings he was
basically saying I'm not getting enough
wins with the black pieces for
forgiveness for playing so many berlins
yeah yeah yeah you know I got to I got
to get uh sharper play right well one
guy who's accomplished that in Spades is
lanir what the heck are we seeing here
lenir Dominguez has got G5 G4 on the
board wow he is attacking with the black
pieces he allowed the capture on G5
yesterday he captured himself with white
on G5 right against darish and was
winning uh in this case E1 last time uh
when he played Fabby he played H6
instead of Castle all the way back right
he played the this exact same position
and he played here H6 and we were
discussing that H6 is against the idea
of Bishop to G5 clear and if you do play
castle then you have to be ready for
this type of expansions well back to the
drawing board he understood that okay I
don't want to be surprised again so I
will play this H6 move right now now
again for me you know already advancing
the pawn Shield is
questionable start stop right there just
a questionable Advance this move G5 but
this advance I find excuse me absolutely
shocking I mean I really wouldn't uh
advise that at all because the move G5
weakens the F5 Square clear so when you
play the move G4 you're actually forcing
me to Target the the weakness in your
Camp which is to play Knight H4 and on a
good day if I could play Knight C2 to E3
and Knight F5 I'm going to win the game
without trying but on the other hand
without G4 you are not allowed to play
Knight H5 that is true right so if you
go Knight H5 right now there is Knight
takes E5 without my Rook on F1 right
there's no Tempo against yeah whereas if
I play G4 okay fair move your knight
then I can play Knight H5 exactly so G4
Knight
H4 Knight H5 is now permitted because
the pawn on G4 but again this bishop on
G3 I it's all yours Kate no I want to
get my queen out maybe Queen G5 G5 okay
fair Knight
E3 and again my my goal is pretty simple
you maybe you should just pull in your
horns a little bit and play a little bit
defensive move Knight e77 yes because
you know what I mean if I get my knight
to F5 I mean wow okay uh before we get
too immersed in this uh coach uh uh
clean clear the cobwebs G5 G4 all
theoretical is well known yes this has
been played before and right now why has
uh a couple of options in fact you don't
have to move the Knight you can just
simply pin this Knight with the move
Bishop to H4 yes this is definitely a
move and now after King to G7 once you
don't even take the Knight you don't
even well you can take the Knight if you
want of course but now I take King to G7
and this allows maybe white will want to
do queen to uh G3 and then um get the
repetition going and perhaps this is
what Sam is thinking as well hey I got
surprised in the opening maybe I want to
go for this
route and by the way we're being alerted
by our producers because they haven't
seen this in uh a decade of doing these
shows lener is actually up on time and
in fact we've seen him time yesterday he
did catch up with uh Dar and that's why
he didn't win that game because he went
down to his last second correct I mean
that was just incredible and right now
Sam is thinking hey I got surprised am I
going to accept the draw play the move
Bishop to H4 and just repeat the
position I have that option but we know
Sam is a fighter he has the white pieces
sure he's on 50% but he wants to win
always with the white pieces so I don't
think we're going to see Bishop H4 so go
ahead and tell us about the the Knight
H4 Knight H4 and as uh isight H5 yes you
have to do this so that you open the
Avenue Knight to C2 and queen to G5 it's
all about reacting on this side as well
because you know what white is going to
try to do white is going to try to go
either D4 try to soften up the center or
ideas of Knight to E3 and as we were
discussing this bishop to H4 I believe
was played commentators
commentators curse you just said Sam's a
great fighter won't go for the early
repetition b h on let's see the players
right now I don't have that move on my
computer screen yet but we have been
told that Bishop to H4 has been played
but you know you have trench reactions
and he seemed like unhappy he was
shaking his hand head and he was it felt
like he made a blunder but maybe he was
just like fighting with himself whether
he wants to go for this drawish
variation or not well it's one of those
things too Kate I mean you experience it
unfortun we all experience it too often
we have our preparation we come to the
game we've got we we're ready to show
our new idea and our prent out prepares
us and we get into a variation we
actually didn't prepare for and then we
want to go
rats bail out and we also remember
tomorrow is a rest day right so Sam saan
has white so maybe he really wishes to
fight but then doesn't know how to how
to continue and just settles for a drawi
varation I think that's what we're
probably going to see
and check the standings Abby Banu in the
leadership position the
14 pH point is for lir and Sam if you
look at their current standings they're
both at 50% one and a half points a
piece they really need a victory right
and so when uh Sam is seeing G5 G4 he's
got a opportunity to go for a full full
uh throated struggle with Knight H4
Knight C2 Knight E3 even though the
engine says it's about balanced right uh
it's a it's a big game it's an important
the problem is linear is blitzing out
his moves it's going to be a
double-edged game if you allow this
Knight H5 Queen G5 I'm going to attack
you on the king side as well exactly so
from a practical perspective I sort of
understand Sam's decision
he got surprised he did not and that's
probably what he was thinking about hey
can I remember those lines right now in
the next few minutes and by the way King
to G7 was played did not take on F3 wow
so you still have the option of
withdrawing with the move Knight to D2
by the way you can also play Knight C2
right now just leave that Knight on F3
I'm pre and say okay come on take it
Knight C2 is a theoretical move as well
you can play the move Knight to C2 as
well and in fact it has been played most
in this position three games with Knight
C2 only one game with Knight to D2
Knight to C2 G takes F3 Queen takes F3
Bishop to E6 and once again you have the
option repetition Queen to G3 King to h8
Queen to F3 back King to G7 because if
you give me too much time what I'm going
to do as black I'm going to play the
move Knight to B8 Knight to D7 and then
I'm going to defend the Knight on F6 and
this is why I have to start with the
move Bishop to E6 first because if you
don't play Bishop to E6 you start with a
move Knight to B8 the problem is after
the move d4 Knight D7 you have some
problems with the F5 Square the bishop
is not out yet he not controlling that
square so now I can just simply go
Knight D3 Knight F5 you're in trouble in
this position so this is the plan you go
Bishop B6 you go Knight B8 you go Knight
D7 if you give me enough time so what
you have to do is immediately give that
check Queen G3 Queen F3 Queen G3 Queen
F3 and just simply make a draw um once
again I'm the materialist on the panel
here I like my pawns I like my Knights I
see the move King G7 and I'm happy to
play the the the single mover Knight to
D2 what happens after Knight to D2 well
Knight D2 now I go Knight to E7 and in
fact this was played as well in a pretty
tough game between ronox sadani and Ivan
chaparo the problem is
with this move Knight to D2 you also
allow me a very quick response Knight E7
and this is very typical in this
position to transfer the knight from C6
where he doesn't do as much to G6
especially right now with this offensive
idea an offensive task that black has
given to himself on the king side push
the pawns try to create something I need
more forces on that side so Knight to E7
Knight G6 the problem once you put the
bishop on H4 Knight G6 comes with tempo
as well so it makes perfect sense and
that's why he played the move King to G7
he's teasing him he's like hey come on
take you know play Knight D2 save your
knight from F3 let's not make a
repetition let's not make a draw let's
keep the game going because uh lir could
have taken on F3 and that would have
been a draw on the Spot close to on the
spot but I bet you dollars to Donuts in
our audience there a lot a lot of people
saying I'm amazed that you would allow
the move Bishop takes F6 and the king is
on F6 yes I know I know and you're
leading with your
chin why not why not but you're telling
me the king is safe actually the king is
safe I have the dark Square control
right now in the absence of the dark
Square Bishop for white I will just
simply go Knight to G6 to defend and
solidify the center and then I will just
I'm one move away from hiding the king
back right you don't have enough black
has a pair of Bishops right so after
King G7 I can play F5 and just just open
up the position that's right the king k
your king is right out there in the
middle of the board again lener is
trying to get a fight and Sam Sean still
has the opportunity to uh not allow him
to get a fight by by playing the move
Knight to C2 and I think after Knight C2
you sort of have to take on F3 finally
right that's what we used to say about
the Hedgehog the Hedgehog was a defense
where you would burrow yourself in and
your opponent would exhaust themselves
trying to engage in a fight with a
hedgehog and by the time you get the
Hedgehog out he's angry ready to fight
and you've exhausted your yourself but
this King on F6 man I'm looking at that
and I'm going wow modern chess
impressive stuff and just to give you an
idea why you have to take on F3 after
the move Knight to C2 it's one of those
options in one of those positions in
which you just simply don't have a good
option at your disposal we were
discussing Knight to E7 was an idea
Bishop to E6 to continue the development
was also an idea the problem is if you
do go Bishop to E6 now I go Knight D2
and unfortunately you don't have this
idea of Knight D7 Knight G6 anymore
because I take I take on E6 and then I
take on G4 right and that's problem yes
I take take take take that's a pawn up
and your king actually doesn't go back
uh to its uh shell anytime soon so this
is problematic that's why after the move
Knight to C2 you sort of have to accept
it take on F3 and make a drw right right
gotcha let's continue our Look Around
the Horn here we're going to go to the
game of Fabby for a moment catch up with
what Fabby and dares are doing again we
see more Joo Pian and that's not the
only one yeah there's another one you
see coming up three out of six Joo pios
today really it's not the Berlin
any it's the New Berlin I want to say
sam Shanklin versus Wesley so a very key
matchup but looking at the position it
looks very balanced to my eyes this uh F
this ending that tan petosan made famous
as black um o Knight takes G6 one the
moment I see Knight takes G6 I don't see
Advantage I I'm surprised that Sam is C
capturing that Bishop because I thought
theight is positioned very well on F4
exactly but the question is what do you
want to do with the bishop on F1 that's
a different matter together right
exactly I guess uh I would probably be
playing Rook to D1 and Bishop to D3 and
trying to provoke a trade of the Bishops
on the D3 square and then enjoy the this
Con disconnected pawns on the king side
right well yeah just the kind of the
double pawns as well as what what you
just described the isolated Pawn on H5
Rook D1 Bishop D3 but Knight takes G6
Pawn takes Bishop D3 well everybody is
playing for F5 as well as king G7 here
Bishops of opposite colors Rooks are
going to come into the center and I
think uh Wesley is going to say I'm
happy about this let's continue our our
uh going around Jeffrey Jeong versus
Andrew Tang this looks like a Catalan a
closed Catalan with an early A5 I used
to like to do this myself I used to play
for A5 B4 B5 pardon me B5 B4 and Bishop
A6 that was my go-to weapon uh as black
in these catalans but Queen
B6 okay that that throws me off why is a
queen good on B6 K I don't really know
this position but you're my top agent in
these matters thinking Andrew is getting
the queen out just getting the queen out
but wow okay uh it does make it awkward
if if I had intended to play Knight D2
and E4 for uh I queen B6 does tickle the
pawn I guess the question is can I play
Knight C3 and play for E2 E4 this way
but then you're not guarding C4 anymore
right that is a good point of course so
you're thinking you could take it take
take okay let me do something a little
bit I I really really do want to get in
E4 and if I do like Knight
G4 are you getting TR
we getting somebody's getting
G5 wow okay we we managed to blow the
game
completely uh open
G5 okay that that that causes me to
clutch my head in despair I don't know
uh G5 you you really threw me off with
that one wow um Queen
B6 strange move also potentially after
capturing that Knight and the Pawn
disappearing from D4 I have Bishop C5
you mean here here takes Knight
G4 E4 Bishop to C5 as well as the move
you rocked me with which was G5 yeah we
saw that in the game pza against Anna
zatonski Y and Anna had also this
pressure on the F2 Pawn exactly Queen B6
not sure I can necessarily refute it
maybe just ask you what it is that
you're doing there let's say I go H3
pull in my horns for just a moment how
does Queen B6 help
you untangle the queen side maybe
thinking about C5 also C5 but not
immediately because I feel the D5 is a
target for you right and I think you're
right first impressions are maybe you're
not so happy comfy after C5 so can I do
A4 yeah and after Knight C3 a
three wow just want to weaken that you
know that's funny because I do like
these types of ideas when this Knight
which is on B8 like if I go B3 here you
want to put your knight on B4 right uh
with the Knight on D7 I'm not sure A3 B3
is is happiness for the uh for for for
Black's position here um Queen B6 threw
me off there Christian I'm not used to
seeing that one uh and we have just one
more game to go leavon Roni and versus
Ray Robson that's the one you were
talking about once again another uh Joko
piano that's another Joko piano but I
have to say I'm drawn to this game
between Mishra and Hans and I will let
you guys go to the leevon game in just a
second but take a look at how this one
developed so I think we left it around
Queen to C1 and if I remember correctly
I've analyzed this position as well he
takes D4 was the right move or at least
the one preferred by the elite level
Grand Masters take on D4 A5 and now we
uh get the idea of why the queen on C1
is nicely placed nevertheless we get
these type of positions in which if I
remember correctly I will go Rook to B8
at the right moment you will go B3 I
will go A4 and slowly slowly things will
pet up into draw yes and the engine is
saying that it's very close to equality
as well at the same time whoever
analyzed this position better will have
the better chances to win it because if
I manage to somehow get a knight on C5
get some pressure on the C file you
still have some structural weaknesses
right and you still have this bishop PA
G7 which for the moment is not playing
an active role so instead of that after
Queen to C1 Hans decides to go C4 now
this is a very risky decision but at the
same time you're keeping the position
very in balanced as well because now as
we can see this Pawn on B2 you know at
some point you will have to go B3 the
structures are changing quite severely
after this one take a look at this
Knight D2 take on D2 Knight D2 Bishop to
F5 B3 finally you have to go B3 and
Bishop to D3 this bishop on D3 doesn't
have any Targets but it controls a lot
of important Square specifically the
square B1 there's no Rook to B1 take
advantage of the B file that's going to
open up in just a second so the bishop
Pawn D3 despite the fact that it looks a
little bit off it does have some active
purposes in the position for
black question is what do you do after
this move H4 which by the way was played
immediately by Mishra Mishra is still in
his opening preparation absolutely crazy
H4 H5 that's what we have right now I'm
seeing only a couple of games I don't
recognize the names which means this is
probably correspondence CH mhm
2400s correspondence shess it seems like
this is something uh very much proposed
and offered by the engines Queen to A3
is a very interesting move now also from
C1 we see another Avenue for this queen
E6 or Rook to E8 these are two moves to
defend the pawn on E7 and they both
create the opportunities for very
interesting play take a look at this if
you go E6 I have this obvious
breakthrough take Tak d right but after
Queen to d8 this is not clear because
once you play the move D5 guess what
your Pawn on E5 is weak also your Pawn
on H4 after the move Queen to d8 is weak
as well so this one is not that clear
Bishop to G5 Queen to D5 I found a very
nice Square for my queen and then we get
into this type of situations you
sacrifice a pawn but you do have a lot
of compensation for it due to the
activity on the dark squares and the
weak King no more Bishop on G7 so your
king is going to get weak I have this
queen may be coming to E7 at the right
moment Rook to E3 Rook to E1 a lot of
opportunities for white definitely full
compensation in this one let's go back
for just a second because there's
another idea in the position what if you
go Rook to E8 right I really like this
move E6 with the same type of idea if
you take now I take and now I go D5 and
I'm going to go for the E6 Pawn I can
also just simply play for Knight to F3
or Bishop to E4 Bishop to F4 Bishop to
E5 positional the idea is to exchange
the dark Square Bishop right if I manage
to do that then I will have a lot of
conversation and I do manage to do that
so right now mishra's thinking seems to
be out of uh his theory at least his
immediate theoretical knowledge but I'm
sure he the way he analyzes this kid I
mean he was like oh Christian turn off
the engine I I need to focus in my
training after the game you know I
finished a six-hour game but I still
have some training back uh at home at my
hotel room with my dad trying to figure
things out trying to figure whether I
actually thought about the right
decisions the Right Moves In the Heat of
the battle so this young man just
incredible he showcases skill in every
single facet of the game the opening the
middle game the end game he's just
simply incredible
wow to talk about the analysis after
game I remember he was telling us during
the US Juniors that once he get back to
the hotel his father picks the critical
positions and he goes over each position
to again figure out what he missed or
where he should have calculated deeper
exactly well I remember what graciella
Casas the famous martial artist said
learn to love the
training and all goals are possible
learn to love the training and all and M
loves you didn't tell me about the
current position H4 by Mishra H5
instantly by Hans nean how is the
computer assessing this one so the
assessment is still very balanced it's a
0.4 with this idea I mean queen to A3 B
takes C4 is also an idea but generally
it's tied to the idea of Queen to A3 so
you will need to develop your queen
there put some pressure on uh the E7
pawn and depending on how black reacts I
have this idea of breaking with taking
on C4 and then D5 but again once you
play that move D5 this bishop wakes up
right so you have to be very very
careful and perhaps this is why Hans
played this idea with C4 he's he wants
to engage in a battle he wants to engage
in an imbalanced position and he's
looking for a fight and I'm sure ABI
Manu is not going to shy away from that
exactly forcibly reminded of the fact
that Nai had that E5 E6 against arena in
today game and I'm looking at that
sacrifice I love that move Queen A3 and
against Rook E8 I love that move that
you flicked in there Christian if you
don't mind putting it on the board again
E6 uh wants more for us if you put Queen
A3 and why is this game uh so important
well it's very important because we have
abanu Mish who is the leader and in Hans
manages to win this game then he's going
to be C with him right of this very
important tournament right H4 H5 and
again I love this move what do you think
about this uh uh cake Queen A3 give me
your Pawn okay Rook E8 uh defends the
pawn right and I hit
[Music]
E6 like just how how this messes uh
black structure up takes takes takes and
Bishop F4 and I'm I'm seeing Knight F3
I'm seeing Knight F3 to G5 and I'm
seeing Rook takes E6 and I would not
want to play this with black but what if
I go with the other Rook to E8 all right
I don't like your Bishop A4 okay the
other Rook to E8 right here Queen A3 the
other Rook to E8 and then another idea
that Christian had was to take and to
flick in the move
D5 and with A7 but E5 will be hanging as
well okay let's do it let's do it takes
takes D5 Queen C7 Queen C Queen C7 you
make me interested in
D6
okay I mean that pawn is marching up the
board uh uh Kade Queen D7 I still see
Bishop
E5 I don't know I I'm I like that guy
that guy and if you is it's up the board
uh Rook E7 it's in your Camp Bishop by
the way Bishop G5 with the idea of
Bishop E7 s might be also attractive
yeah if you have to go F6 that weakens
your position even you don't want to
play F6 I can go Rook E6 Rook to E6
Bishop anchors on E7 yeah I'm just
feeling like I'm having more fun than
you are you're you're just kind of
Defending here but if you go back to the
position here and go all the way back as
Christian described in an earlier
rendition of this um here because E5 is
hanging D5 is hanging and uh but you
also have a couple of Pawns hanging C6
C6 isang A7 so if you want to grab grab
how did a moment ago you showed me a
position where maybe the H4 Pawn was
hanging that's because it was with a
move E6 instead of Rook E8 got so Rook
E8 the reaction was a bit different than
against E6 I gotcha uh double-edged
position to be sure I enjoyed I I think
that this is going to be a great game to
keep our eye on again I just want to go
back to the lady section for just a
second because I was more than curious
to see how Jennifer was going to meet
this Archangel morphe defense uh
position and she did play A2
A3 uh atusa in order to uh preserve her
Bishop Jennifer went right for that line
that we were looking at We we played oh
I think they did it too Knight E2 and I
played
C5 um have they caught up with us by the
way or am I no I I have I think you need
to refresh because there are a couple
more moves gotcha let me just do yes she
didn't play Knight E2 she she played
Knight to
D5 okay Knight to D5 there was a
trade uh I'm reminded of what very
interesting Pawn structure Christian was
telling us about the pawn structure uh
whenever you think about the Joko piano
and you can think about the pawn
structures changing uh okay okay you
tell me who do you like
why I like move Queen G4 here for white
so I'm very happy to get there okay uh
so black turn soop I'll play Bishop F6
Queen G4 and uh they told me that I
should put my Rooks on open files yeah
they told me that as well so Bishop F4
maybe we went to the same school of
Chess uh okay uh I I I spoke about it
earlier this idea of opening up my
Bishop on um B7 I'll play C6 I'll take
the double Pawns in case you want to
capture on
C6 I'm thinking about Queen F yeah no
let's capture let's capture on C6 let's
see capture all right takes I was just
going to play B5 and try to okay I agree
that you have two nice bonds over here
but okay for the moment I've got my Rook
on the open file um maybe I've got
certain ideas of Def maybe bishop to B5
yeah once you manage to play D5 the
Bishop from C4 I don't really know where
I want to have it exactly exactly we'll
keep an eye on that one uh Christian
what has interested you I'm looking at
the game between our leaders in the
ladies section Tois Jova with the black
pieces facing this very vicious early
attack with H4 from Karissa the scotch
very interesting game in this one Knight
to B6 we left it off after this move
Knight to B6 and Kissa decided to go
Knight to
C3 I don't like this move too much
because generally I like to have my
knight on D2 defending this Pawn on C4
also with the Knight on D2 whenever I go
B3 and Bishop to B2 that defends my Pawn
on E5 as well and if I feel like the
Knight on D2 has sort of the same
purpose as a knight on C3 and I still
want to go towards the center right I
can touch that E4 square with either
Knight on D2 or on C3 so I just simply
like that square better Knight to C3 and
at this point Queen to E6 was the best
move in the position in fact giving I
want to say giving black probably an
advantage uh right now because how do
you defend this Pawn on C4 I'm going to
have to play B3 whether I like it one
one day or another but now this is a bit
Pro problematic right because the bishop
hasn't landed on A6 yet right what that
means is that the a file is not
obstructed by the bishop on A6 so I can
go A4 and then this is a big threat
taking on B three your Rook on A1 is not
going to be protected you have to go
Bishop to B2 but that allows me to go
Bishop to B4 follow it up with A3 I have
a lot of play in the position and you
see everything is kind of related to
each other every single move is related
to the previous one Queen to E6 A4
Bishop to B4 because that diagonal has
been opened up so Queen to E6 was the
better move she played Bishop to A6 B3
we have Castle Rook to H three and now
this is a very good
um um example of the ideas that you guys
were discussing at the beginning why do
you play H4 right right well take a look
at this first of all this Rook on H3
nicely protects and is ready to get
included into uh the offensive via the
central E3 square but also protects this
Knight on C3 very nicely also H4 if you
do take the natural take with a queen on
F6 Bishop to G5 finishes the game right
what I'm going to get the exchange and
you were mentioning theas you're saying
this H4 sometimes you have this idea of
Bishop to G5 indeed that's what we have
right
now but take a look at this begum is
like hey I'm not going to accept this
this is a worse end game I have a worse
structure I don't like it I'm going to
go Bishop to B2 long Castle White
doesn't have any problems in the
position right clear that game says no
I'm going to go Queen F7 going to give
you a pawn you want to take my Pawn sure
take my Pawn right I don't think you
want to take that
PA I'm not sure Bishop Rook
E8 D5 D5 that's scary right I wouldn't
touch that pawn on G7 I have to say so I
really like this last move from begim
the engine the engine is still
considering this as a very good position
for white with the move Queen to C2
again it's not obvious not obvious and
I'm sure Queen to C2 is probably not the
only one maybe you can continue the
development not with Bishop to uh B
Because Rook to E8 is going to come and
then you have some problems because and
D5 can be also very uncomfortable so for
example if you do this I have a feeling
Bishop to C5 is coming very dangerous
right very dangerous position for uh
White I I I want to Echo what Kate just
said if you play Bishop B2 and I play D5
oh yes oh yes uh that
you know so much pressure on that pawn
on C4 now we understand why Queen C2 to
get get out of the bishop the range of
the bishop on A6 exactly Queen C2 Queen
to C2 so that D5 you can just simply
take on D5 right I will be happy if we
trade like this because I'm running away
with the King I'm cing it uh to safety
on G1 right right no I'm very happy with
this position so Queen C2 kind of uh s
side steps a couple of
again you cannot take with a queen if
you do take with the pawn then I can
just simply go Bishop to E3 continue my
natural development Bishop to E3
followed by uh long castle and you have
the worst structure in the position as
black now when I see this move I like it
finally enough when you describe Bishop
E3 and long castles as a natural I'm
thinking I don't want to put my king on
the queen
side and walk towards the the king side
with
opportunity as well you can probably do
that as well once again with a bishon to
and potentially some ideas of Rook to E8
and pressuring you on the E file then
maybe at the right moment I will have D5
so you have to pay attention to that but
you you can definitely control the flow
of the game with this move Queen to C2
you have to play this move Queen to C2
is a very important uh redirection of
the pieces exactly and uh let's jump in
a couple of other games Kate where would
you like to take us yeah I wanted to pay
some attention to game esar and Ash
against abrahami and T because I don't
think we really looked at and look it's
a position double edge opposed castling
a French tatev uh one of those players
who have really been loyal to the French
defense I was for a number of years but
I kind of got cured of the French
defense I mean it took a while right uh
Bishop f whoa
A4 okay uh castling on opposite sides of
the board it's very natural for black to
be playing for G5 H5 A4 I was thinking
that white was going to be playing for
B4 I thought that was more topical A4 H6
Knight A3 G5 black has a very direct
plan right very direct to start running
with those pawns ah check this out uh
tat she knows what's coming she knows
that her opponent is preparing night B5
and B4 so she wants to try to keep the
queen side closed but is she going to AC
accomplish her task because or she just
B3 and she just took on B3 and queen
takes B3 or Knight B5
isn't isn't this is not looking good for
getting G getting there first if you
take with the queen can I can I quickly
take the Knight on A3 with the bishop
and then play Knight E S Knight C6 I
don't like giving up the dark Square
Bishop but I'm little terrified I
understand you I was going to recapture
the queen because I didn't think I was
going to break through on B7 but I agree
with you like I don't want you uh having
har yeah harmonic development with
Knight E7 I want to kind of uh cause you
to pause here Queen takes A3 on a good
day F3 Bishop F2 um she's a little slow
with developing the pieces a shria who
needs a comeback uh help us out here
Christian shria who needs to come back
in uh this round four uh she can't go
into the clubhouse dogghouse with an 0
and four she's 0 and3 how is she doing
uh great great yes borderline winning
after Queen to B3 right the engine is
saying that this is more than a point
advantage and what plus 1.2 with the
best moves but it just feels so much
much easier to play for white I have
clear plans I want to go C4 open you up
and then Checkmate you I can always
counter your ideas with H4 with a move
F3 Bishop to F2 and bring another
attacker on this diagonal exactly Knight
to B5 is also a big threat in the
position because you don't want to take
on B5 a takes B5 your A7 Pawn is going
to be in big trouble so right I'm
looking at the position I'm seeing all
these resources that white has at her
disposal and I have to say I mean this
is an opening victory for ashar and
tatev right now not yet in the tank but
she's definitely feeling the pressure so
was C4 a mistake by tatv it just feels C
takes B3 the last move was very very bad
what she had to do was in fact go Knight
to
E7 B takes C4 and just sacrifice the
pawn like this but slow down White's
attack and try to get her own attack
with the move H5 this is not easy to see
H5 sure are you actually going to give
this Pawn as well it seems like that was
direction that she had to take but still
the position remains quite difficult for
black I have to say so taking on B3
Queen takes B3 look it's the French it's
the French it's the French what do you
expect from the French it's it's a
really bad opening it's a very passive
bad opening I mean I I know I'm going to
get a lot of hate for this but the
French is not a good opening don't play
it I said I got cured you thought that
was funny and now he's like reinforcing
it in a worst way is a good opening when
you touch the Eon and you forget to play
e it's a bad opening don't play the
French kids don't
French we are getting ready for a break
and uh about this time uh we check in
with our uh good friends at Q Boutique
to see what they have on special well
check this out this is a walnut wooden
board and it's absolutely stunning it
makes the perfect gift to someone else
or even yourself check this out it's a
board crafted from Walnut it measures 21
in x 21 in with
2.25 in squares and it has unique
rounded Corners displays the laser cut
logos of the World Chess Hall of Fame on
the H1 and a squares as well as those of
the St Louis chess club on the A1 and h8
squares these boards are available at
cutique St louis.com
for all your chess shopping needs and as
we go on break we have a special special
message from the St Louis chess club and
Scholastic Center board of directors
we'll see you on the other side of our
[Music]
break
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless
uh national championships tournaments
for juniors helping gr schools and
they've just grown the game so much
across the United States I think if I
look at my own career and I look at
American chest in general we're in a
much better place than we were 15 years
ago and so the contributions have been
immense and of course it's all thanks to
Dr J singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that s Lu's Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it sense a hope
that the game of chess will always stay
afloat by the mere fact of its existence
I think it it it sends positive waves
across the
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership today the World
Chess Hall of Fame located in the heart
of St Louis's historic Central West End
want to know why chess has intrigued
people around the world for nearly 15 00
years stop by and learn about the impact
of Chess from our three floors
showcasing the art culture and history
of the game the World Chess Hall of Fame
has something for everyone to enjoy for
more information on current exhibits
please visit World Chess h.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from grandmas
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Poli Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the worldclass
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall full of Fame it also plays host to
an award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit St
Louis chess club.org to claim your
membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chest
piece sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you or a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit worldes
h.org
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
show after three rounds Kate just tell
us about the standings yes we have two
leaders in the women's section Karis and
beim to here Jova so far having a very
nice tournament both having two and a
half points out of three with uh three
players uh plus one uh Arena Anna and
Nazi and in the open section tell with
this sensation going on there Kate we
have a soul leader very young 14 years
year old Grandmaster abiman Mishra two
and a half points out of three and uh we
have very special guests in studio very
pleased s Sal welcome welcome so nice to
have you aboard s you are contemporary
Bobby fiser you have so many marvelous
stories now president of the Marshall
chess Foundation introduce yourself to
our audience and and we can't help but
ask about Bobby fiser stories please uh
take it away uh as yasta said my name is
Sal Mata I'm the uh I'm a vice president
of the Marshall chess club and a
president of the Marshall chess
Foundation um a little bit later we'll
talk about the uh the Fisher archives um
sure um yes I knew Bobby many many times
he was taught he was always at Jack
Collins's house right so many times I
would just go to the house and usually
about 10 or 11 o'clock at night Bobby
would show up because that was he was
sleeping all day those were his hours
those were his hours he actually uh went
he would when I won the US junior he
went over all the games um and I
remember there was one I was very very
proud of and he just sort of looked at
me said you don't really have really
have very much here do
you
okay but he was always spoton and very
very quickly understood what was
happening the downside of analyzing with
a genius right S I mean my goodness it
was amazing yes yeah and you had this
really nice story just a moment ago
you're telling me about pal benko who
was a candidate Master at the time
trying to teach Bobby that the Bon was
unplayable tell our audience that worked
out so actually this was the last round
of the uh the US Junior Chess
Championship which I won um and luckily
I was I managed to get one and a half
points ahead of brown in the bol of
brown in the last round um and we got to
a very very complicated position I was
the white side of the bononi um
obviously Brown is is black uh he's
dying to beat me um and I come to a
point where I'm looking at this very
complex move and I can't really
calculate it to the end but my gut is
saying that's the right move right um
and among other things it probably it
might have gotten Walter into time
pressure which he loves which he always
was getting into and just at the moment
I was about to make the move Bobby fiser
walks in because he used to attend the
US Juniors you know continuously and I
just froze and I played some general
move and Walter just crushed me
immediately okay on the afterwards we it
was held in the in chess club which was
in the Henry Hudson Hotel we all Walter
and I went thinking we were going to
have our postmortem right to look at
your game and we sat down and
immediately B and fiser pushed us aside
boo took the white side which was my
side um uh Bobby took the the black side
because of course he loved to play the
Bon and they just started analyzing this
game Brown and I were now Irrelevant for
the whole the whole
circumstance and it was just amazing
because it was one of the first times
this is a candidate a two two time
candidate he was a seriously strong
player right right and no matter what he
did did to try to control Bobby right
he's trying to be you know the great
strategist and you know control the
board etc etc he couldn't control him
fiser was just always find incredible
counterplay uh and it was just like
really amaz and brown and I just sort of
looked at each other because we' seen
none of this stuff um and but I think we
afterwards we talked about it said you
know there are Grand Masters and then
there's this guy Bobby fiser and there's
something different there something
special there and I think we even said
this is probably a world what a world
champion is like how old was Bobby at
this time
what years I was te 16 in 67 so he was
born in
43 6 I can't do the
math 20 something right I gotcha um but
oh well I mean just this idea that you
were around this Legend and saw him
growing up today you are uh president of
the Marshall foundation and you came
across a lot of materials that Regina
his mom
had kept tell us and where did they end
up where are they today so well the tars
um uh Russell and Regina uh Bobby's
sister had um they donated Joan sorry
yes uh donated 20 to 25 boxes full of uh
original score sheets um carbon copies
of course because that's what we all had
we didn't have those um the AR Arbiters
took away our Originals why yeah the G
of his of his first book Bobby Fisher's
games of Chess uh many many photographs
correspondents etc etc and they donated
it to the Marshall chess Foundation
because they wanted to have a tax
deductible donation which they did uh it
sat there actually arrived in 2008 which
was the year that Bobby died at the age
of 64 which as you know is symbolically
important to chess players um and
nothing happened with it and um I'm
suddenly the president of the Marshall
chess foundation and I thought it was
very very important to to get this sold
um and initially it was well let's see
if we can get some money for it and I I
went to um auction houses and try to
contact private people and then at some
point I I was thinking about it going
wait a minute this is Bobby fiser okay
this is the most important stuff in the
world um for chess players and I didn't
want to see a diaspora cuz the the um
the auction house started talking about
oh we sell it in Lots I said what's that
oh we private and put it in sh you'll
get you'll get the she's for 59 and blah
blah blah I said that's wrong so I got
in touch with um Shannon Bailey of the
World Chess Hall of Fame and I said I
think this is the place this belongs you
need this and um after a lot of
negotiation and discussion you know we
we we worked out a deal right and
literally two days ago John Donaldson
was here and he and I were pouring over
the collection and and helping to
catalog it which exactly you need chess
players to be able to do it so I'm very
very happy about that cuz I feel it's
found a home it's found a home it's
found the right home um so I'm I'm
delighted just a second you're telling
me that boxes and boxes of Bobby Fisher
training games have been uncovered on
Earth so these are score sheets that's
nobody beside yourself and John have
seen in ages there are about 14 or 15
that no one has ever seen wow okay so
what I'm hoping it's also interesting
because you look at the games and let's
say they're late 57 and in about a month
he's going to win the US champ
Championship right and he's up a pawn
and a rook and pawn ending and can't
convert it and you sit there go what
happened in that very short period of
time he just went from he figured it out
right somehow he understood chess and
then he won the US championship and a
year later he was a candidate in you
know he was just amazing yeah a lot of
this just very interesting so how did he
go from there to here um in such a short
period of Time how do you do it I don't
know come
on I had to secret I wouldn't be here
dude you're on the show for a reason we
brought you we thought you were a
specialist I don't yeah it's remarkable
it's inred yeah it really is it's like a
genius just suddenly blond he's got it
that's it um so it was very very
exciting so anyway um I'm very happy to
have done that Christian you've got an
opportunity to ask uh Bobby Fisher
stories and what it was like growing up
in New York uh with inter I'm sure we
will hear a lot about that but I do want
to ask you about some the players in
this Championship specifically our
leader right now abanu Mishra is there
do you see any similarities between
himself and Bobby uh actually
yesterday's game I was very impressed uh
that he was Ray Robson against that that
it was everybody the three of you were
trying to figure out what was going on
exactly with the engine with the engine
and and I thought that you know he just
seems to have an incredible ability to
play in very complicated positions I I
get the prep ation but what I'm
impressed with even more is just the
overboard over theboard capability of of
playing such a complicated game and and
queen d8 rookie 7 he understood where he
had to place his pieces to meet the
requirements of the position just
incredible it was very very impressive
um s I'm gonna put you on the spot right
here right now I'm going to bring up the
game uh of Mishra today because it's a
very complicated position as we were
coming into our studios here here he is
he's white he's up against um Hans
Neiman and the last few moves were this
whole ideas that we had seen Queen A3
putting pressure on uh whoops I think
was not play you wanted to play yeah I
think actually this is our analysis let
me uh Let me refresh the board for just
a moment and this is what happened not
what we were looking at Bishop G5 Rook
E8 takes takes Knight E4 take it away
what is going on
and would you ever yes exactly dude
we're putting you in the hot seat I'm
I'm looking to take a
break well it's oh he took he already
yes so we're going to see Rook takes
E4 uh well I think if I were black I
would not be happy about the broken Pawn
structure true um and I think that's a
good I I like the idea of Rook B8 cuz
otherwise Rook B1 would have been very
strong and wasn't that Queen just on A3
a move or two ago trying to put it there
that was our analysis the queen uh slid
over to cwan earlier in the game and we
were looking at ideas of Queen A3 in
order to Target this Pawn on E6 you may
you mentioned the double pawns but this
uh control of the B
file just your evaluation uh would you
rather play black or rather play White
I'd rather play white but I think black
has a lot of counterplay here U and I
think Queen A3 is not a move because of
Queen B2 at this point exactly Queen A3
Queen B2 trading the Queens seems to
help only uh Black's cause and playing
something like Rook e 2
looks okay little okay it's okay just
like but then maybe I don't know C5 I
feel at some point maybe it's going to
turn into an okay you get my Pawn on A2
something like Queen to E3 you go Queen
B2 I move the Rook back without the Rook
on E2 I don't like this mean like Rook
B8 Queen let say queen E3 right Queen B2
you go Queen B2 I move my Rook you take
my Pawn on A2 and then I start an attack
on the king side with G4 I I I feel
that's going to be the race that we're
going to see right absolutely I I'm not
sure you actually answer the question as
MRE did you do you recognize greatness
in Mishra as well well this is the first
time I've really followed his games
closely and and live as a whole
different feeling you really start to
understand what what people are doing I
I was very impressed with yesterday's
game absolutely and I have a question so
you were a US Junior Champion you played
in the US championships how does it feel
to be here today to analyze in this
studio to see how you know the Hall of
Fame how the playing Hall where their
players are playing well I think it's
fantastic I mean it's just it's one of
the reasons I came to St Louis one was
to to help John with the archive with
the archive but a lot of it was just
first of all to see the St Louis chess
scene uh and to also attend um in
a modern US champion mod us Championship
right do you miss playing this
tournament sure sure I'll I'll tell you
one last memory um which is again of
Bobby I mean you this is very very
sophisticated the setup you have here
and I'm sure you know that when Bobby
was playing we had no such thing of
course so what they had is the play The
Players would be playing and then uh
there would be large demonstration
boards behind them the audience is out
there so they could follow the games um
and I worked the wallboard so I was able
to to work one of Bob I'm a yes
absolutely so I actually U was was the
the guy who was following fish's moves
and relaying them and well putting them
up on the board um and he was this was
the I can't remember which US
Championship it was but he was had been
playing only the Kings Indian uh which
we were talking about yesterday with
Carissa etc etc and all of a sudden he
started playing the nimzo Indian uh
which nobody had seen before with the
the old that special line where quick B6
Bishop A6 right um um and he was black
against Sadi of course STI I think was
completely taken aback that he was not
prepared to the teeth for the king's
Indian and uh and there was a point
where Bobby it was I'm probably an
expert at this point I'm going well he
could probably do that but sacrifices an
exchange of some compensation of course
he plays it and just crushes Sadi I was
very impressed it was sort of nice to
make you know be the person who was like
making those moves on the board
pretending it was
me that was my idea I thought of that
yeah good work Bobby so thank you so
much for coming it was great to have you
with us today absolutely thank you so
much me too and I also just want to say
one last thing the three of you do a
wonderful job oh you're only saying that
cuz it's true yes it's true it's
wonderful it's great thank you so much
thank you very much and here don't can't
go away okay uh here we got the pairings
uh to show you uh everybody so we have
asaran playing Abraham asaran is looking
for that lucky break and she has a very
good position so far then this very
important match two leaders in the
women's section Yip playing toir janova
then cantes playing Lee bashian playing
you another really important match up
the former US Women's Champions playing
each other P against crush and then
zatonski playing Yen and in the open the
pairings for round four for that of it
so here we have Karana playing sh savian
playing Dominguez maybe we will see a
here uh we will take a look at it after
shangan playing saw and then a very
important matchup the leader in the open
section Mishra playing neimand then we
have aronian playing Robson who is a
little bit struggling so far in the
tournament and then Jeong playing tank
nice nice pairings and Christian uh take
us to where the action is well the
action at least right now the way I look
at it is in the ladies section Karissa
versus tokira the battle of the two
leaders co-leaders going into today's
round take a look at this I think we
left it after the move F6 e takes F6 and
we saw this move Queen to F7 and we were
saying we like this Pawn sacrifice it's
a good Pawn sacrifice it creates a lot
of chaos a lot of havoc in the position
and take a look at this queen to C2 was
the right move we were discussing this
it wasn't an easy decision right she
played the move Bishop to B2 which in my
estimation is the most natural move you
just want to go Castle hide the king
keep the queen on E2 for the moment but
it's not a good move specifically
because you can go right now D5 that was
the move that scared us forget about
taking on F6 we understood that you
don't have to do this anytime soon sure
allow white to take on G7 activate your
pieces and actually that's going to give
you more than enough compensation but
what you can do is D5 and this move was
appearing in a lot of our variations the
one that we were looking at right and it
creates a lot of tension right now you
need to sacrifice that pawn somehow as
White Queen to C2 is one way I'm looking
at Castle as well but do you want to go
castle and after G takes F6 always look
at ideas and always have to be careful
about ideas with Bishop to H6 check it
just doesn't feel like you have that
much time to hide your king so this one
is a very very complex battle but I have
to say after this move Bishop to B2 if
to here Jova plays the move D5 she's in
in po position to take the advantage in
this one forget about what the engine is
saying 0 0 0 it doesn't matter it's just
easier to play in my estimation for
black did she play the move D5 it
doesn't seem like she did move no he she
played Rook E8 Rook E8 which is a very
attractive move as well because Rook E3
is forced think Bishop C5 yes and you
know you can't take on E8 you're
probably going to take on G7 I probably
have to take on G7 in fact I think I'm
forced to take on G7 because again you
cannot take on E8 Rook takes C8 just
finishes the game clear Knight to E4
unfortunately that's not going to stay
there for a long time and I can just
kick you with the move Bishop to B4
force you to go King to D1 lose the
right to Castle and now D5 just finishes
the job no no no we got to take on G7
right so Bishop to C5 has to be played
take on G7 right and then there's this
crazy calculation I get the two Queens
on the board you take on F2 right King
D2 you take on H eight and now we have
at this position Knight to E4 hold on I
take on on on h8 or I include Queen F4
check if you want to yeah I want I
wanted to Queen F4 check now take now
you take but now I have this move Queen
E4 don't take because
I I was going to go rook f8 and I wasn't
sure in that position Bishop C5 is on
the board guys so now we're seeing a
very forced sequence of
moves this one this is where the action
is at this particular moment G7 has to
happen right there is no alternative no
no she has to go and and probably that's
what she calculated when she Let's uh
take a look at how much time did she
spend for this move Bishop to B2 1 hour
and 13 minutes one hour so 13 minutes
spend on this move Bishop to B2 she
definitely had to calculate this rookie
eight because it's the most forced line
right uh another another look see uh
Rook E8 Rook E3 Bishop C5 which is on
the board take on G7 yes and now none of
this bishop takes E3 business R G8 right
yes Rook G8 now I go Rook takes C8 and
this is actually not good Rook takes and
now Knight to
E4 in fact this is more or less easy to
see right because there's still this
Pawn on G7 I solidify my situation with
F3 and you don't have D5 why not Bishop
B4 check and then D5 right but don't I
have Queen G4 ah Queen G4 yes Queen G4
is the winning King and then Knight to F
Knight to F6 you can give me a check but
there's not much more than that it's
just a check just a check scenario can I
just bail out with B8 in Long Castle I
mean G8 and long Castle I just force The
Rook to go away from the e file but G8 I
can take with the queen right hold on
show show show the viewers what you're
talking about show show show the viewers
so if we move back MH yeah so what do
you do after F G7 do you go this move
yes Rook G8 Knight take take Knight E4
no instead of Knight E4 I thought G8 but
you're right no knight4 is winning kn4
is completely winning right now just
winning for white because G8 Queen takes
G8 but it looks I mean we're going under
D5 yeah yeah Queen takes G8 just yeah I
forgot you can capture with Queen H no
but not she's probably not going to do
this so so the idea is you should take
on G7 take on E
right and let's follow that line One
More Time by the way this is not easy to
calculate at all seriously so I'm
wondering what happens if you go King to
D1 so King to D2 is the engine proposed
move but what if you go King to D1 well
now I have to take the queen and at
least to my eyes this does feel a little
bit more natural for white because with
the move King to D2 you have to contend
with ideas of Queen F4 check which is
there's an extra check that you have to
calculate right you get to this position
and most of the times you're going to go
King to D1 W very quickly but with King
D2 you have the option to play Rook D1
that's right that's right that's right
but here Knight E4 is the tempo you hit
the Rook you hit the bishop and I'm
assuming as white you want to bail out
how do you bail out I don't know I just
said you want to ba so if you take take
the sounds great right right this is not
that good and my guess is that with a
king on D2 you can already go to C3 I'm
not losing a pawn you're not losing the
pawn right you can go to C3 which is a
much better version because look the
King on C3 doesn't look great right but
you don't have any big checks at least
not immediately so that's why we go into
that position with the move King to D2
but that's not easy to see I have to say
who do you guys prefer in this position
as this particular moment I like ban
because I thought her King was really
nicely insulated on C8 and I thought
that White's King whether on E1 or D1 in
the variations you just showed was a
Target right yeah I feel the play for
black is much easier right I know I want
to do D5 I want to finish my development
by the way Carissa thinking over this
very key moment but we don't see a
better move than F6 thinking maybe she
wants to go Knight E4 but Knight E4 I
take you take on G7 the problem is I
take on F2 first and you take I take on4
that's a check right and this is not
good this is not good news I mean she's
calculating it almost for sure but there
just simply too much you go Bishop D3 I
can go Rook F4 Rook E7 sacrifice the
rook and that's going to be a piece up
for black exactly no this is not looking
good she is forced right now to take on
G7 we're going to have to wait and see
whether she's actually going to do it I
like this whole line of beam's F6
approach she sacrific the pawn she sees
the initiative very aggressive uh I did
like also D5 too I have to admit I think
that for black Bon's problem was both
Rook E8 as well as D5 were moves that
you know right you like want to make
them I I worked with uh beum as a
commentator and I have to say she loves
the initiative yeah she give her the
attack and
she's and she's got what she wants let's
turn our attention to the game of Nasi
and Arena because that was another
Marquee matchup coming into today's uh
pairings and uh we left it uh earlier
than this but let's play catchup F7 F6
Bishop takes F6 and uh well what do you
think uh Pawn is a little delayed but IR
is quick with targeting the D4 Pawn
right Rook A8 is coming up pretty
natural uh pressure that she has against
this Pawn again I always say that uh
what you want is your fair share the
center effective uh peace development
these pieces look pretty reasonable and
a safe King and I think both players
have accomplished that and so a more or
less uh balanced position going on here
another important game with lots of uh
implications for the tournament is the
game between Anna zatonski and ruang Yan
Anna uh just a half a point behind our
tournament leader she's enjoying a a I
want to say strategic Victory out of the
opening as uh Black's Queens sight ponds
are split meaning that just a little bit
weaker uh it's a technical position some
some types of position I think Anna just
plays incredibly well I wouldn't want to
give her a technical position right and
look at time she has 51 minutes that's a
lot of time for Anna exactly uh she uh
loves to get into time trouble
especially in chaotic positions she's
got the type of position right now where
she feels good so that's a a game to
keep our eye on and tell us about Sam SE
Sam seon and lanir that was that Bishop
H4 crazy game that big option to uh
potentially make the draw right with
move Knight to C2 or
not he decides to not do it he goes for
this move Knight to B5 this is a
completely different approach because
right now in a lot of variations we were
looking at this idea of knight2 Knight
E3 Knight F5 that was the big problem uh
that black had to face in this instances
right now I can just simply go Bishop to
B6 which he did and if you do go Knight
to D2 right now Knight to E7 and the
Knight on B5 why did we put it there
it's really not well placed not only
because he doesn't do anything it
doesn't come to E3 to go to F5 and
support the attack but also it will get
hit with C6 C6 followed by D5 and this
is not looking good for white in fact
it's close to losing so what he did was
after Bishop to B6 D4 now this forces me
to take on F3 right I cannot wait
anymore the pressure the tension is too
high in the position you are starting to
threaten to take on E5 I have to do
something I have to take on F3 you have
no you have no Knight E7 mov no more
knight7 exactly because of the tension
in the center right right uh infused by
the last move d4 so this is the position
that we currently have but what if I
start getting ready with the move Rook
to a G8 ready for what ready to get this
Rook somehow to G6 like for example if
you try to go into that sequence of
drawish ideas Queen G3 Queen to F3
that's not happening anymore now you
have Rook to G6 now you're in trouble
right what if I never move the queen
away from F3 exactly I just play Rook ad
D1 H3 and I wait exactly yes and this is
probably what he wants to do my guess is
that he wants to go Rook to D1 now okay
I see the move A4 but I like Queen to E7
to my eyes this is the most natural move
get out of Dodge on the D file I don't
even know what A4 is actually doing in
the position Knight
A5 yes but it's a silly looking move a
silly looking move when when The Rook
comes to D1 and you start seeing D takes
E5 ideas you put the queen on E7 right
but but this is the problem that I'm
having for Sam in this position how do
you continue well well exactly uh I've
got a Pinn piece the the Knight on F6 I
got my Bishop I got my queen but how do
I put more pressure on the F6 Square I
want to play F4 and I want my Rook on
the f file and by the way how do I do
that again my idea is to go Knight B8
Knight D7 right or even Knight to d8
Knight to E6 if I manage to land a
knight on G5 then your PIN is over right
right and the game is over because so
let's go H3 okay I just want to control
G4 and see what you can do
knight8 is silly okay let's go Knight d8
right Knight d8 or Knight B8 whichever
the problem with Knight d8 is that you
stop me with a move D5 and I'm not sure
how to assess this position let's go
Knight d8 or Bishop to D7 which one
Knight B8 okay I sort of like this move
Knight to B8 right right is a typical
plan so for white how do we put more
pressure on F6 good
question I see the engine likes to take
on E5 I'm not sure exactly why take take
tick take
yeah wow now we know why because we were
looking at ideas of how do we put more
pressure on E5 that's that's on F6 I
mean and but you can also take with the
queen right Queen takes Knight D4 and
now Knight to C6 again still a very
complex position mhm and by the way all
right we have time we're the
commentators let's see why this A4 mov
is so good right let's try to understand
why the engine really loves this move A4
so I want to start G4 I want to try G4
King H1 Rook G1 and just open up the
king side Knight A5 seems to be a very
very good move right now very potent
especially coupl with the C6 and then
Bishop d8 okay now we understand
triggered A4 Knight A5 C6 and get this
bishop to d8 to cancel this pin then I'm
going to go Queen to E8 cancel the pin
and that's going to be G over but
Christian do you have time for C6
because I have intermediate move D takes
E5 so let's go Bishop F1 okay C6 D takes
E5 D takes C5 good move take a knight D6
that's a big difference at least you're
not C7 I force you to either F5 I
thought I would be happy here yes yes
but now I take takes Queen takes well
you kind of have to go Queen because if
you take with the pawn then I can just
simply go King H7 right Queen E6 but now
queen6
yeah I'm just too slow like well by a
Tempo because you were about to play
Rook D7 which would have been a killing
move uh you you only missed it by a temp
just to uh just to show it to everybody
because I think if you go B5 let's say
Rook e eight right or B5 yeah B5 to to
cement the Knight on c47 very nice right
right but this is not easy again this is
not easy to calculate and that's why Sam
play the move Knight B5 because he looks
at the position and he sees Dominguez
struggling to find these ideas but if he
does understand this a495 C6 is a really
beautiful idea I have to say but it's
also an engine generated idea right
right I don't know how much time
Dominguez spent analyzing these
positions analyzing and understanding
the maneuvering ideas to get away from
this piit yeah G5 G4 uh before we jump
to the ladies I just wanted to go to the
game of Sam Shanklin and Wesley so
because again those uh those two uh very
very important game for our tournament
again tomorrow will be a free day
everybody and well when we left it it
was a Balan position and I don't think
anything changed uh uh Kate my first
impression though is I would love as
white to get a minor piece endgame only
I would love to I don't know how I'm
going to trade Rooks I'm say because I
do see this Pawn on H5 and it's a a
Perpetual Target or long-term Target for
the bishop means your king the black
king will have to remain on the king
side would you call this a balanced
position how would you describe every
time you have a bishop you like that you
can create attack on one side and be
defending on the other side while the
Knight needs to decide is the Knight
going to be defending or is the Knight
going to be attacking so I understand
the idea of trading the Rooks but also
we have to see that it's a bad Bishop
right the h8 square is dark right so if
we trade the pawns if I play G4 I'm not
queening my Pawn right exactly uh let's
jump to the ladies and uh when we left
at ashria we thought was in the driver's
seat against tatv uh let's pick up the
action there
where that's NY uh here it is uh we
thought that ashria is about to play uh
moves like C3 C4 breaking open the C
file Knight B5 and we thought tatf was
in trouble Bishop C5 C4 well
what's better than getting one of those
in getting them both in she got in C4 as
well as Knight B5 Bishop takes he takes
and this open C file this looks great
and the light Square Bishop on E2 is
going to land on F3 that's going to be
another amazing diagonal yes from F3 to
B8 this looks okay but uh now now that
we're here uh would you get would would
you play for A5 A6 would you play for
Queen F3 Bishop F3 take us through your
th thought process we both agree that
ashri has uh got a great attacking uh
position Brewing do you do you change
direction because I'm one of those Pawn
grubbers I think about moves like Bishop
uh C4 all the time I'm thinking about
like Rook fc1 Rook fc1 I'm going to get
developing the r getting it on the file
pinning the bishop I got to get out of
Dodge King B8 no question okay now again
are you playing for B6 you're playing
for A5 A6 you're trying to go Bishop F3
what if I play Rook C4 with the idea to
play Rook C1 oh boy oh boy well I I have
to I have to close my eyes and hope my
development is by the way you are giving
up Pawn on H5 how do you feel about I
feel terribly terribly uh gate you know
me but let's not capture it because
there are some tricky stuff with Knight
F5 so Rook ac1 I yikes yikes yikes okay
well you're forcing me to back off I
mean there's nothing I can do I don't
want to play B6 exposing my king I don't
really even want to play Rook C8 because
then I'm afraid something bad is going
to happen along the SE file I'll play
Bishop B6 and again I'm just hanging on
by my fingernails here yeah but you're
at least I'm hang kind of surviving
still yes I wish I had the A5 Pawn there
but then okay what you do here right cuz
if I go Queen A2 you're going to play
Bishop A5 right correct Queen A2 you
have a nasty threat of A4 A5 I will
blockade you so you're you may be
helping me with that Tempo I don't know
it's not that clear honestly what to do
here because I don't have time for F3 to
get the bishop to F2 because there is
this discovered attack right F3 the
desirable Bishop F2 as you just
pointed out D3 check is okay I think
doubling the Rooks may be too slow right
so let's go with your A5 just
immediately A5 and again I again I'm
closing my eyes I'm not walking I am not
going to the queen king site it's way
too slow I have to make a stand on this
hill the queen side but I feel like it's
going to be like a
Civ and for both ladies this is so
crucial because again ashria is very
very unfortunately is sitting with three
losses going into a rest day and T had a
very difficult loss yesterday against
beim to Jova she had a much better
position at one moment then she
blundered and she lost that game exactly
and going into that game of yesterday
she was tight for first so uh this is a
big game for both of those uh players we
talk about confidence momentum but this
one uh I was going to say for me I I
really like this move Bishop to C4
because why I I wanted to be able to
play F3 and Bishop here and if I play
the the desirable F4 let's just say I am
walking into a discovered Checker clear
right so if I get the bishop out of the
way Bishop to C4 I get you to play a
move like Rook E8 right right because I
don't want to play Rook H6 to block
forever the Knight on G8 exactly now I
can play F3 and or F4 with more or less
uh Carey uh Grace can also play this A6
uh B6 ideas but I do like very much this
idea pardon me I I think I actually
prefer F4 crazily enough and by the way
just to mention the life position that
we see right there is not correct or
quite a few moves back no no a lot of
things have happened after tell tell
what happened we did have Rook C1 well
we see a different position there's a
Pawn on A4 nothing has been actually
exchanged so that's very very yes yes
we're up to Rook fc1 was played and I do
believe your
inner and to be honest this looks really
good I mean take a look at this if you
go King to B8 we should probably have to
right yeah yeah can I start with B6
let's let's have a look see I mean I
really want to just Checkmate you to and
blow up in the position blow up the
position Che a takes B I get you no A5
that's it you're just having way too
much fun and Bishop takes B6 A5 right
yes and let's go back and now is it time
for the simple simple chess I think I
think it's time yes for simple chess
where well I still have Rook H7 to
cover and to to to to stop my Rook take
C5 business Rook B1 and I don't know if
Bishop takes B7 and Rook takes C5 is
that threatening but I like the why
something is coming something is coming
uncomfortable I like the sacrifice me
too me too by the way let's just go back
for a second so Bishop F3 Rook H7 what
if I what if I focus on the bishop Pawn
C5 so Bishop F3 Rook H7 that's fine
Bishop F3 Rook F7 F yeah that's fine
okay looks more or less natural indeed
what if I go Queen B5 I really want to
focus on that Bishop on C5 tickle the
bishop yeah yeah and Rook C8
C
box box so now I I do have the option of
taking on B7 and taking on C5 if I want
right but I don't think I want I I like
it when you just keep all the tension in
the position you know moves like Rook B8
because you are threatening Bishop takes
B7 maybe retreating the queen that's
right A7 A6 gets nasty I mean that for
Knight on G8 is so much out of play we
really need the Knight on D5 or
somewhere you know when I see these
positions and I'm on the black side I
think to myself oh dear I'm going to
appear in a book on brilliancies and I'm
going to be on the wrong side of the
book that's what happens that's what
happens when you play the
French right Christian what's happening
in the open section with Mishra
absolutely let's uh take a look at what
happened in the last few moves I think
we left it with S as well after the move
Rook A8 to B8 and he said he didn't like
this move Rook to E2 a bit too passive
but this is what Mishra decided do again
wanted to stop Queen B2 right right
right but he didn't like it s didn't
like it because it was too passive and
was giving maybe black a couple of
tempies in the process we were
discussing ideas of Queen to F1 or queen
to E3 and then G4 at the right moment it
was a battle between okay sure you're
going to take my A2 pawn and you're
going to have a very dangerous weapon on
the a file but at the same time am I
checkmating you first because I do have
a lot of weapons around your king as
well right Queen E3 G4 Rook takes G4 H5
at right he didn't want to be looking at
all of those stuff he didn't want to
calculate that he wants to keep the
tension in the position and he played
the move Rook to E2 Queen to A5 Queen to
E3 now G4 is a bit more tricky uh
because there's no more Rook on e4
there's no more uh resources around the
black king queen to D5 and I do get to
set up this defense Rook A1 and queen to
E6 at a moment I want to play E6 E5 E6
so Queen E6 stops not only that but to
be honest after you play the move E6
you're also opening up my Bishop right
so I do have to be careful I E6 F5
followed by C5 opening up the bishop I
have to be careful from a strategical
point of view so that's why probably he
hesitated playing the move E6 and
finally H said okay enough is enough I'm
not going to let you're not playing E6
okay we're done with that move uh but at
the same time with the last move Queen
to E6 year old so allowing me to go to
Queen to E4 and improve even further the
position and the quality of my pieces
the quality of my queen at the same time
not only that I'm very centralized but I
also start having ideas of Rook to B1
the fight for the B file the only open
file in the position in fact is
extremely important so I think Queen to
E4 to my eyes at least it looks very
natural well the quality of the Queen's
definitely favoring white and you know
the property of the queen is not a good
blockader it's not a good blockader but
in this particular position Rook B5 go
ahead you want to go Rook to B5 you want
to fight with the move right we talk
about the B5 being important so let's
bring both of the Rooks there and I
think in the end I will still have to go
towards the same idea G G yes yes all
right Rook eb8 Rook
E8 m that's fine you get to B2 but I
have this nice connection of these Rooks
which protects me quite nicely it's like
a wall if you don't mind me asking whose
King are you exposing Rook to B2 good
question I mean my Rook is on the second
let go somewh King G2 or King H2 maybe
just in time because I was I was about
to play Queen H3 uh before you play King
H2 so oh boy uh okay I'm still wrapping
my head around the position
F6 yeah F6 Bishop to C1 seems to be
already good for white um wow Bishop C1
yeah I would assume I'm getting first on
the G file so you're right you're right
take take you take but now to G2 is no
no no no you you got the G file first I
agreed so what if I'm a little bit more
patient then I play A5 instead of F6 and
we do have by the way Queen to E4 now my
question is can I go Queen
D5 Queen D5 yeah just say that okay do
you want to draw dude you're boring I
know so you want to allow me to play E6
if I want to at the yeah if you allow me
to exchange the Queens maybe Queen D5 I
go E6 E6
F5 this was my question because we
didn't really get a chance to answer or
F6 first and then F5 I'm not sure okay
let's let's think about it maybe F6
first but F6 I have Queen takes G6 E5
how is
that I think that's I'm with Kate on
this one you might be
wi you're on your own Chris all
right forget about it forget about
forget about it forget about it queen
queen F7 check and Rook takes G5 it's
all white White's having fun yes but
what you said this
ending uh after F5 I I wasn't going to
go into the ending by the way I was
thinking about Queen to G3 and Bishop F4
I was trying to get a temp
Against The Rook as well as the G6 Pawn
uh fun fun fun game here going on good
absolutely good tension and I wanted I
mean Ray Robson we talked about ashria
having her troubles let's just take a
look at the game between leavon aronian
and Ray Robson both of these men coming
into this competition full of ambition
uh we do have an
equal uh material at the moment but I'm
the position actually I'm kind of liking
what I'm seeing from Ray's side right
because black can double up his Rooks on
file and put more pressure on that F2
Pawn isn't that kind of easy to do by
the way Bishop E4 followed by Rook F7
Rook F6 and the other Rook comes over
well Bishop before Rook E3 like at some
point I will stop you on that diagonal
with this Rook E3 F3 right and F3 but
why do you need Bishop E4 I don't know I
don't know uh all right so Rook F7 well
the problem was I I I didn't want to see
King H1 and F3 so that was why I moved
my Bishop
first uh and maybe bishop E4 is the
wrong Square maybe I should be going
Bishop to G6 just so that you can't you
know if you got to go Rook E2 and I can
go Rook F6 and you got to go Rook now
that um how do you say now that pawn is
uh meets constant protection
and and uh as we look at our standings
we can see that both players are really
looking for a victory in this game draws
don't help Kate yeah leevon had the
shortest game probably ever at the US
championships I think only eight moves
yesterday making a draw and Ray uh yeah
he lost a very difficult gameer three
draws for leavon by no means is he out
of it there's a lot a lot of games to go
but at a certain moment you just just
got to make your mark you got to say Hey
you know you got to win some games in
for Ray robs and he just wants to get
back into the tournament to feel his
confidence again uh in this game between
leavon and Ray I would just think that
black is for Choice a little bit even
though it's not much uh Christian no
there's nothing here and definitely
black is not for choice not for choice
this is just equal but but why just call
a spade a spade this is completely equal
because after Bishop G6 you wouldn't
find it more practical okay but maybe I
can even start invading you right now
well our idea was to go Rook F6 and Rook
f8 okay but can I just defend that at
some point and Bishop H5 was our idea be
careful Queen G5 Queen G5 right now you
have to go yeah no I I wanted to no and
this is my aggressive stance this is my
aggressive stance I can also take like a
much more passive stance let's say
Bishop to G6 Brook to E3 right right why
Rook F6 Rook E1 Rook f8 now I can go F3
right King H1 next and that's it
basically we go into this position
exactly or queen to F2 we exchange
everything yeah no that looks uh really
really dryw it's going to be a draw no
way any of the sides are going to make
any inroads but take a look at this Sean
once again has the opportunity to go
Queen G3 Queen F3 because after G takes
F3 Queen takes F3 not Rook to G8 to get
ready for all this setup with Rook to G6
which was the right way of doing it and
it would have created quite some
problems for white but Queen to E7 he
played now again if seian wants he's got
the repetition he can go into the
repetition yes will he continue will he
try even more in this position to
continue this
game that's the question I don't think
you have again you can go Rook ad D1
right but that's going to allow Rook to
G8 right I'm trying to see other ideas
but I don't see them well you cannot
take on E5 because of Knight takes E5
right like Rook ad D1 Rook D3 maybe on a
good day I can transfer my queen yes
Rook a rook D1 Rook D3 Queen G3 Rook
let's try now again I will go Rook G
that's my plan right Rook to D3 again we
know the plan right it's silly but we
know it
and let's say if I make a normal move
Bishop to D7 okay how do you continue I
like H3 I just want to control the G4
Square all right let's go Rook
A8 looks so strange also unclear what
probably I just have to uh do Knight d8
at some point right and put everything
on that side first so King H1
G4 but
maybe the Thing Once you play G4 you no
longer have any checks on this side
right
again at some point I will have to go
this stupid A4 I might have to play A2
A4 I really have to play this move A4 so
that I you go Knight A5 C6 Bishop d8
Christian Kate we're in break territory
and as we go on break Sabina caught up
with some of the ladies and asked them
the importance of St Louis chess club
and Scholastic Center for their careers
uh take a listen and we'll see you on
the other side of our
break
the St Lou chess club is celebrating its
15th year anniversary tell me a little
bit about its impact in the United
States and do you have any favorite
moments uh yes certainly so St Louis
chess club has become our home for
professional chess players all the
biggest events are held here and um it
certainly is my second home I have a lot
of random memories uh I think one of the
biggest ones was uh finishing US
championships last year and I was
surrounded by a lot of friends and
family and it was just like really
special um really special moments it
definitely has brought the rise of
American chess I remember my first
championship here in
2014 and that's probably one of my most
memorable memories especially my first
game here and I just love coming back to
St Louis and playing so they really did
a great job with American CH I don't
have a lot of experience here but uh I
heard a lot of good things about St
Louis chess club the impact that uh St
Louis chess club had on like kids
education and I know that a lot of like
Grand Masters come here like every month
yeah the St Louis chess club has had a
huge impact on chess in the US I
remember when I was playing in the US
Championship prior to when it moved to
the St Louis chess club and um I do
appreciate that the US Championship was
still being held but it wasn't as
prestigious as it is now the price fund
was lowerer we're playing two rounds a
day so I feel like it has elevated chess
uh to a new level especially women's
chair uh uh I'm very happy to come to St
Louis every year and even a couple times
in a year yes American chess was
completely different I moved to United
States in 2002 and there's I cannot even
compare like chess situation in now and
back in those years and main reason why
I'm still playing at St Louis because
I'm the oldest participant already for
many years and it's keep me motivated
and it's
really it's really nice that we have
this opportunity to play us Championship
it's such a nice place and that we have
so many good tournament I think that the
impact it has is huge on us chess for
people both who are watching the games
um of Chess and the players who are up
and coming um I think the thing that
chess club provides young players with a
lot of great opportunities and I'm
really happy that it's the 15th
anniversary um and I hope that uh the
same L just will continue to have these
amazing tournaments well U my favorite
memory about it is when I came
2021 for the US Champs held the CH with
me and then the whole experience is
wonderful St Louis chesa really did a
great job in promoting chess in general
in the US but especially for women's
chess you know I grew up playing in the
US championship you know my first time I
was like 133 now I'm 21 so um I think
it's done a lot especially for girls
chest because it's been you know
something I returned to multiple times
every year for like the last 8 years so
yeah like I don't know where I would be
in chess or like in general if it wasn't
for a s L's chess club the club has done
so much for chess here in America and
it's been such a long time I don't
remember when like I can't remember a
time like before seeing Louis um here
you know I remember like growing up
watching all the broadcasts on like
YouTube following along us Champs and
stuff and was always like the highlight
of my my day back when I was a kid yeah
well the St Louis chess club has had has
had such an amazing impact on American
chess I mean it seems like it just got
better and better every year gave so
many opportunities to players um and
certainly it's like it's a motivating
thing for me as a chess player like the
level the number high quality events
that we're having here you know kind of
um gives you a chance to really stay as
a professional player in terms of
memories here I mean in a way they all
fade into each other right CU you just
come here like year after year numerous
times I mean it feels like home for me
um any place that I look at I'll think
oh yeah I remember I was really sad
after this game and I went to sit in
that place in Forest Park you know so I
have memories like that but I'll tell
you something funny like recently um
Tony Rich the director of the club he he
was talking about the memories that he
had and he's like I remember at the very
beginning I saw Arena Crush in her cool
leather jacket and I was like yeah why
don't I wear that anymore so I'm back to
wearing the leather
[Music]
jackets yeah um it's amazing what the
club has done for chess in general
because I mean it's already been 15
years and they've done countless uh
national championships tournaments for
juniors helping gr schools and they've
just grown the game so much across the
United States I think if I look at my
own career and I look at American chest
in general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr Jun
singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that s Lu CH Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that that it's it's there it is
there it will be there I think it's
sense a hope that the game of chess will
always stay Float by the mere fact of
its existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly nearly 1500 years
stop by and learn about the impact of
Chess from our three floors showcasing
the art culture and history of the game
the World Chess Hall of Fame has
something for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Ken sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the worldclass
St Louis chess club and the world Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q bouti stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world World thanks to co-founders Dr
Jeanie Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield
the St Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures
weekly tournaments merchandise discounts
and so much more visit St Louis chess
club.org to claim your membership
today welcome back everyone as we are in
the throws of round four and it's been a
very exciting round just to take a quick
look at the standings coming into
today's competition uh we'll start with
ladies yes we have two leaders here
Karis beim to here janova having a very
good start to the tournament with two
and a half points out of three the one
who is not having a good start is is
ashita esan but he has she has some
chances in today's round and in the open
section the standings there because we
have a sensation
Brewing we have abim Manuel Mishra who
is the sole leader of the open section
with two and a half points out of three
absolutely unexpected performance so far
he's got a big game uh with Hans Neiman
in this round four that we've been
keeping an eye on and I was looking as
we were coming in from the break uh we
were looking at this move A6 by ashria
in her game with tatv and after A6 I
thought well B6 was going to be just
automatically played for sure uh tat did
not she went Knight F5 looking for some
complications exactly and I was we were
just having a little brief uh about a
there a takes
D3 Bishop F3 Knight takes G3 and we're
looking at this move B6 which I thought
was a real real visual the whole idea of
course is if you play Bishop takes B6
Queen takes B6 Rook A8 mate and she
didn't play that shria retreated her
Bishop but did you see a defense because
I didn't see the defense I not sure if
there isn't
defense uh 92 Che back my intention was
to move my king actually and if you take
my Rook my intention was to go Rook
takes and please take my queen so then I
am in the brilliancy books after you
take my queen I've got Rook A8 did a
shria miss a a chance for immortality uh
Christian or was it just a
fleeting
uh yeah the situation is not looking
that good anymore um I was looking
through some of the lines she played
Bishop H2 but in that position first of
all B6 here was was very strong yes yes
really really strong because if the best
move is to go Knight to H6 and allow the
opening of all these files after A7
fantastic not looking good you're going
to lose this one so B6 huge missed
opportunity she played the move A5 and
now finally tatv is getting a couple of
Moves In to try to get her attack going
as well with the move Knight to H6 and
something happening on on the king side
Knight to F5 Bishop to H2 this is what
we have right now G4 was played at least
the position is opening for tatev as
well on the king side right so this is a
good sign apologies instead of Bishop H2
if we could have gone a takes B7 because
Kate and I were entertaining ourselves
with the move a takes takes B7 D3 we
thought Bishop F3 Knight takes
G3
a second taking away my pH wait a second
yes sir no no no I see what you have in
mind but no I'm not going to let you do
that ah D2 I didn't see important
forcing The Rook to go away here and now
I'm actually not going to take the
bishon G3 but in fact I'm going to go
Knight to D4 no that messes me all up no
no no no I was I was on a different
track all together and I'm taking on F3
I get my Rook to f8 H4 your F2 is
hanging as well no that wasn't where I
was going no no didn't like that so this
is what we currently have on the board
uh Bishop to D3 seems to be the best
move not an easy one because again
you're allowing G takes H3 and things of
that nature how can I not be playing A6
takes B7 I want to open up the queen
side yeah the problem is again this D3
look you have time to do that you have
time to open up the king side the queen
side I'm anxious to do that you are
anxious and I understand that but I have
ideas of a rook takes C5 right so this
is pretty nice if you do go B6 because
you take I take on E6 this bishop is uh
opening up as well even the board is
getting confused excited yeah what's
happening here uh also with this
diagonal opened up if I manage to get
the queen to E4 start threatening
checkmates it's over right so you have
to be very careful this is a good
sacrifice and this gives white the
decisive Advantage but take a look at
what happened in this one Kissa versus
beim well actually a lot of things have
happened so we left it off somewhere
around after Queen to F3 and we were
saying that D5 is a very strong move yes
in fact I want you to take on F6 because
after d takes C4 The Rook is coming to
d8 your king is not safe right this is
looking really bad for Karissa for the
white pieces she did not play that she
missed a bit with a move Rook to f8 King
to C2 D5
and now a very strong move would have
been
A3 whoa not you cannot take because of
Queen to F5 then I take on B4 and you
cannot recap recapture that because you
have some problems uh with the bishop on
A6 for example take take take I can take
on A6 and C5 next discover check yeah
this is looking really
good but she did not play that and by
the way after A3 if you do go Bishop to
E7 then I can just simply go back to uh
D2 and this allows me to control uh the
queen side like such she played C takes
D5 Bishop takes F1 Rook takes F1 take on
D5 Queen to F5 this is what we have King
is going to go to B7 we're expecting
King B7 right if you go Queen D7 then I
take take maybe you know what maybe she
will be um looking at this line because
you take you take with the Knight you
cannot take on six right this is a very
tempting transition as well for begim I
have to say well I'm looking at the
structure and it it's not a structure
I'd want to play forget about it she
played King to B7 she's keeping the
Queens on the board she wants to
Checkmate she's aggressive she's an
attacker but how easy is this I don't
know what if I just go either Knight to
C3 or maybe even again this move A3 I
really want to kick this bishop away mhm
so maybe A3 what do you okay you you you
kick me away Bishop E7 let's go Bishop
to E7 and now I go Knight to
C3 and you're not worried about A4 well
the thing is you're not a pawn up right
so the pawns are equal right now uh for
whatever reason I felt that black is a
pawn up but she's not pawns are equal
and whose King is weaker right now I was
thinking whites H I'm just worried about
the pawn structure honestly the pawn on
F6 is kind of really annoying for black
well I always have Queen G6 as a way of
curing my structure right I do queen G6
yeah but I was thinking that if I could
play moves like well no I wanted to keep
the Queens for a moment uh Christian yes
and I was thinking by the way Knight G3
was played wow that but in the position
we just had a moment ago if you go back
to the night on
C3 I was thinking that on a good day I
really want to play A4 with the idea
that if you take B let's just say ba for
just a moment uh a future D4 like Rook
d8 C5 D4 and my queen my queen nicely on
F7 is ready to uh Le like I go Rook d8
here
so D4 and then my queen could go to A2 I
don't know and I was kind of hoping that
I get an attack going but you might and
maybe that's what she's looking at the
Knight went to G3 though Knight to G3
and queen to E6 seven is what we have on
the board now is looking at Queen she's
still got the A4 in her pocket to to pry
open the queen she could have played A4
in this position yeah immediately right
that was an option for sure I don't like
this Knight on G3 for Karissa it doesn't
seem like it has a great future right in
the position like where are you going to
H5 to start hunting pawns you're going
to get M on the other side right so
don't do that I felt like she had to
stay around her King with the Knight on
C3 A3 followed by Knight to C3 right now
the trend of uh the position is
definitely in Blacks favor cool Kate
where would you like to take us I want
to take a look at alysis Lee and Talia
Cervantes game okay and uh our pick and
a lot of people thought that uh Alice Le
was coming in as a favorite into this
event she starts with two losses in a
single draw how's she doing what's going
on let's take a look so we were so she
did recapture with the E Pawn by the way
on D5 we were looking at a lot of
variations if it was recaptured by the
other side not the common uh uh
imbalance of two Knights versus two
Bishops but when I look at those Cavalry
on protected Outpost E4 and C4 I like
such Knights Knights right if you have a
pair of Bishops you want to open up the
position but this position is kind of
closed by the way uh I see uh Alice's
last move Queen E6 as Open Season Rook
takes H3 I mean that sacrifice is very
inviting I it's not even a sacrifice
it's a cruncher uh Rook takes H3 and I
think Talia is not a happy camper here
because you can really push H4 right
that would be something you would like
to just move the pawn away so you cannot
capture it but G5 is coming up yeah uh
by the way we haven't been discussing
I'm not looking myself at winning an
exchange I I can play Knight D2 forking
the queen and Rook but at this moment
I'm with you I want to pursue the
kingside attack uh with G5 I like
Alice's position very very much also in
these positions I remember I had a a
very nice
um uh sequence of sacrifices on G3 and
Knight takes G3 Queen takes E3 against
arianto utat grandm from Indonesia
uh we played a very nice match in
Jakarta I loved visiting Indonesia this
night on e4 is not easy to get rid of
you don't want to play F3 and Talia
certainly doesn't want to play Bishop
takes E4 I'm really curious what white
can do actually here to stop me from
yeah just breaking through right H4 G5
looks really really good for Alice and
back over to you uh Christian what's
caught your eye I'm still trying to uh
see exactly what's happening in the open
section and this game between Fabiano we
haven't looked at in somehow in quite a
while against Darius Z the only thing
I'm
seeing as an imbalance in the position
is the time 40 minutes for Fabby only 19
minutes for Darius with a lot of moves
to go still 18 moves to go but the
position is looking really good for
Darius this was a joke of piano I think
we left it somewhere all the way here
after the move B3 and we were trying to
understand what each and every side is
trying to do and let's take a look at
what happened Bishop takes D7 Knight
takes D7 I do like this move Knight to
B8 by
Darius and I do like the move Bishop
takes E3 as well because this Knight was
coming to F5 I don't want to see a
knight next to my king I don't want to
deal with ideas of D4 later on hitting
the Bish Pawn C5 this was a good trade
not an easy one to do for Darius because
you're giving giv up your Bishop you're
allowing me to stay uh with dominant
dark Square Bishop on the board as white
but it's very much tied to the next move
which is D5 you have to play the move D5
otherwise I'm just simply going to go C4
myself stop you from going D5 and then
at the right moment I'm going to go D4
open up the center and that's going to
give my Bishop dominance in the position
so you have to start First Strike first
with a move D5 and he did C5 to to stop
me once again from going D4 and this is
what we have right
now this is an interesting one because
Fabiano knows he's not better at this
point he understands that I you don't
have space there's absolutely no reasons
in the position why white would be
better but it's still a game it's still
a maneuvering game you still can ask and
pose some questions and some problems to
your opponent and that's what he's going
to try to do that's a very similar thing
to what happened in last year's
championship if I'm not
mistaken Darius got a very good position
also with the black pieces but later on
in the game due to the time trouble
situation he made some big big mistakes
he had a great position all throughout
the game so this is the strategy that
Fabiano seems to have been employing
against Darius take him to those last
final minutes and try to complicate
matters at that point I think that's
what a lot of players try to do against
lanir de inz the problem is when lanir
is in time trouble he plays really
really well I just was checking out the
game of Jennifer U our defending
Champion she's up against atusa that was
a very uh awkward Pawn structure for
both players but the reason why I was
attract my ey was attracted to this
particular position is because I like
Jennifer's last move Queen A8 and in my
eye what I foresaw was the move Rook A5
and I don't necessarily want to play
Bishop takes D5 I actually want to play
Rook takes D5 sacrifice saf an exchange
yeah it's not much of a sacrifice it's
easy when you see the pawn on G2 so
atusa's got to be aware that that uh is
on her opponent's agenda if you don't
mind tell me about the Mishra game
because that Hans Neeman Mishra oh I
don't mind that all yes got I was just
about to tell you about that game of
course do it a lot of things have
happened actually we left it off after
Queen to E4 and we were discussing ideas
of G4 F3 and G4 or Rook to B1 to fight
for the B file and he understood Hans
that there's a fight going on on the B
file and that's why I'm getting ready to
double up with Rook to B8 Rook to B5
also potentially setting up this idea of
C5 or queen to D5 F3 Queen D5 Queen to
F4 shying away for uh from the queen
trade right the problem is that right
now this is a very well-timed break
with a move C5 it's all about activating
the bishop right let's take a look take
on C5 Queen takes C5 Queen to E3 that's
what we have right now in the position
but that's a success for Hans I mean
it's looking so much better than it
looked a few moves ago there's no attack
on this side the double pawns have been
removed my Bishop is right now maybe the
preferable Bishop in the position right
now because I have some targets along
this diagonal C3 E5 a lot of ideas in
the position position and if you go
Queen to C7 okay I understand if you
take on E3 this is probably going to be
a draw I'm going to take on E3 I'm going
to attack this Pawn on C4 with a move
Rook to
E4 the material is limited there's no
reason why black is much better in this
position but what if I keep the Queens
on the board right Queen C7 what if I go
Queen to C7 yes I have ideas first of
all Rook to C8 was
played so if I take on then take on E7
you take on E5 I think this is what he
wants and he's saying that this position
oh no no I should play A4 first I no A4
Rook B7 right I wanted to put your Rook
on A5 and get the position with my
Bishop on E7 okay you can play this but
I'm actually wondering what's happening
in this one yes Bishop takes Rook takes
C3 why the engine saying that this is so
much better for black C3 C3 is hanging
and this is the reason I mean this end
game is that much better well it's just
I guess King G7 by the way H4 is also
weak I could go Bop G3 you lot3 bishop7
and then Bishop so these are the two
weaknesses you have two weaknesses and
you're not going to be able to defend
all of them that's a very interesting
situation also there is potential to
bring the king to B5 and then play A5
yes yes I think it I think it's more
severe than that just that final
position if you don't mind uh uh if I go
Bishop to G3 instead of King G7 Bishop
to G3 and if you go Bishop to E7 I was
going to go F5 my next move is going to
be king F7 and Bishop back to E5 right I
still have this I'm still surviving
somehow but yes I understand what you're
saying yeah you can't keep everything
tight you have to be a bit precise but
definitely this black who has great
chances to win this one to Res G so Rook
to C8 I guess Hans is actually better
right now right with black pieces the
position has completely switched flipped
over on its head from a not a winning
Advantage but but better Advantage a
pretty significant Advantage for white
for Mishra out of the opening right
right now it is Hans who has the
advantage and will try to squeeze
everything out of this position yeah
very important game because Hans nean
can catch up with abim Manuel Mishra if
he manages to win this game absolutely
and as you look at you see that game
between Wesley so and Sam Shanklin now
that's been a balanced Affair throughout
but again that's a that's a game uh
where I really think that uh we've got
to keep an eye on that one I've got to
got to go to the uh open section I
apologize we may see a three four
repetition in Sean Dominguez
game all right I sorry I was just kind
of mesmerized by this uh trying to take
stock of this ending now we were
thinking that it was been a very
balanced Affair for some time between
Sam and Wesley but this last movie
check Sam is clearly targeting this Pawn
on H5 and he does want to play the move
Rook H6 if allowed I guess you have to
play King G7 and just uh just go with
the flow here for a moment this Knight
on C5 is doing a terrific job at uh
covering D7 protecting B7 and I guess
it's okay for Wesley this this feels
like white should be better Kate but
maybe it's not it's better because white
is targeting the pawn on H5 right right
if that pawn was on H6 I think things
are very much different yeah then
there's nothing to worry about okay well
keep an eye on this one and back over to
youis breaking news guys remember when T
was lost yes that's not the case anymore
she's completely winning right now no
way take a look at this switcher Ro H4 h
G4 and queen to E4 huge blunder no she
played Queen D3 to blockade the pawn
exactly why continue with Queen to E4 D3
came on the board that immediately
played by tat what an opportunity for
tatel and she took it and right now I
mean G3 don't go G3 isn't this game over
absolutely I mean I I understand you
take and I cannot take back because you
get checkmated but I can take on D3
first you take on D3 now I take on C5 I
can even take on F2 first you don't even
why you Bishop by the way Rook takes C5
was played on the board oh this is what
she missed Rook to
D4 and this is over that's an easy move
to miss I know but okay Rook to D4 is
the fancy way but can I just take on E2
isn't this completely winning as well
now well well now you don't have the G3
I drop back with the Rook right you have
to drop back with a rook but then I go
Rook to h8 and I uh win like this I have
a checkmating threat so if you take on
E2 Queen H7 or queen to H4 and there's
no way to defend against it so that's
one way but Rook to D4 that's a
beautiful one if she finds this move
Rook to D4 I think this is pretty much
game over wow kind of traing the queen
in the center she has to you can take
right this this take on E2 you have to
go back to C1 and now I go Rook to d8
how do you stop Rook to D1 you don't m
that's it that's it game over painful
painful I have to say asita I mean whoa
she's not finding her footing in this
tournament W this is brutal thing about
Chess right one move here Queen E4
completely changes the whole evaluation
of the game oh my goodness and I think
she had those moments where she could
have also played Rook takes C5 and queen
takes E6 sacrifice The Exchange she's
definitely better what about our
tournament leaders in the uh open
section uh between Carissa and mean the
l section sorry with the lady section
Carissa and Bon yeah not that much has
happened so well we saw the Knight go to
G3 which we didn't like this is where we
left it Queen to D3 now I finally
understand there is a knight coming to
F5 so you sto me and now F4 and Rook to
G8 was
played of course if you take I take on
G2 that's the idea right I take on G2
then maybe I go Queen to E four and this
is not looking like a good end game all
my pieces are much more active the
Knight coming to D5 supporting the push
of e3 not looking at that rate okay but
you can start with this move King to B1
first
right and then Rook to C1 and then at
the right moment I will take on F5 so
Kissa seems to be back in the game at
least still a very complex battle
balanced position uh completely crazy it
doesn't look very
classic um but uh yeah it does seem like
the game has more or less from an
objective point of view even out so uh
just help me out here Christian and King
B1 is on the board by the way uh as as
prescribed Queen takes H4 Knight takes
F5 Queen
H2 uh I'm trying to play Rook takes G2
you have to play G3 my Queen's broken
through but you have to connect the Rook
Rook e maybe I can stop you ah okay I A3
Queen C2 I st I was about to go Rook
takes E5 and queen B2 M Queen C2 stops
so for example if I do something like
this Rook takes C5 that's game over
right y oops because of Queen to B2 so
yeah no Queen again it's this one is
going to uh be decided by the time only
12 minutes for beg him and 40 minutes
again this is a battle between two
players that almost never get in time
trouble right but be him right now is
closer to that time trouble situation
and that might be problematic as we
enter the final moves before the time
control speaking of time control
whenever you say time control uh my mind
is alerted to lanir Dominguez uh what's
happening in that time control I see
Sean is only is still trying to figure
out whether he's going to take the draw
or not it's funny because lener at this
point after Queen F3 Queen G3 Queen F3
he thought for a while and he played the
move King to G6 so he switching things
up a little bit I'm not really sure why
well I kind of understand because Bishop
takes F6 with the King on G7 was coming
with the temple but at the same time
with a king on G7 after the move Rook to
G8 you could hide on f8 you no longer
have that opportunity in this situation
so so now the whole ideas of H3 become a
little bit more attractive H2 H3 because
qu G3 was played let's uh interesting
enough he played Queen G3 because he
could have claimed a let's let's let's
go there let's go there they're looking
for it okay there we go and we do have
our first result with King to H7 I'm
going to repeat the position three times
let's shake
heads Frank Guadalupe is looking at his
score sheet is going to check with the
computer whether the position has
repeated three times and will confirm or
deny whether this is a
draw I think it's going to be a
draw I also see it's actually the fourth
time right fourth time kage no third
time okay that actually happened in the
zit up uh anat Kpop
versus uh um John uh vanderville they
played four times the Knight G5 in the
zit Rook f8 Knight F3 neither player
made a draw and then they
played it was like no problem with the
move King H7 I Pro a draw and shakes all
around draw um perm handshakes all
around Talia is permitted Alice to play
the move that we just thought could not
be it's just unacceptable Rook takes H3
but Alice resisted and she did not go
for that Rook take H3 sacrifice how do
you resist how do you well she went for
uh exch oh but let's take a look she had
played the move Queen E6 and boy if
that's not a telegraph of the intentions
I don't know what is Bishop C5 and Alice
could resist everything except
Temptation she went for the exchange
Rook takes
H3 um wow that just well speaks for
itself doesn't
it to borrow a stealing lineer a turn of
phrase I mean Rook T she didn't do it
let's see what she did she played Knight
D2 Queen B4 takes Bishop takes we're up
to date with the players and for Talia
maybe there's some relief here in this
position because she does at least have
ideas of Bishop takes A7 A6 I don't know
if they're but can I capture on H3 right
now yes that's I do want to double up
the Rooks and Checkmate on H1 I don't
blame you one a small little bit uh I
really don't want to take that Rook but
what am I what else am I supposed to do
takes takes queen I'm going to try to
crash through with my queen on B7 and I
thought playing B6 I thought B5 B5 even
B5 that's CU if you capture then I get
my other Rook to h8 and I don't see you
stopping that Checkmate okay let's see I
go check King to B King to D7 and now I
start looking
around promote to night but then King E6
and I am escaping you are indeed that
looks really really good
with uh one result in the book we can
just see the standings now as uh we have
a draw right we have a draw not much has
changed for it in the leadings of this
open section we still have ABI Manu
Mishra with two and a half points um
leading the tournament exactly Christian
to you did tatev spot that move Rook D4
of course she did yes yes she did Rook
to D4 is on the board Queen takes B7
we're going to see a quick sequence of
moves so maybe we can pan out to that
game because after d takes E2 Rook C1
Rook d8 it's resignation time right that
pawn on E2 is absolutely a monster
you're not in time unfortunately you're
not in time to stop me from playing Rook
to D1 and promoting that pawn and giving
a Checkmate exactly yes adding insult to
injury it is a Checkmate because the
bishop is actually on H2 and this is the
moment where we expect tatf to play Rook
to d8 yes followed by Rook to D1 and if
we do this it doesn't help at all we're
ready to play Rook takes A1 and there no
there's no stopping the
promotion and forri oh my gosh that's
just such a blow uh she got a good
position I mean she got a winning
position and that your move B B5 B6 just
uh uh sacrificing Pond to open up the
position was
so natural actually I I I just don't
know what to say d8 sometimes when you
have a bad tournament it just it all
goes wrong completely everything goes
wrong you have just no confidence and
it's so easy to make mistakes in those
critical moments everything spirals out
of control it's all about
momentum I'm so proud to talk about my
winning streaks I'm less proud to talk
about my losing streaks and the worst I
ever had had it happened to me one time
I actually lost three games in a row and
I thought the world had turned upside
down that happens to Great yes or I lost
three games in a row and the rules of
physics had changed on me how do you
deal with that I didn't deal well I
actually had a flu at the time I didn't
realize it at the time I just felt
miserable but I had a flu not as an
excuse but I just wanted to say that
once again it was just like a loss of
confidence and it's like what do I do
for this next game because you know I
was losing winning positions right not
as badly as Sha but today she'll really
like H she'll feel terrible yeah I
remember me having a bad tournament and
then very quickly playing another one
hoping I can rebounds and play well
right you want to get back and it was
terrible it went even I lost the first
round I think I lost the second round
and then I was like what am I doing and
I remember the third round I also lost
and my coach was like you are winning
there completely and I was like I
thought I was losing since the beginning
and I was just completely off with my
assessment because I just had no
confidence whatsoever indeed indeed and
it can go real wrong and after this move
Rook d8 ashri is looking at the uh
tatters of her position because earlier
yeah she she will regret and we just saw
thought they take a seep of water oh no
not the water we know what that means
what do water torture um back to be him
for a moment uh what's going on in their
game I think we should stay with this
one just because I feel we're going to
see a resignation and if we don't see a
resignation in the next minute maybe we
can move away but perhaps she will try
to continue with Rook to E1 it's just so
hopeless right but I remember yesterday
ashita was playing a really long game
even with three pawns down against an
Queen down this is a queen coming to E1
and you cannot stop it actually exactly
this is the current position I was
saying that even in case
you could play the move Rook E1 in
anticipation hoping that you could get
F3 King F2 and Rook D1 is coming
regardless yeah this is just Unstoppable
I was for for a moment there I was even
looking at uh the attempt of trading
Rooks doesn't help at all Rook C8 check
King takes B7 and again Rook D1 is is
killing it yes no absolutely um um okay
she doesn't seem to be
very eager to uh finish the game so
perhaps we can move on she has 36
minutes I think she's going to take time
this is still a US Championship you
don't want to resign prematurely maybe
there is you know a crazy move that can
save
something we're gonna keep an eye on it
and we'll go to a guest in studio Chris
over to you well let's see who the guest
is because I all right we have Sam Sean
in the studio Sam first of all uh a
difficult game out of the opening he
seemed to know the opening better uh
than you and then you decided to
sacrifice you went for this Knight to B5
tell us a bit about uh the story of that
decision yeah so he played this very
interesting line with Bishop A7 and G4
and I felt if I don't play Bishop H4 he
has very comfortable position after
Knight H5 Queen G5 so I tried to make
this bishop H4 Knight B5 work for a long
time mhm uh I mean if I if I don't make
it work I think he goes uh like Knight
D2 Knight E7 and then Knight G6 that's
right and I have I have to give my dark
C Bishop so I think this works out but
you can go Knight to H4 Knight to H4 is
another move in this position Knight to
H4 okay yeah right Knight H4 but then
you know Knight H5 comes
and Knight H5 exactly yeah yeah that's
why I thought Bishop H4 is very
interesting uh but I'm not sure it leads
to anything from the way he played King
G7 that
five Knight to B5 is the novelty and we
were looking at some ideas for black to
try to uh keep his extra piece in the
position one of them was this after
Queen sorry not uh Queen to E7 Rook to
G8 was an option did you spot this one
what was your I mean Rook to G8 I play
Rook a D1 let's say right and now Queen
to E7 I have to go Queen E7 yeah I
thought we could get this position the
game I could have played on after Queen
E7 with Rook ad D1 and then he plays
Rook G8 I I think I have to play
something like H3 here or Rook D3 maybe
Rook D3 let's try Rook D3 Rook to D3 I
think what the the engine was always
trying to get was ideas of
A4 Knight A5 followed by C6 and Bishop
to
d8 Ah that's a very very nice idea yes
and if H3 is it the same uh idea the
same idea pretty much in every single
position yes this A4
uhuh and he's just saying that white
doesn't have a way to break through to
get to that KN on yeah basically my
position is extremely nice that he's in
an eternal pin but uh I I don't have the
Breakthrough like if you go back a few
moves uh if he doesn't play Rook G8 mhm
I mean we can look at the game so Queen
E7 yes check
F3 he went for Ken G6 and uh yeah I went
for pral after King G6 if I play Rook ad
D1 here MH
um he goes Rook G8
yes I think logically a H3 again mhm or
yeah H3 yeah and this position he just
stays in this A4 he is very strong with
Knight A5 I
mean yeah that's the key idea but we
were really trying not to make this move
because it's such a crazy move yeah it's
completely on the other side of the
board you're just saying that okay you
don't have another resource coming
against uh that Knight on F6 so I'm just
simply going to do whatever I want on
this side A4 Knight A5 it doesn't come
to your mind right right right right so
I wonder if he plays Bishop D7 instead
of A4 and then I play A4 what's the
right yeah yeah this is probably the
best way to do it yeah I I think the the
problem for me is how do I get F4 in
because let's say King G7 Rook D3 Rook a
E8 I guess makes sense sure
I just don't really know what to do so
King H1 just keep waiting I think you're
not doing anything and he's not doing
anything either it's kind of like a
stand still there was uh we were
analyzing after the game there was a
very interesting idea so if you go to
the final position Rook ad D1 instead of
a Perpetual so King G6 Rook a D1 Queen
F3 King G6 Rook a D1 if you play Knight
ba uh right away yes I can play D Tak E5
yes yes I'm not saying I have to here
but there's always this idea of playing
Knight D4 exactly yes yes yes yeah and
but the problem is he doesn't have to
play Knight B8 so it's this weird
position where we we're both stuck and
uh we don't really have ideas yeah
because if I ever try Queen G3 check F4
which is very logical um his Bishop on
B6 opens up got it it's not very easy to
continue Sam uh very tense but in the
end probably the correct result happened
in this one
congratulations you're going into the
rest day on a 50% score uh that's a very
decent score how do you feel about your
performance up to this point in this
tournament uh I mean I've had some
interesting games so far and uh I I have
had some chances in the second round in
the end yesterday but I think
objectively it's it's been solid so far
solid so far congratulations we'll see
you after tomorrow we have a quick
question from Kate one one more question
for you Sam very quick question Sam uh
at one moment we saw a closeup at you
and I think after Queen takes F3 you
were like shaking hands and you seemed
very unhappy so was it because you
thought maybe the game is going to
quickly end in a draw or was there
another reason that you seemed very
unhappy uh I don't remember when was
that after I took on F3 G4 maybe after
G4 when he played yeah yeah I I did not
know G4 and I was not happy because
you forgot the line that it exists
or you were caught unaware by G4 I I
simply didn't know the move G4 ah so
that you were you were uh caught unaware
cuz we weren't sure that yeah yeah but
you manage it very well and I think draw
is a good result in this game all right
Sam enjoy your free day all right thank
you absolutely as we continue our look
and we I think jeffy's game with uh
Andrew Tang has also been drawn uh
didn't apologies to when we left it we
had seen this uh moment with Queen B6
and he did play Knight C3 Jeffrey and it
got away from us he didn't not much has
happened in that one it was a
pretty slow slow affair
right by the way for Andrew
not a bad result at all right with the
black pieces making a comfortable draw
against Jeffrey right he had a draw
yesterday pretty quick today relatively
fast and tomorrow rest day for him
absolutely we got to go back to the Hans
game Hans versus Mishra that's the big
battle right
absolutely uh we left it and we were
about to see the Queens coming off the
board we thought that Hans had a bit of
a nibble what is happened to the
position wow look at those PA and Bishop
takes C3 well that's a pawn that's an
extra one I like that's actually the
second one and two pawns up yeah just
pause for a moment here uh Bishop F6 is
everybody's choice but is there anything
else that we can do exactly in this
moment perhaps Bishop F6 is going to
just simply lead to some sort of
simplifications right well hold it hold
it hold I think alternative by the way
is Bishop B2 and maybe
E5 Bishop B2 Rook takes C4 and E5 yeah
mhm because I want so then you have an
anchor Square for your Bishop I
will but then I have intermediate mod
Bishop D5 Bishop D4 I take on D4 with e
Rook yes yes let's just show our
audience that because at first blush
you're kind of pleased right oh I get to
pick up this Rook I thought if you take
me the other Rook I have a check yep
very nice take
here nope no you take with the other rug
and you're crying oops there you go uh
but hold on you guys I mean I'm a pawn
Grabber I live for being a pawn up in a
position why isn't Bishop F6 the way to
go so I can Retreat back to E3 Bishop
back to
E3
now now we're going to go I don't know
another one of those uh three pawns for
a rook uh kind of thing uh once again uh
standings and we have another guest in
studio one more time do it once more
with now two draws yes we have two draws
already happened that happened but we
still have a so leader abanu Mishra with
two and a half points and a two-way tie
for the second place Fabiano Karana and
Sam shankland with two points we just
heard the perspective of Sam seon let's
get the perspective easy for me to say
of lanir over to see you Christen lener
after four rounds going into the first
rest day give us your assessment of your
performance and uh tell us a bit about
yesterday's game as well because that
one was pretty
wild yeah uh obviously a big chance for
me yesterday um but um yeah other than
that um pretty solid pretty normal I
mean I had three blacks uh so I guess
it's fine um but yeah yester the game
was was uh very interesting I uh I was a
Pity not to win because I would would
have been one of my best games I think
but that Queen to F6 at the end and
uh sorry that Queen to F6 idea at the
end Rook to E3 and queen to F6 did you
see it during the analysis did you see
it did your did the computer show it to
you after the
game yeah of course I mean I saw it
after the game but during the game I was
kind of I mean I was aware of it but uh
of course I um it never really came to
my mind to play this uh rookie 3 I mean
I was considering um just briefly
because I mean the main issue was that I
had so little time and you can always
lose this position so I was uh I mean uh
once I got down to less than two minutes
I was a big bit in a panic mode and um
just briefly thought about the queen of
six but always with the Rook on E1 I
mean not not with the Rook on E3 so
there was always takes takes King H7 uh
but yeah this Rook E3 was brilliant and
of course there there were many um I
mean there were few other ways to win
but yeah it was tough with little time I
think this B takes A4 was brilliant uh
uh from him because I was thinking it's
just I'm going to M him and he he cannot
do anything but yeah suddenly he found
the best defensive and then at least
yeah and even A5 I mean I was really
shocked by A5 I thought I was just ma
him and he goes A5 I mean the pawn is
still so far but uh it was winning but
yeah it wasn't so simple absolutely well
three blacks only one white and you had
a great chance with the white pieces
that is a good sign for your form lanir
go get some rest during the rest day
guys any questions for yeah oh gez
absolutely uh lanir uh first of all yeah
sorry for the Miss yesterday that Queen
F6 would have been absolutely brilliant
we were looking at your game because of
the whole sacrifice and we were
mystified by two suggestions of the
computer one suggestion involved you're
playing A5 A4 first question was that a
a move you considered secondly the other
suggestion of the computer was to play
for Rook G8 which actually makes a lot
of sense because there's no longer the
repetition you would have Rook G6 in
case of Queen G3 uh did either of those
two moves or maybe both uh catch your
eye I mean A4 I didn't think about it at
all uh just a way too too deep for me I
mean the position it's already very
complex there like many options for both
sides and it's it's hard to tell for for
humans here uh what's what's right and
what what's not uh Rook d8 was indeed a
very logical way and I was considering
the move of course but I think uh um oh
instead of Queen E7 yeah no I the moves
I was considering here other than Queen
E7 were Knight
B8 uh because it's very natural I mean
very human at least to try to play
Knight B8 Knight D7 but uh first of all
I wasn't sure if D5 D5 Queen G3 and
queen takes E5 what was the the
situation there I mean um Queen G3 King
H7 Queen takes C5 I have to play
probably Knight G4 and then yeah because
if Knight D7 there is Queen F5 check so
Knight G4 obviously and then Queen H5
and uh I wasn't sure at all I mean maybe
black is okay here but uh Queen E8 or
something but
uh but
uh yeah Rook G8 uh was was indeed
logical
um I was just worried that I would never
get rid of this pin and that he would
have time for Rook D1 Rook D3 but
apparently Rook D1 Rook D3 is not so
deadly and I can just stay put with the
queen on E7 and then maybe yeah maybe
even go for this uh slow play with
Bishop D7 it's very hard to to decide on
this because it looks like I'm I'm going
to to get uh to get uh mated here or
that will lose F6 because once The Rook
gets to the third rank there are ideas
with queen E2 and then Rook F3 but uh
yeah I guess the point is Queen E2 King
H7 and and then or King f8 and then Rook
G6 Lenard this reminds me that Sam
savian was saying that he felt he's
putting his opponent into Eternal pain
but he doesn't have uh ways how to
increase the pressure how did you feel
in that position with that pain were you
in Eternal pain
pain yes so that's why I was uh trying
to to to find ways to to solve it to get
rid of the pin but it turns out that I I
didn't have to worry about it so much
but yeah uh it's it's a very difficult
position for both sides because white is
obviously running some risk as well I
mean if things go run um he's indeed
down a piece but uh at the same time for
black is also unpleasant especially if
you have to uh be cool and not worry at
all and just put Queen on E7 and play
like like Bishop D7 Rook A8 and so on I
think yeah uh very hard position to play
for both and I think draw is is a
logical result after all lanir thank you
so much for joining us enjoy your free
day uh you deserve it um we have update
uh with the ladies now that tatev has
won her game she's getting back in the
mix yes so she is currently also the
leader in the women's section together
with Karissa and be to Jova with two and
a half points and with Kissa and Beam
still playing somebody's going to get
more points than tatf but are you right
the moment tatf is attack first and
Christian uh what's happening in M's
game that's the big moment right here
because black has so many options right
we were looking at Bishop B2 Bishop B5
Bishop F6 Bishop F6 was your decision
right take take and that is the question
how is this end game Rook to a five I
was assuming if you do go A4 I do feel
like you have a lot of uh potential in
the position E5 get the king in and then
just make use of this majority on the
king side but what I can do is try to go
for the attack like Rook to C8 I'll give
you another check I'll give you another
check and yet another check right what
do you do now King D6 let's go King D6
and this is probably what Hans is
calculating right now this uh race
you're going to take on A2 I'm going to
take on G6 the problem is I also have
ideas of G4 I'm not even sure I'm going
to start taking your pawns rather I'm
going to start pushing my pawns with the
move G4 try to create something try to
do something with the H Pawn so this is
the race that Hans is calculating and
take a look at this Mishra only five
minutes on his clock Hans 25 minutes on
his clock so he has the luxury of
calculating all of these options right
now according to the engine the best
move is Bishop E5 and that creates the
most problems for white in the position
because if you do take on C4 I'm going
to take take and now I'm going to go
Bishop to G3 that comes with a very
serious threat right I have to get out
of R to B1 right I don't get checkm of
course if you take on E7 no time for
that so you have to go King to F1 but
now after Rook to B2 you start
understanding how tied up white is in
the position you take on E7 I'll give
you a check first you cannot go to E1
you have to go here I pick up a pawn
good luck defending this one not going
to be easy so this is the key move
should be that if he finds it I'm
looking at the position A4 being the
best move find A4 and understand the
details and the differences with only a
couple of uh minutes on your clock
Bishop E5 is on the board wow Bravo five
minutes right now and this is not is
this an expected move for Mishra I don't
think so I think he was looking at
Bishop F6 and trying to calculate that
Rook end game absolutely I believe this
is coming as a surprise and from a
practical perspective and from an
objective perspective right now m is in
deep trouble with five minutes on the
clock and Jeffrey Jang uh is in uh
Studio to uh talk to you
Christian Jeffrey welcome to the show
tell us a bit about today's game um you
tried but unfortunately you weren't able
to break through your opponents very
strong and resilient
defense yeah thank you for inviting me
um today was a bit dry I wasn't
expecting this uh Bishop B4 Check Line
in the Catalan and I think he got what
he wanted um out of the opening probably
after Queen B6 I should have played C5
just to stop this uh DT C4 in the game
but um yeah the one I chose wasn't too
problematic for him and and he was able
to equalize relatively easily absolutely
and yesterday uh uh it was a difficult
game obviously against Fabiano with the
white pieces unfortunately you fell for
those complications and in the end game
maybe you were close to a drop but from
a practical perspective with so little
time on the clock it wasn't easy what
were the adjustments that you made after
yesterday's
game yeah I think the main problem about
yesterday's game was just my time
management I played way too slowly uh
after move 40 yeah and also before um so
yeah today I tried to play
faster uh unfortunately Andrew was very
solid so it didn't really work to
Perfection uh today as well but I'll
keep trying still many games to be
played and tomorrow you get a
well-deserved rest day guys any
questions for Jeffrey not for me Jeffrey
just uh enjoy your rest day and we'll
see you uh on
Tuesday thank you I wanted to point out
uh boldly point out the obvious
darou uh is really in severe time
trouble I mean I don't know exactly
where it all disappeared but he's got
like three four moves to play uh but
he's on the in increment no he has 13
moves to play pardon me 13 they're at
move 27 right now yeah
moves to play and we he only has 36
seconds and the last move was Rook E7 in
that game and uh but let's say with with
with Hans guys cuz CU that's yes that's
a sequence right now that is going to
define the rest of the game okay and
Mishra is only down to his last minute
so Rook takes C4 was the whole sequence
and we see we're going to see Bishop G3
that's the key move setting up the back
rank mate just taking away the king F2
Square
and that's setting up a decisive
Advantage for black okay so if he plays
the move Bishop to G3 it's going to be
extremely difficult to
untie going
for what was
that what exactly was that it was
actually pretty strange I don't know
exactly where he picked it up but it was
a habit of Tony miles too uh he's going
to make a move Bishop G3 and he would
like well polish the square is wrong but
just kind of like take fluff or whatever
away and he's like he's going to play
Bishop G3 you know he's going to play
bishop and he was kind of cleaning the
square what was he doing just a second
ago was he cleaning the square dust it
off dust it off pointing to that's where
I want to
go I'm going to put my Bishop there yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know he's
think a favor to Mishra who has only
three minutes left like this is what I'm
going to play you can start
thinking uh Maurice Ashley was telling
me about a play player who was
purposefully uh annoying him he would
show him the base of the square he'd
pick up a piece let's say the night and
he'd show him the base of the night and
then he put it on the board I'm going to
move my
Bishop you like oh that was one game
that Maurice really wanted to win and he
did Bishop to G3 and I don't know I I
really didn't like that sequence with uh
King coming and then the Rook coming
Gliding Over I didn't like that sequence
at all but Rook has to go back Rook
comes down do I seize the defensive and
just no that looks very ugly I agree
very very ugly uh in studio tatv winner
for today with you Christian that first
of all congratulations uh that was a
very shaky game uh that was the French
okay you still continue winning games
with the French uh tell us a bit about
your opening uh Choice uh and the middle
game of this game and how you recovered
from that difficult opening
phase Oh I thought you were going to ask
me how I recovered from yesterday
because I was really upset after
yesterday's game too yeah she played the
advance French I wasn't expecting it she
usually plays Knight C3 so I played a
line I don't normally play with this F6
and we got into some unknown territory
and I don't think I okay I know I didn't
handle it well as I actually checked the
game
quickly after C4 I spent a lot of time
and I guess I didn't react well but I
feel like every time I spent too much
time I don't react well but I I don't
even know what to do here because every
move I consider just looked terrifying
after C4 Rook is coming to C1 the Knight
going to B5 it just looks like I'm just
getting checkmated no this is just
allowed me so much once I get the pawn
to G4 Knight on F5 she just gave me
everything it was this moment that she
had the move B6 did you see spot this
move during the game I mean I spotted
the idea I knew something like this was
coming but I thought okay I'm I have to
take probably right and then then attack
me if you succeed you succeed what can I
do yeah yeah absolutely and then she
gave you this opportunity Knight to F5
now you're starting to feel better about
your attack right you're getting some
moves with Tempo in was that your
feeling as
well well I was feeling better about not
getting made it because now things
really can get on the light Square so
okay I have a bishop um covering the
dark Square so I'm blocking Bishop F3
the queen goes to E4 B7 is covered I was
really shocked when she took on G4
because why gave me this open H
file yeah I mean here I'm already here I
was actually very happy already here I
could already feel things are going my
way because she just completely lost um
any thread of the position so I I
already could tell that something bad is
about to happen to her and then she
played this move Queen to E4 and that's
exactly the bad thing that happened to
her because you immediately uh blasted
open the position with the move D3 and
this is perhaps something that she
missed when did you spot this idea of
Rook to D4 after Rook takes
C5 um when she went even before she went
Queen E4 because my whole game my whole
uh plan is associated with this D3 move
right get getting D3 open this diagonal
getting G3 somehow get some kind like
make the thing make the game messy right
so as long as I can get D3 my Rook comes
to D4 like I was kind of shocked I was
like am I winning here like how could
this be but uh you know now all of a
sudden I have a Pawn on E2 T
congratulations a big important victory
bounceback victory after as you
mentioned yesterday's disappointment
you're back in this tournament you're
for the moment a part of the co- leading
group as you enter uh the resty what are
you going to do during the
resting um well we have community
service to do and besides that I don't
really have any plans just take it easy
I know I have a big match coming up
against Kissa I believe I'm playing
White against Carissa so that's going to
be a huge match I probably spend most of
it
preparing we'll see you after tomorrow t
enjoy your rest day tat and uh again
update our standings first will we K
yeah so let's take a look so after the
win TF abramian is catching up with the
leaders Karis and be here Genova all of
them having two and a half points with
Carissa and beam ready to play still
playing and in the open in the open
section we still have ABI Manuel Mishra
leading with two and a half points we
have a bunch of draws but that did not
affect the soulle leader but Hans nean
is playing against mro we think Hans has
uh a serious Advantage if Hans can win
he'll be scoring he'll have the same
score pardon me as Mishra with two and a
half points just wanted to say that in
the Carissa uh versus B game that seems
to be very balanced but breaking
developments big news in the Nazi versus
Arena Crush match because I'm just
looking at this position and I think uh
everyone who's ever seen these types of
um um mating patterns yeah the KN uh I
think they actually call it the Arabian
mate you put the Knight on F6 you put
the Rook on H7 and uh it's it's a
magical Checkmate in this particular
case you can do it a different way too
you can go to the E8 Square so that you
can actually uh do it with a double
threat you're threatening Knight E8 uh
take C7 and Knight E8 to F6 so Nasi
looking really good in uh this one I
mean if Nazi can pick up another Pawn
that is a big Advantage well uh it she
she's not a pawn up at the moment but
it's right I saw the B on G7 disappeared
so my whole career all I do is Count PS
it's like it it's second nature I feel
like a Spock you know just keeping uh
keeping track of Pawns but it does look
like Nai really has a a a clear
Advantage with this move 98 I don't know
don't think time is a factor is it it
sort of it is a little bit Nazi has 17
minutes while Arena has only two minutes
left okay and they still have to make
nine moves okay and uh back over to you
uh Christian what's caught your eye well
what's caught my eye is that Darius is
still down to his last one minute and
things have changed a little bit some
exchanges have happened this Pawn on E5
disappeared after this exchange and in
return you got the H3 Pawn yes so this
is what we have right now the position
remains very close to equality but again
it's one minute against 18 minutes right
how do we feel about this position Queen
to E1 has been played right now I think
black is absolutely perfectly fine
should be yes I agree with you maybe
even Knight to D7 right I was even
thinking about H5 and Knight G4 yeah ah
you want to go aggressive well you know
it's my natural inclination you know
like I don't like seizing the defensive
I'm not that kind of a guy right right
right now the question is can I cuz H3
Pawn is missing C4 but C4 you just like
go back I don't like that move do I like
to trade Queens with Knight C4
yes you can definitely do that but the
problem is this Pawn on B6 is nicely and
secure uh by the Knight on D5 secure by
the Knight on D5 I don't even have to
trade the queen I'm kind of inclined to
going Queen H3 Queen F5 you know I mean
even Queen H3 Knight on my agenda I'm
not sure about trading Queens you have
to do queen F1 and again H5 H4 could
disturb uh the king side so even though
how does he have okay Queen to F5 played
with 15 seconds on
wow uh I was never good in time trouble
uh I was very against well Walter Shan
Brown Sammy Revy were two great lanir
Dominguez is a great time trouble guy
yes but
youing I like playing against the guys
who are in time trouble I mean that that
was fun Queen F5 I think darsh is fine
it's all about the clock yes
absolutely all right well let's uh uh we
have in studio Sam back over to you
Christian no no we don't have Sam Sam is
actually still playing but we do have an
interview sorry Sam as we go on a break
ah that was what it is we've got Sam
Shanklin for you enjoy
everyone Hi Sam thank you so much for
joining me today tell me a little bit
about your chess upbringing well I
didn't have much of a chess upbring I
took my first chess class with the
Berkeley chess school after school
program when I was in fourth grade I was
9 years old I didn't play a tournament
until I was 11 and uh growing up in
California that was probably one of the
best places in America to grow up but
American chess was really desolate at
the time there's a reason that you know
only me and Hikaru from that generation
uh really blossomed into top players
until the next Generation came along
with guys like Ray and Jeffrey and Sam
San uh but growing up in America there
really were very few opportunities uh
but I'm delighted that that has changed
a lot recently uh because it's something
I really dedicated my life to and I
wasn't able to do that until I was an
adult I know a lot of people especially
those who came who grew up in other
countries other continents uh were able
to do chess full-time from the time they
were 10 or whatever that was not me I
mean I went through the full American
K12 education system got a University
degree uh but chess always was what
motivated me the most it was what I was
most passionate about I worked really
really hard and very proud of how far
I've come do you have a book that has
influenced you the most as you were
growing up uh there have been so many uh
books that have had a positive impact on
me uh there was certainly all of the
grandmas uh preparation series The
repertoire ones with quality chess the
first one with Boris aook convinced me
to start playing D4 when I had played E4
my whole life and uh that sort of turned
me around in a lot of good ways um but
if you made me pick one book that I
think uh had the biggest impact on me it
was practical chest defense and that was
for two reasons one because I think it's
a really good book and two because uh uh
I it inspired me to work with yakob B
the author and he's been my coach ever
since and um you know when I won the
Sanford Fellowship in uh this was 2014
uh and I had money at my disposal for
the first time in my life I was you know
2600 as an adult I had made it there
that far but I was sort of stuck and I
needed a coach at that point and hiring
yob came and the rest is history and I
know uh he's convinced you or maybe you
two have worked together and you've
become an author as well you recently
have published a new book can you tell
me a little bit bit about your career as
an author as well yeah so basically my
top priority by far is trying to be the
best chess player I can be and a lot of
my peers you know 2700 Club they take
one look at me like why are you writing
so many books creating so much content
and the answer is quite simple is I
write about stuff that I want to improve
myself uh so for example my most recent
book theoretical Rook end Games took
three and a half years to write it's
finally it's going to be released
October 18th I have some Advanced copies
here uh but it was three and a half
years of studying complex Rook hand
games I mean yeah I get that maybe
putting them into words not is not like
100% the most useful use of my time for
training but I learned so much writing
this book and I'm just looking at myself
as a I have plenty of examples of my own
games in this book when I was 2700 I
just missed playing Rook end games and
now hopefully that will happen less
often so every single project I've ever
taken on for both for Quality chess and
for chessable has been done with the
same stated goal in mind to make me a
better chess players for completely
selfish reasons and uh if the readers
want to come along for the ride they're
welcome to and funnily enough this model
has been extremely successful for the
books everyone really loves them uh I'm
just doing my own training and inviting
people to join yeah I've seen a lot of
your books you're also writing um and
you've created courses on chessable and
on chessable you're mostly known for
your
openings uh courses which one would you
say is uh the most uh important to study
or is it all three parts of the game uh
well I mean you can't be a complete
chest player without being good at All
Phases of the game if I were to make an
analogy that I quite like is if you can
run really fast uh control the ball
really well with your feet pass really
well shoot really well dribble really
well steal really well and you can't
stop the ball with your hands to save
your life that's fine don't be a
goalkeeper in chess if you're really
good at openings you're well prepared
you've analyzed them deep into the Early
Middle game you have very good tactical
vision for quick little tricks good
positional feel for your pieces you know
have good knowledge of technical end
games but you can't calculate to save
your life you've got a problem and so I
think to sort of isolate one part of
Chess or some parts of Chess is more
important than others is just not true
it's not a good idea and you have to be
a complete player capable of playing All
Phases of the game in order to play at a
high level when you were young uh you've
often mentioned uh on your social media
that Gary Kasparov was one of your
Heroes uh was he the one who's
influenced you the most as um as a world
champion yes of course Gary Kasparov was
my earliest hero one of the biggest
reasons was just that I met him I mean
for what it's worth I know this sounds
ridiculous when you look at the world
today I never met a Grandmaster until I
was 15 I never played with one until I
was 16 you know this I I did not have a
quick development and I did not have
opportunities to play with strong
players and travel and stuff like that I
mean I I had the opportunity to play
with a bunch of 2200s starting very very
young in San Francisco which I'm
extremely grateful for I know at least
at the time that was a lot more than a
lot of other people had especially in
this country uh but I didn't have an
opportunity to like really meet with
strong players and I didn't get how good
Grand Masters and top Grand Masters and
you know super Elite world champions
could be and when I got to meet Gary
kaspar for a weekend uh along with a
bunch of other young American Juniors
and he just completely opened my eyes to
the level of Excellence that chess
players can strive for and uh it
inspired me and laid the foundation for
who I am today and he will always be my
biggest hero and I'm sure you felt
really great when you had the
opportunity to win against him um
earlier a few months ago actually or
maybe a month ago in here in St Louis in
9lx yeah so I've played with Kasparov
twice uh both games were sort of
blowouts the first one he completely
crushed me the second game maybe crushed
as the wrong word but it was a pretty
smooth Victory on my part so uh just
playing with him is is a huge honor I
mean chess 9 LX is a lot of fun it's
it's great but it's not super serious
it's not rated it's sort of an
exhibition event so I didn't care so
much about the results obviously I was
very proud to have beaten him in one of
the two games we played but uh really
just play playing with Gary is a
tremendous honor because he doesn't play
classical chess anymore and that's just
what you can do um but yeah it was one
of the proudest moments of my life when
I beat him I mean it says a lot that
this Sky's 60 years old 18 years retired
and beating him in an exhibition game is
one of the proudest moments of my life
all the same that's how good he was okay
and uh I was wondering about this
competition you have to come back from
Rapid chess blades events that you had
to play to classical chess what did you
do specifically to prepare for this
event well I played some longer training
games which hopefully helps I haven't
been able to play much classical events
this year there haven't been that many
classical events and I wasn't invited to
very many either which was tough uh but
classical chess is certainly what I
specialize in the most it's what I'm
best at I've dedicated my training plan
in the last you know my entire adult
life towards becoming the best classical
chess player I can be and as a result
for the most part I've lagged behind in
Rapid and Blitz uh which I still view as
less important overall it's not been
that terrible obviously like in 960
rapid I made plus three this time last
time in 960 I made plus two and I made
plus one in the rapid section of the St
Louis rapid and Blitz last year so I
mean I I can play rapid when I need to
but classical is what I've worked the
most at it's been a really rough year
for me in a lot of ways but I'm I'm
feeling motivated and energized and I'm
ready to turn around now well thank you
very much Sam looking forward to reading
your book and good luck in this
[Music]
competition
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for juniors helping around
schools and they've just grown the game
so much across the United States I think
if I look at my own career and I look at
American chest in general we're in a
much better place than we were 15 years
ago and so the contributions have been
immense and of course it's all thanks to
Dr Jun singfield and Rex singfield I
would say that St Lucia's Club is like a
rock in the ocean of Chess and we know
that it's it's there it is there it will
be there I think it's sense a hope that
the the game of chess will always stay
Float by the mere fact of its existence
I think it it it sends positive waves
across the
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess fac facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located ated in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess hf.org
[Music]
this St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
profession professional training from
Grandmaster verua niobian other programs
include chess cops a partnership with
the St Louis Police Department looking
to improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2023 national
championships we have some results in
this the fourth round before our free
day tomorrow take a look at the
standings Kate to the honors and the
ladies so Tata have made a very
important win in this round and she's
now tied at the top with Karis say and
beging toir janova with two and a half
points and in the open I know we have a
lot of draws we have a lot of draws but
nothing is going to distract abanu
Mishra who is the sole leader with two
and a half points speaking of M
something going to distract him
something's going to distract he two
pawns down right now that's the big
distraction for abim Manu unfortunately
and to be honest I think he's uh
actually just busted after the move
Bishop to G5 he just played the move
Bishop to D2 We left it off somewhere
around here Hans was still thinking
about this last move Bishop to G3 we
told you guys this is the money move
move if he finds it this is going to be
a win for him take a look at this King
to F1 check Bishop to C1 much better
would have been King to E2 in fact this
was perhaps the last moment in which
Mishra would have been able to stay in
the game somewhat King to E2 couple of
moves have been played after that and
this is what we currently have Bishop to
G5 as we expected F4 but right now if I
just simply go Bishop
H6 and then go E5 next move right how do
you stop me from exchanging even more
pawns and in fact getting into a
technical winning a rook game he's done
it F4 Bishop H6 and prescribed E5 is on
hans's agenda and that's it two pawns
pin it to win it right now you're in
trouble no for sure it's been the case
in absolute shambles as ABI Manu he
knows it right but for Hans nean not
only did he just break the tournament
wide open but he did himself a solid
favor by uh beating a key rival a game
we anticipate he will win and he will
have the same score as Mishra two and a
half going into the reste back kind of
opens up the door a little bit for
Fabiano in his game with darou now we
think the game is very balanced but it's
about the clock as well it's about the
clock and it has been about the clock
for so long right for the last I believe
10 15 moves uh Darius has been playing
on increment and he is still doing
exactly that we discussed about this
situation we discussed about their
previous game at last year's us
Championship Darius had a great position
out of the opening and this is the
sequence and the phase of the game in
which he lost control mhm and maybe it's
happening again right now this is what
we have by the way Darius is down to his
last 20 seconds so keep an eye on that
that well I'm just saying that if mro
was to lose Fabby at plus one as well as
Sam Shanklin at plus one might have a
window and there we see it very good
move I like this move G very much by
darus G5 again uh H5 H4 kind of opening
up the position for the King opening up
the position of White's King is on
Black's agenda and I like this move G5
no G5 was a very very good move not an
easy decision to make uh with
your king with 30 seconds on the clock
not an easy move to make but he timed it
well G5 is a good move well again from
from Fab's perspective he's he I don't
think you want to take too many risks
because if black is able to get an H4 H
takes G3 uh Queen G4 I got Knight
E6 to F4 check on my uh agenda I was
just thinking that Knight E5 looked like
a very natural move after G5 Knight H4
was a better move instead of Bishop to
C3 he just played this move Bishop to C3
maybe trying to put more pressure
quickly put more pressure on his clock
and uh force him to make his decision
his decision came G5 that was a great
move but Knight to H4 I think would have
created much more um big difficulties in
the position for black queen to G4 for
example then Queen to E5 you start
seeing ghosts que to B8 check where is
your king going you have to play uh
Queen to D4 B precise create your own
counterplay but these are not easy moves
to find so I think Knight to H4 from a
practical perspective would have been
the better solution for Fabiano he did
not play there are also ideas by the way
Christian with Knight F5 and Bishop H6
if you just move it back exactly yes
Knight F5 Bishop H6 all sorts of ideas
is against the King on f8 and there's no
more G5 right because of the Knight on
F6 so Knight to H4 was a good uh moment
for for Fabiano he did not spot it right
now after G5 to be honest I'm looking at
the position and current position who's
playing yeah just play D4 I believe uh
G5 no G5 but I'm I'm seeing D4 on your
monitor no no no no no that's that was
me making some moves I got you um no
Fabiano is still thinking trying to
after G5 understand how he can continue
this game there's only two moves until
Darius makes the time control and to be
honest if he makes the time control I I
I can call it I'm going to say that he's
going to be out of danger if he makes
the time control
safely out of danger I think he's out of
danger
yes out of practical danger objectively
he's completely fine in the position
right um but again it's all about the
time this is what I'm looking at I'm not
looking at the evil I'm looking at the
time and I think King G2 was
played no King G2 was already there King
King on G2 yeah no I I mean if I'm in uh
dar's shoes I'm angling for H5 H4
followed by H takes G3 just to loosen up
the king you know just dreaming of one
day going Queen G4 and KN F4 check
that's what uh Fabby and better
yeah uh that's the big uh concern for
Fabby I want to jump to the game of
Wesley so too because not only will
Mishra
uh loss open up the window of
opportunity for Fai to take first place
or uh but for Sam Shanklin as well now
when we left it we thought that Sam was
doing well but check this out he ended
up getting his Bishop trapped Sam
understood that he's not taking any
risks because you know rook and night
versus yester as we understand and he's
hoping that with these uh past but I'm
seeing very very active black pieces
think okay not Rising that much but I
think black is the one playing for a win
here black is playing for the win just
because maybe I can use your pawns try
to Checkmate you so I can go maybe
Knight E5 Knight F4 just to put or
Knight F4 yes yeah just to put one
example of you know how things you know
if uh I I if there weren't pawns on the
board you would give me a check Che easy
but in this case I you know I am
threatening to take this PA you have to
be careful you can go King G5 and
probably Escape but you have to be
careful right so you think that uh
Wesley uh Wesley for choice not by much
you also wanted to go Knight E5 did I
understand you so the idea here is like
something similar to what we just saw
you want to go Rook check and somehow
kind of and I don't even want to take
your G4 Pawn actually well that's kind
of you I wasn't going to give it to you
okay Rook D3 let's see Rook D3 check and
you know King G2 and
uh okay let's go King to
F4 uh King to F4 King to F4 M yes okay
this is getting interesting let's give
you a check on
D2 uhoh uhoh where's my going yeah
alert alert alert
King to G3 King King to E3 I'm hiding
behind your pawns and exactly I think
it's important to capture the pawn on A5
so we can have a check on A4 potentially
okay you think I shouldn't even be
bothering with these pawns yes after
Knight E5 let's just capture the pawn
and just say do your worst yeah okay
fair enough yeah uh but in this case
check and Knight takes
G4 okay uh by the way uh Jennifer you uh
we admired her incredible fighting
Spirit uh yesterday as she saved an
absolutely impossible game to save but
against atusa just a second things could
could have gone wrong for her just a
second uh just bringing up that game
that was the queen A8 game remember that
where I was expecting an exchange
Sacrifice from Jennifer yeah way back
here somewhere around these parts I was
expecting an exchange Cy I with Rook on
A5 takes D5 she didn't do that and I'm
just going to uh excuse me go very very
quickly to the current
position that on7 looks very dangerous
no kidding I mean all the way one one
square from
Coronation uhoh Queen is dropping in I
mean this is a very unhappy uh guest in
the position Queen E7
you got to play Rook B7 do you have a
choice uh
Kate but I want to take your Bishop but
do I have Bishop
takes D6 well uh to begin with yes
but what else can uh Jennifer do uh the
bishop she played Queen D7 so it's on
she did it's on the board Queen D7 this
looks terrible Queen takes F7 and the
problem is if you go Rook B7 I can take
on D6 exactly what Kate wants to do and
sacrifice the queen for the bishop take
on B7 and that's it and uh Rook B7 is on
the
board
right this the the Striking part about
this position is just how really messed
up Jennifer's pieces are so that uh I
mean it it we we were talking about a a
painful pin remember the pain painful
pin how about this one is a painful pin
your Rook on oh no you have I think
you're still winning but luckily there's
Rook V8 at the end you still get that
break do have to be careful though yeah
but if it wasn't for Rook B1 you know
what I mean it's an eternal pin by the
way Bishop Tak D6 is on the board as
expected yes Rook B7 Bishop takes
D6 that's the easy way out that's you
know the practical way out
and then you promote to another queen
yes right so how easy is that okay I
mean I'm an exchange up but there is a
pawn limited somewhat material how how
easy is
that so you're going to get a a there is
also Queen to E4 right ideas by the way
Bishop to A5 was played whoa whoa whoa
what what what no capturing on B6 no no
no but this cannot be good right
Bishop
A5 so we want to take this and take this
no do we no I just want to give check on
F5 maybe no but this is also very Bishop
takes C5 Rook B5 Rook B8 it is but do I
have to she went for it for went for it
yeah me the thing is forward I mean I
don't know about you but this uh this is
uh very straightforward Bishop comes
back to E3 Rook will go to B8 and
there's no check against the white king
no white king will be very very safe
Queen A8 Jennifer
recognizing uh for Jennifer this is
going to be a Dreadful start for her
campaign as she was trying to defend her
title but my goodness uh whoa something
really really went wrong for her here uh
now that we're here and uh let's just
take a a graphic of uh
atusa atusa bashian 35 years old USCF
rating 2388 and she is the seventh time
Iranian Women's Champion yeah we talk
about eight times Arena seven times
Iranian Champion ATA as and I believe
this is her first US Championship right
yes exactly um and she's done it it's
who is just going straight for that line
with Bishop takes D4 and then she'll
bring a rook to B8 and there's nothing
Jennifer can do uh jennif because the
queen can never move from A8 otherwise I
promote precisely so yeah yeah uh I
wanted to while we're over here at the
ladies Championship I wanted to check in
onalia and Alice Lee when we left it at
Alice had uh won an exchange but we were
thinking that Talia might get some
compensation that's not the case by the
way Yer can you go a little bit back to
like move 30 look where the black king
was before with the Queens on the board
say what look at the black king wow and
that's is beging game she's just going
with her King to walk to F3 and
Checkmate on H1 no fear
whatsoever wow and for tell you what a
what a what a great sadness that her
Queen is trapped that she's not in time
to deliver a Checkmate to Alice's King
which is leading the army uh King is on
e4 but what a move we always teach keep
the king safe in the middle game
especially if heavy pieces are on the
board but not here here Alice goes
fiercely with the king in the
center
fear I was about to say uh a little fear
is good you know sometimes you but uh
she does have uh
what I have to say is a winning ending
four versus four but the extra exchange
and
should guide this to victory over to you
Christian and what's what are you
looking at another big game is the one
between PID and Arena crush and piz
according to the engine objectively was
completely winning but she had to find
this move we were discussing about this
Knight F6 Rook H7 check mating patterns
she did go through that and then Arena
had to defend with a move Knight to G5
nicely done by Irena but after Knight to
D5 and she was conducting this whole
sequence uh quite well but at this point
she missed a bit once again what's
Black's plan she should have asked
herself King to G8 get the king in and
try to not get checkmated in the process
the way to avoid that as white was to go
Rook to D7 another an easy move to see
very nice prophylactic whenever we talk
about uh prophylactic moves this is
exactly the type of moves that we're
thinking about Rook to D7 now if you go
King to G8 you walk Fork Knight D7
that's it game over right so you can go
Rook to D6 the problem is this end
that's the ending you love yeah yes
night end games the theory is that
they're very similar to pawn end games
and if you're a pawn up in a pawn end
game generally you have great chances to
win so this is what uh surely Irena
wouldn't have liked to see on the board
sure after Rook to D7 I'm not 100% sure
what you do next there's no moves
there's no moves if you
go then you go Knight F6 Knight F6 back
now you have to go Knight G5 but there's
no more attack on the knight6 H4
finishes the game right so you can go
Knight to f8 but that's very passive
after Rook to F7 right I'm going to take
this Knight and then I'm going to go
Knight to D7 so this one is winning as
well CHR can I go Rook C2 instead of
Rook C5 yep you can try yeah for sure
and I think I'm going to try to do the
same thing so Knight G5
H4
that that's what you're running into
that's what you're facing you can give a
check but that's about it there's not
much more of a continuation afterwards
because you get checkmated that's the
problem right it's all about that
Checkmate and she understood it at the
beginning of this sequence unfortunately
she wasn't able to complete it before
the time uh before the next time control
and that's what we have right now what
did she B5 another opportunity to stop
her with the move Rook to D7 did not
take that and now King comes to G8 and
now I'm not safe yet but I'm doing much
better than I was doing I think this is
what we currently have on the board
after move Knight to G7 finally I know
I'm not getting checkmated right Knight
to G that's a big relief isn't it yeah
just Knight to F5 you also have to worry
about King to G8 that's a threat more or
less right now in the position because
you cannot touch uh the pawn on H6 KN to
five is coming so right Nazi lost
control she did she did she had a golden
opportunity to uh put Arena down in this
one and arena is not an easy opponent uh
to finish and she had a great
opportunity in this tell us about our
tournament leaders uh Karissa and beum
well this one has simplified quite
drastically uh we left it somewhere
around here and I want to show the
sequence beging found a very nice move
first of all after Queen to G2 if you go
Rook to E1 this was a golden opportunity
for Karissa because
after Knight takes A4 which would have
arrived on the board you have Queen to
B5 followed by Rook to E8 and now we
understand that all of your pieces as
black they're sort of tied down right
nasty pins they're in a pin right it
looks like my king is weak but it's not
that weak I'm going to go to a A2 and
I'm just simply going to hide your king
is weak as well and I'm coming with the
next move Knight to E7 which is going to
create some difficulties Knight to D4
followed by Queen to C6 is an idea as
well this would have been winning for
Karissa she had take on A3 Rook takes G8
some sort of sacrifices like this still
some chances but it's probably going to
be winning yes this is an exchange she
did not played this she played Rook to
D1 and this is probably what she missed
Bishop takes A3 nice tactic to get the
pawn back you
can Bishop takes A3 very nice Bishop to
A1 and now we have this one still not
that easy because you have a big
weakness on H7 and I do have a passer
ready to be pushed right this is what we
have
C5 and this is the position that begim
will need to try to um to defend we
would expect H5 right yes and I'm
looking at some Bishop takes G3 yes G4
right right ah Rook G4 you can still
play Rook G4 yeah yeah that's a very
very important move to get I'm trying to
get the
Bish Bish versus Rook yes yes yes dude
B's on your team what are you
talking we practiced that in game so
much but it's still difficult it's still
not that easy to uh to make equality she
does know the procedures but you know
theory is much easier than practice
exactly uh so what you're saying is kiss
is a two result game yes yes definitely
a two game Karissa is on the move but
she did miss some chances along the way
thank you Kate where would you like to
take us I saw we have a move in the
Mishra Hans nean game all righty I'll
jump right over to that one and maybe
only one but oh that was that Bishop
H6 and uh telegraphing I've got these
double pawns I'm two pawns up I want to
utilize them E5 and with the bishop on
um H6 I balling x-raying if you will the
D2 Bishop G3 so can I capture on F4 and
get another Pawn to I was about to say
yes you can and yes you should another
move that you I mean I like what you
just suggested very very strongly
but also so we want to Target the pawn
chain so we will make the F4 Point uh
Pawn a bit weaker but no I loved what
you you you suggested initially I like
that even better takes takes and E5
I do think also H4 you know is another
Runner but this is this is over two PS
up that's it game over yeah there's no
way Hans is going to let this one go
exactly so if let's try for Misha to
play Rook C8 check okay King up rook C7
and now we just have to be careful not
to go on the sixth rank why because of
F5 F5 or E takes or F takes E5 very good
F5 check I was like okay
maybe you I no no no no no I don't want
I'm not even calculating it no you I
don't want to see that you don't even
want to see that you got to go go King e
i get it it's probably winning even
after
f56 and of course as we check our
standings coming in today's
round very important game for behind
yeah if he manages to win he will catch
up with the leader abanu Mishra and they
will both have two and a half points
exactly meaning the window open for
Fabby and Sam if they could win their
games that would be clear first uh and
Fabby is in a struggle with darush and
Sam is
probably even against Wesley so but you
were thinking oh very that that might
play with the
Knight Knight his try but nothing is
going to come up because there some
pawns on the board that maybe the rook
and Knight can but a lot of them got
cleaned up oh did they yes all right
let's just take a quick Gander at that
one this is the Sam Shanklin Wesley slow
game and we were we're talking about
rook and Bishop versus rook and rook and
Knight wait a minute how am I going to
do this Rook Knight versus Rook I had to
stop and think about a little that's
what we had also yesterday that's what I
meant and today we have it the same
thing but because there's pawns on the
board it's sometimes it's not that easy
to give checks to the king and the and
the king can you know like wander in and
you would rather not there wouldn't be a
B3 Pawn so that you would be able to
give a roof check yeah the strategy for
white is to get rid of the pawns as soon
as possible exactly sacrifice them if
you can let me just refresh my board for
a moment and uh here we do have we do
see the king coming up to E3 so that you
know we we want to push the white king
to the edge of the board so that we can
set up those checkmating patterns we're
so familiar with do Rook B8 and just go
yeah Rook B8 is absolutely essential uh
before before we get Knight F3 and again
we're looking to check the king away
let's stay with this one because I have
a feeling Wesley is not even going try
for too
long do you see some some patterns that
we can I'm see a problem Rook B8 is a
very good move but if we move back and
move the Rook to H4 let's say we want to
support the pawn going forward so King
E3 yes Rook H4 right now black can have
Knight F3 which I desperately want and
after Rook H3 there is Checkmate
immediately thank you for the self
helpmate yes and if you move the Rook
let's say back Rook B4 then I give check
on G1 King H3 and these are these are
the patter F2 and again it's a Checkmate
yeah again this is a another nice self
uh helpmate and now we see them
repeating the position they're going to
shake hands in just a second oops excuse
me I'm just going to refresh my board
and we expect uh draw a greed Sam is
going to look to into Frank's Direction
say with King G2 I'm the position to
unlike the ladies said I don't even want
to look at this anymore let's get out of
here we've got a free day tomorrow
everybody let's go and enjoy our our day
tomorrow and uh draw a hand looks like
both of them are very happy please it
was a well played game I don't think
either player had too much in this one
take us to the Fabe game for a moment
Chris well actually I I want to see the
picture of F's game right now I want to
see the video and I want to see how many
minutes Darius has left after the time
control because I feel like I jinxed him
I said that he's out of danger if he
makes the time control but he's been
thinking since a very long time after
how many minutes does he still have in
the second time control right now is the
question who did that was that lir who
did that who no somebody maybe it was
Ray Robson no somebody to answer a
question just it's 16 minutes 16 minutes
okay so he spent half of his time on one
move that's not a good sign that's
really not a good sign because he hasn't
played it yet if he gets down to his
last 30 seconds again Fab's going to
find a way to complicate things who did
that that uh they they were in time
trouble they made the time control and
then minutes later later they were TI
trouble again it was pretty bad probably
L yeah take us through the current
position Christian well we left it off
after this move G5 Knight to D2 look you
have to be careful you have to P the
brakes right now as white because you
were mentioning H4 G4 wait a minute wait
a minute if I manag to open up the
position of your king with a two knights
and the queen around you that's not good
right so he understood what he had to do
exchange some pieces Knight to D2 was
played H4 Knight to E4 Knight takes C4
and this is what we have right now Queen
to H7 was played question about Queen to
H7 what do you want do you want to
support H3 I don't think you do I don't
think so either because once you go H3 I
hide behind it right in front of it with
a move King to H2 and I feel like my
king is safe I want to weaken your your
structure I want to go H4 takes G3
actually what if I go this move Queen to
D3 to try to invade E7 cover some
business squares Bishop E5 oh sorry I
was now I'm starting to
Hope I see a check I see a bishop coming
to F6 maybe some check mating patterns
yes yes yes so H Queen D3 HG so you take
right I take back with the f I have to
take with the F Pawn I don't want to see
a knight landing on F4 no I suppose I go
Queen H4 H5 just kind of eyeballing E2
yes okay let's see Bishop F6 or Bishop
E5 let's go Bishop E5 Bishop
E5 where do I want my king actually E8
or you didn't want to push the pawn to
G4 instead of Queen
H5 okay that's an interesting idea yeah
all right let's have a look at that why
not G4 okay I'll give you a check you go
to E not to G because the problem is
Queen H3 King G1 and I'm stuck there
right so he can go even on G8 is fine
actually but I think you want to go to
E8
right I wasn't really too sure actually
yes but you do have and perhaps this is
the idea now we understand why he spent
so much time now we understand why he
played the move Queen to H7 I think he
wants to go this sequence of take G4 and
get the check in right get the check on
H3 try to get the king try to get the
Perpetual but for me uh Christian it was
very nice from from darou to take the
pawn on D3 that wasn't bothering any
anybody you put the pawn on e4 maybe
Fab's happy could I see that Knight
trade again because that night trade was
maybe but what do you want to do that I
wanted to move my Knight Knight to D7
and not not not to promote the problem
is Knight to D6 after Knight D7 Queen G6
the pawn on
D3 went wild what's happened Queen F3 I
don't know Queen A8 is coming so be
careful
G8 G8 Knight C game
over just to interrupt you for a second
Aran has WUSA has won her game against
the defending Champion Jennifer you yeah
per F first victory in her debut
tournament I congrat just before the
free day you feel so good your free day
is so much better after a win right it's
unbelievable especially before the rest
day right you also know like job well
done now I can rest and I'm ready to
start again after the rest day
absolutely our congratulations and that
final position let me just uh bring that
up because uh we thought that there was
nothing that Jennifer could do to escape
where is it it's right there the the
final position it was like this really
nice Pawn on
A7 and all atusa was going to do was
just set this up bring her Bishop back
play for Rook B5 and there would there
was nothing that uh Jennifer could do to
prevent Rook B8 and queens and uh for
Jennifer o tough tournament oh
absolutely the tough tournament has got
a lot tougher uh with this loss
Christian how is beam doing not great
not great not great no she missed her
opportunity of going H5 we were
discussing this go H5 go H4 try to
eliminate the last few pairs of Pawns
right it's very very important to do so
before my king can touch your Bishop
exactly that's the key in the position
she played the move Rook to H7 that's a
bit passive of course I'm not going to
take on H6 and allow you uh to get this
straight position sure you get my Bishop
but it doesn't really matter that's an
easy draw so we have this position right
now King to C2 was played after Rook to
H7 C4 and now apparently F6 is the big
move was winning wow winning winning for
Karissa right now and the question is
why what if I go H5 now I go G4 and then
G5 and then G5 I connect my pawns very
happy that's not very very happy yes
right she did not play it and by the way
after F6 you cannot uh go Rook to F7
because I simply just take and I defend
my Pawn clear right so she played King
to D1 and now we have Bishop to F2 now
we're back into some sort of a drawing
territory but how easy is the drawing I
understand Carissa's idea which was just
to chase the bishop away so she can win
the pawn right but apparently this is a
draw I get my king in
time back to D7 wow but this is not easy
I mean I mean Karissa you know she was
probably thinking not knowing this we
have a table base in front of her she
has two connected pass pawns why isn't
she winning that's right and she played
Rook H2 okay with the same idea just
drive the bishop away win the PA take on
H6 and life is good but it's not Rook H2
Bishop to D4 I'm wondering if Bishop to
C5 is good as well and perhaps this is
something that she's looking for after
Bishop to D4 G4 maybe is her idea right
to go G5 right what if you go Rook to G7
then I go Rook to G2 and how do you
defend this I no no no no no but okay if
this is a draw then this is not easy
because understanding that this position
is a draw no this is just practically as
a player you don't want to get into this
position but there's no alternative
right now you are losing that pawn you
are losing the H6 Pawn let's take a look
at the standings updated updated women's
standings and here we still have uh kis
beim to janova and T Abraham who just
won an important game they are all
leading the tournament with two and a
half points as we started the show
Christian said Fighting Chess and uh we
started with uh five draws in both
sections in round one and then suddenly
progressively the the winning
percentages kept climbing well we've got
two out of two so far in this round four
and back to you and the um and Fab's
game there well the H game in fact fabbi
nothing has happened Queen to H7 was the
last move we've seen in that one but we
got to this position um he did play King
F7 after all he did play King F7 and now
the question is will he play King to E6
no he's not going to
walk but it's winning I know it is a
good move and he just made the move King
E6 he did play King E6 okay did okay so
they are catching up to our analysis but
it is funny to to to do it tactically to
win tactically it's a brave decision Kos
to I mean I thought he's just going to
avoid it with King E8 very peaceful move
that's what I thought he would do but
you know he's showing courage his flare
flare yes the chess you need some of it
okay we're not going to say it we have
been saying it so many times no not not
not not we understand the dialogue and
here uh through the magic of Television
we did uh we did anticipate King E8 we
thought King E6 might be played but why
play
tactics uh when we can just take it easy
nope king6 let's go is not taking it
easy he wants he wants tactics exactly
why not and in the l section uh we do
have four games remaining we do expect
Alice Lee uh again she's an exchange up
four versus four against Talia we think
that uh she is uh going to be winning
this because she's also got a passer as
well as uh an extra exchange so that is
likely to be a win
Carissa uh has gone into this Bishop's
ending it's just unfair that is supposed
to be a draw that's is just unbelievable
this I mean for me you know I do
recognize that the table base sometimes
reveals amazing insights about positions
like Queen endings where you have two
pawns a queen against a queen and it's
de draw it's like right crazy uh so
we're expecting more victories uh as uh
we have atusa in studio um Christian
atusa welcome uh to the show
congratulations for a very important
Victory against the defending champion
this is your first US chess
championships as well how does it feel
to be uh playing in your first US
Championship um hi guys
so actually um this tournament is a
little bit uh new for me me compared to
the other players so I just tried to be
solid but uh I drew my first two games
and I lost yesterday which I didn't
expect it but anyway uh so uh yeah I
mean it's a great way to come back after
loss with a victory against the
champion yes exactly I mean U Jennifer
is a strong player and uh uh I'm happy
happy that I could win today tell us a
bit about the the game when did you feel
like you're taking over the
initiative uh actually I expected her to
play this line so I was uh prepared for
this line and I thought that I mean
throughout the game uh White was more
comfortable I'm not sure about uh my
queen A4 Queen D1 idea but I knew that
even after exchanging the pawns still I
have a passed on on A3 so that should be
fine that's the key and uh yeah exactly
and um I mean her position was more
difficult to defend than mine so my my
position was I think more comfortable
definitely agree uh with that assessment
and it was at this point when she took a
pawn but you finally managed to get your
Pawn all the way to A7 and now it's
starting to look pretty clear that not
only you have enough compensation for
your lost Pawn but in fact you're just
simply breaking through you're winning
at this point and you conducted the
attack very nicely Queen to A4 invade
via D7 and then this queen sacrifice
atusa congratulations great game
tomorrow is the rest day what what are
your plans for the rest
day uh actually I think I'm going to
just rest a little bit because even
though we play just four games but it
feels more than that and also we're
going to go to one of the schools high
school here and I'm looking forward to
it because this is my first time
excellent congratulations atusa we'll
see you in a couple of days enjoy uh
enjoy the lessons uh that uh we do in
the community uh day uh the players go
out into the um schools that we coach at
at the St Louis chess club souland
Scholastic Center we we reach as many as
2500 students each and every year that
we expose to chess and since we have
these programs in the schools and we
have the U the participants of the US
championships it's really nice to that
they uh go out on the community today
and visit the schools and I think it's
amazing for all those kids to meet the
best players women in in the open
section the United States fantastic
imagine you could meet you know the best
players when you were six seven years
old it would be it would be overwhelming
awesome just simply awesome and I had
gone out this was like a year or two ago
I had gone out and I had played and I I
got nicked for a draw and my opponent
played really really really well they
almost carried him off off the football
field it was like yes very very very
nice and uh Christian how's Hans doing
Hans is still winning yes he still
winning yes and maybe we can uh see the
last final moves because I don't think
there's much abiman you can do right now
H even gave him a pawn back offered the
G6 Pawn okay you can take it it doesn't
matter my H Pawn is going down the board
and it's going very quickly and you're
not going to be able to stop it
that's
yes now I go Bishop G G5 yeah cover up
very nicely a beautiful shell for the
King on G4 the king is beautiful
protected I must say as what you're
saying
H4 H3 H2 and if the Rook ever does
manage to get over to the H file then
you've got Bishop H4 is another way of
helping escort the pawn meanwhile Rooks
belong behind pass pawns a pawn is no
threat whatsoever and Hans is cruising
this is this is easy Manu is just um you
know trying to go through the game
understand in his his mind where he made
that big blunder big mistake right well
was it a blunder didn't he just kind of
get outplayed a little bit he sort of
get out playay yes I didn't see like
nothing double question mark exchanging
the Queens was a very bad decision was a
bad decision okay yes yes at that
particular moment exchanging the Queens
was a very bad decision uh because again
his victory over Ray Robson yesterday
was so very impressive because the
position was chaotic and he played uh an
Olympic player uh Ray Robson not easy to
do and uh how's Fabby doing well not
that much has changed in Fabiano's uh
game I think these are the last couple
of moves Queen to G4 take take King to
E7 again Fab's strategy hasn't changed
since the beginning of the game since
the middle game uh to be frank he's just
trying to get Darius to his last couple
of seconds and he probably will be able
to do so by just shuffling the pieces
you know poking here and there Queen to
D3 maybe I go on D5 or d8 you have to be
careful about that okay spend five more
minutes right okay spend five more
minutes here's another test here's
another test small tests the position is
completely equal of course but there is
a couple of tests that darus will have
to pass in this one as well a couple of
decisions that maybe if he doesn't take
it quickly enough he's going to end in
trouble King Queen to H5 okay that's a
good yeah CU we were looking at these
ideas of G5 G4 and potential Queen H3
but I didn't think it was going anywhere
I didn't really want to play G5 G4
myself I actually really want to play G4
because that's an opportunity for me
with the black pieces to you know start
giving checks to the white king and for
me to take some kind of initiative not
just wait for white here you go this is
what I like this is what I I I've I've
been missing if you play Bishop E5 I'm
not going to play G4 and queen H3
because I feel that's a dead end I'm
going to play Knight D4 that's his plan
yes I'm going to play Knight D4 I'm not
necessarily going to play Queen E2 check
I'm just I want to only play Queen E2
check when we're in a in an ending where
I can give a
perpet Perpetual check this is it this
is the IDE this yeah to keep the
diagonal open so that I always have uh
Queen E2 check there well Darius did
play a very good game I mean this was a
really really good game no and that's
that's great good defense if he manages
to get that Knight on D4 and I don't
really see a good way for white to try
to even remotely stop that this is even
if you don't play Bishop E5 I can still
go Knight D4 more or less that's uh on
tap as we say and I think right now both
players are realizing the mechanism of
making a draw exactly
very nice okay let's go to let's go back
to Hans because we're seeing the last
few moves in that game right and funly
enough after the move Bishop B4 which I
thought was threatening Bishop E7 I
thought okay well now's a good time to
play King H King F5 and
F3 uh an said you know what I don't even
think that Bishop E7 is a threat I'm
going to play
F3 a kind of a tactical Mo Motif with
the whole King E6 it's sort of like
you're playing to win tactically as well
so let's take a look at that Bishop E7
F2 threat Queen Rooks Rook takes G5 King
F4 King F4 and promoting with a check is
the problem that's that's a big problem
big problem it's like it's very nice for
you to get a skier against M no that is
a check oops so yes f very accurate
calculation I mean so many risks would
you be taking them no of course not I
would have played King F5 and played H3
on my next turn and uh not you know I
don't believe in allowing my opponent
even the
joy of making the threat you know like
okay uh Misha played the move Bishop B4
with the hopeful attempt of having a
threat and so I'm of the school that I
don't even give you you know the chance
of making the threat of Bishop B7 King
F5 idea of H3 maybe the idea of crook
takes because I'm a pawn grubber as well
but uh Hans realizes that he's got this
game in the bag after F2 and uh he's
just waiting for his opponent to come to
the same realization no and this is an
important victory for H because huge
difficult loss yesterday and now with
the black p against against the leader
that's never an easy task and a Manu has
been showing great form he's been
playing very good chess in general
absolutely absolutely in fact one of the
things when Mishra is coming on the show
and enthus enthusiastically explaining
to us how he's going to win I'm thinking
to myself who's going to stop this guy K
yeah but Hans may stop him after if he
manages to win he is going to catch up
with him and have two and a half points
I think it's always amazing if you are
able to like bounce back you lose
difficult game and the next day you win
that should count for more than one
point exactly uh for for me it was
always very nice when I was playing in
these events with Gary casparo so Gary
would go through the field just he'd
Scorch the field like get I don't care
five five victories out of eight games
so what you wanted to do was get the the
number right behind Gary you wanted to
play the opponent you wanted to play
Gary's opponent next right because
they'd be all moralized they just gotten
Crush hum they humiliated they didn't
bounce back so quickly as uh as other
players so yeah that was the idea he
wanted the the number right after Gary
what are you looking at uh Christian I'm
looking at this Talia versus Alice Lee
game very important game for completely
winning for Alice Lee not that much has
changed I can just put the behind the
pawn follow it up with uh A2 I have a
feeling at some point you will have to
sacrifice the bishop for the upcoming
Queen on A1 and then we're going to have
to play Rook for two pawns which is
obviously just simply winning a
technical task but it's not over yet
it's not completely over yet because if
I manage somehow to start pushing my
pawns it might get complicated I don't
think Alice is going to let Talia off
the hook in this one but she's still
harboring some hopes uh crazy for for me
uh is the game between Carissa Yip and
uh ban because Karissa obviously was
playing for this ending indeed hoping
that she would a should she would be
able to achieve two protected pass ponds
two connected uh pass ponds against uh
the bishop she did and the uh table base
is saying draw chess is unfair it's just
amazing and now it looks like it's very
forceful right if you push the pawn to
G5
I King E4 okay and what else can I do
right F6 I move the king king F5 now
you're threatening to take so nothing
else to do push or you can also go
Bishop C3 by oh thank you all right I'll
I'll Happ but I guess Bishop C3 just
Bishop C5 back right and that keeps an
eye yep so Bishop back to D2 Bishop back
to D4 F7 Bishop back to C5 not
G7 doesn't I don't think it that I
thought I just I make your freeze for a
quick second and your next move is going
to be king G6 and you capture one pawn
and that's easy and beum okay I see one
way to lose this so you go Bishop C5
keep going yeah yeah keep going King C3
yep King C3 let let me fall for six King
C4 let me fall for
it Bishop B4 let me fall for
it no just take on
F7
because the king and Pa gave is a drop
wait I don't get why don't you capture
the bishop on
B4 yes yes you can also do that right he
was he was taking he was saying King
takes F7 as well I was just trying to
give up the bishop anything you want I
was trying to you can even lose it with
help and by the way W H has won his game
nishra very important win this opens up
fully this tournament right now it
really does it really does and if Obby
draws with which is the most likely
result right now plus one is going to be
a massive tie yes going to leave us uh
with a massive tie yes well how massive
is the question so you're going to have
Hans you're going to have ABI Manu
you're going to have Fabby and and and
Sam Shanklin that's four but they were
not joined by laner or no any of the PE
leavon any of the people 50% leavon
they're all all on all on 50% half a
point behind yes yes so it's
a those guys those guys are are are wolf
hounds they're right behind you and um
uh I wanted to ask you about uh an Nasi
and Arena Crush because that is a huge
game of as well as of course now Nazi we
thought was winning before there we go
and a draw agreed with Kissa and
vegan that was a back and forth Affair
it really
was uh it was hot potato with the
advantage yeah that's Scotch it was a
Hot Scotch yes nice um what's happening
uh Kate with Arena and Nasi let's take a
look Arena she's fought her way back
nicely
I yeah no my my my first impression is
is she's a pawn she's a pawn up where
did you win a pawn well the the the H
Pawn is missing so right about here uh
Nai played Knight E3 and there goes the
H Pawn now she can win the pawn on H6
back canot but the Rook D3 no you cannot
and there's a big threat of Knight F5
and you cannot stop it actually you can
go G4 yes and uh Rook takes A3 and
that's is well extra Pawn I mean just do
do not go G5 do not go G5 an extra Pawn
okay well actually that's a good
question can you go
G5 no G5 that has to be lost how is it
lost though I think I think Knight a
five yes check let keep going yesing
than and maybe B6 B6 okay B6 King E5 and
C5 not in time yeah shall we show
Christian but he may have missed
it you tricked
me again yes sir yes sir once again so
Reena and uh Talia are Reena continuing
her her momentum in this tournament
exactly she did play Alice Lee did play
that key move I like that move a lot
Rook A7 as the this Rook is being
prepared to just move away so we can go
A3 A2 Force Talia to give up her bishop
and as you were saying it will be a rook
uh versus two pawns
e and more results in the ladies Kate so
we can see what is the current standing
so we have two leaders still Karis say
and begim toir janova they did make a
draw so they are Leaders with three
points but they are closely followed by
Anna zatonski and T Abraham with two and
a half points but the window has been
open for arena because we think she's on
the better side of this ending if she
can get a win against n she also will be
TI for first oh that that will be huge
huge yeah huge turnaround I mean she was
really warus at that position but she
managed to to turn it around and let's
take a look at the current standing in
the open section we have two leaders
here actually pardon me three leaders
abim Manu Mishra Sam Shanklin and Hans
stean all have two and a half points out
of four with the expectation that Fabby
will draw his game and also uh join now
on the other hand should fabbi
win web is a a balanced position after
all the windows open for him for Clear
first uh going into the rest day
tomorrow yeah and that's that's a big
one that's still a big one and he's
still trying to find a way in right okay
he missed his opportunity Darius there
is to go that move Knight to D4 at least
without sacrificing a full Pawn right
yes because he played the move um after
Bishop E5 instead of Knight to D4 we
were discussing this he played move King
to E8 first and now King to G1 King
Knight to D4 is still an option the
problem is that right now now you
actually lose the pawn I wanted to go
check on E2 Queen F3 still I mean you
have an attack on B3 you have an attack
on G3 but you start doubting yourself a
little bit right you are a pawn down at
least for the next few moves I want G4
on the board please yes yes I want a G4
but now I go Queen
D6 Queen D5 excuse me
yeah the bishop can sneak in maybe you
can go here que is a good move I'm
curious if Queen G5 is also good yeah
Queen G5 works as well Queen H6 you
still want to get to that King somehow
right right yeah look it's it's
difficult to lose this position the
truth is just because uh the white king
is so weak right on G1 and any check if
I manage to give one check is probably
going to lead to a Perpetual so this is
the nature of the position as we we see
it right now but again it's all about
the time 9 minutes and 50 seconds
against 15 minutes so still Fabiano is
trying to find some way of magical
resource in the position to get this
Victory because he knows it I have a
golden opportunity to uh get in first
position going into the first resting
that would be massive for his chances to
defend his title I completely agree with
that no question about it and you know
the victories in these championships are
so hard to come by because you know when
you do defeat somebody they're not going
to lose all their games they're going to
be meeting your Rivals and nicking them
for draws as well so uh a victory today
is huge but I do expect that we're going
to be in a massive tie uh four-way tie
and what's happening in Arena's game
yeah let's take a look at the game
between Nazi PID and inen Crush because
Nazi just played Rook B8 attacking the
pawn on B7 she didn't go for Rook takes
H6 but Rook to B8 we were looking at
well I again I would be more inclined
but but I like this Rook B8 because if
you go Rook D7 maybe I can try Knight
G4 kind of activate my knight attack the
pawn on H6 threaten Fork on
E5 what do you want to do yeah well what
can I do actually not too much I'm going
to play I'm going to avoid first of all
I'm going to avoid losing I'm going to
go Rook check and I'm going to go Pawn
grubbing uh Rook takes A3 I may not be
able to win the game but at least I I'll
I'll en enjoy the snacks uh we have Hans
in studio over to you Christian Hans uh
first of all congratulations a big
victory big bounceback victory yesterday
it wasn't your day what did you do last
night to recover from that difficult
loss and come back back with new energy
in today's
round well um I honestly could not fall
asleep until um 5:00 a.m. o that was not
because I was outside of my hotel I was
in in the hotel
um so you were staying professional yes
well no I did not leave the hotel uh
usually when you say that I could not
sleep till 5:00 a.m. you would make
other assumptions um but I honestly just
could not fall asleep until till 5:00
a.m. uh this um this moment yesterday
this move F4 uh just really sort of
haunted me and uh I actually saw the
idea um and that would have just been
like you know basically winning the game
so that sort of was Haunting me um uh uh
until 5 a.m. and then I barely didn't I
didn't even check when E4 this game I
didn't prepare at all for E4 um but uh
okay he chose an opening that um uh I
knew quite well like all you probably
like obviously I spent a lot of time in
the opening um but I was it's not that I
didn't know the opening it's that I was
actually just choosing the lines uh the
line that I wanted to play yes um
because after the moment he plays like
Bishop C6 bc6 Bishop B3 there's a lot of
different uh ways to sort of equalize
and the one I played was just sort of a
psychological choice just because I
thought that um after um like Bishop
D3 this is all known um but it's a very
very technical POS position and I
thought that um perhaps he would feel uh
uncomfortable in a very slow maneuvering
game and uh eventually he he he sort of
and your alternative was in fact as you
mentioned to take on D4 and play this
structure which is considered to be
closer to equality but at the same time
white is not risking that much you
wanted to keep more pieces you wanted to
keep the position imbalance right yeah
well Rook B8 well the reason actually
that um Bishop C6 first like is is not
is technically not as precise as instead
of Queen B6 I can play Rook B8 um uh
like this is usually because usually you
don't need to take you can play Bishop
E3 without Bishop takes C6 right um and
then I would then there's then you do
allow the the idea of let's say Bishop
B3 but now you allow CD CD Queen B6 um
and then Queen B6 there's like uh main
move is Bishop
C6 uh Queen C6 and this maybe he didn't
want
to allow um so this is just allowing
like I knew Rook B8 and queen B6 are
both fine but I hadn't checked it in a
while
so I just remember
this like just everything being like
pretty equal but this there's some
long-term hopes just because of the
structure perhaps um but yeah he played
H4 this is the first move I didn't know
I wasn't exactly sure how to react after
H4 I thought H5 was logical I don't
think that I think I think that seems
fine Bishop G5 Rook E8 take take Knight
E4 yes yeah this I sort of um this was a
bit annoying but I thought it was fine
how did you assess the position at this
point because the engine was in fact
saying that you're in some sort of
danger right
now maybe I don't know it's unclear it's
hard to see like how white breaks
through um because I pring the queen to
D5 I control the B file maybe G4 at the
right moment he has to time it very well
what was my what was my mistake what was
the mistake then your I wouldn't call it
necessarily a mistake again you're the
engine is saying 0.9 so he's not as uh
significant right and he has to a
mistake or what is because I know after
Bishop D3 is like the best move like
what is the right after H4 H5 maybe a oh
okay oh A5 yeah just wait perhaps after
Bishop so this is this is yeah so this
was critical yeah so I calculated F6
Bishop so Bishop F4 C5 yes um I actually
saw this you could also include well
yeah and then BC mhm but I also wasn't
sure
like uh you don't include I thought like
the
issue was that let's say you take on F6
first like you
include instead of uh you take on F6
after C5 or yeah after F6 immediately
you take on F6 okay I thought like take
take and then Bishop F4 I just rookie
because my was C5 now uh uh C5
BC life yes yes and after DC not a three
uh so I just have to go Rook e eight
yeah maybe I I miss evaluated yeah I
should go F6 that makes sense but he
missed a bit he didn't find this move
Queen to F1 and after Rook to E2 already
you're back in the game you're
immediately back yeah Queen B5 yeah
Queen B5 I thought it's fine I have like
Queen D5 yeah Rook I like Queen E6 a lot
it was a nice uh Queen E6 was very very
nice prophylactic because he's sort of
threatening Queen H3 yes so I thought
Queen I just thought that you know uh it
was very clear that he felt very
uncomfortable in the position because he
couldn't really he can't just like
calculate he can't like Brute Force this
is sort of the style that he has like
not much uh like lacking in some let's
say like understanding uh but very good
calculator so it was clear that he was
very uncomfortable here and he tried to
like he sort of lost control like he
started going wrong here yeah and it was
at this point B5 Queen E6 yeah C5 take
yeah Rook C8 was a nice move and then
yeah here just uh he just sort of E6
takes yeah so he I think what he should
play is after takes I don't know Rook E4
is just a you can't explain such a move
but Rook E6 um yeah Bishop C3 is fine
but I thought Rook E6 instead Rook K C6
yeah and Bishop C3 Rook
E4 I wasn't sure how to yeah this seemed
yeah Bishop G7
and now have I wasn't I was I wasn't
sure like Rook G7 no this I saw this I
saw but R Rook E7 after G5 instead of
instead of Rook takes G6 instead of Rook
takes
G6 Rook takes E7 C3 oh I guess I am fast
enough yeah this was hard to to
calculate because it looks like I might
be Che okay yeah so the so8 rookie 7even
yeah uh Bishop f8 yeah no I saw Bishop
f8 but I guess it's uh just couldn't
really evaluate it um it looked really
weird yeah yeah okay this is probably
probably winning eventually um but he
also had only five
minutes at this moment yeah he did and
but I think just the momentum was
shifting right he just uh I think this
type of position he just really uh maybe
doesn't have much experience and I think
he he never actually I think he might
have one game in like the G6 Russell Lio
so um I think just a bit of an
experience um so Bishop C3 Rook C1 yeah
there were a couple of Final Moments
Bish B5 was was yeah this was nice yeah
so Rook B so I gave a check um so the no
no no yeah this a this was this is a
mistake with because I thought Rook B2
A4 I wasn't sure how to to break Rook F2
King Rook e Rook e two Rook E4 I saw
this wait so Rook F2 King G1 Rook E2
Rook E4 Rook B2
yes and then you have to go King F1 King
F7 and maybe I just slowly it's not that
clear how you break right yeah this I
wasn't sure um oh so this was a mistake
Rick Rick B1 was a mistake interesting
yeah it seemed what what was the what
was the so you have to play this
position basically Bishop to E3 go with
a I wasn't clear Bishop just basically
play this should be winning winning
winning somehow yeah yeah maybe this was
the practical but he was low in time so
I thought he would uh oh the E5 followed
by King E6 things of that nature yeah
slowly slowly probably he's in zong
eventually once I should just bring the
king to D5 and then Pawn on A6 and I
probably win uh would eventually just
stuck so yeah yeah interesting and after
that thought executed very nicely I have
to say it was uh yeah this was Final
moment when you played King E6 allowed
F5 of course that's just one move calcul
but sorry could you just tell me like
what the mistake was like how could he
have better defended King E2 instead of
Bishop C1 after Rook to B1 and and I go
check that was the only way that he
could have um continued King E2 check to
Rook B2 mhm Rook takes a22 Bishop B7
Rook G2 yes so this is not this is not
winning well check and king7 Bishop
G but I I have to pawns I don't I guess
the king is a bit weak right yeah the
king is a bit weak I thought that it
should
be would like Rook H2 it's not easy to
to assess this one right yeah I this
looked like um a oh he's just a
Perpetual oh wow that's that's insane
yeah you take the pawn but now it's just
a per or maybe he has some just insane
defense yeah cuz it looked to me like a
uh if you have two pawns no I understand
okay okay I guess it's hard to evaluate
yeah because this seemed like the other
one I was worried that there might be a
fortress
um but um interesting yeah after that it
was there was no chance really well
still you asked the Practical questions
you put a lot of pressure not only on
the position but on time as well so you
did your job and you got the full points
congratulations and what are you going
to do during the rest day to uh recharge
and get ready for the next phase of the
event well I've just found out there's a
rest day not by you but someone told me
I didn't realize it was a rest day
[Music]
um I will uh go enjoy um St Louis's uh
finest ways of passing time you also
have to do community hours you will have
to go to some schools of course that's
what I was referring to yeah I'm a man
I'm you know I I I find it insulting
that you don't think that that's what
I'm referring to you know you should you
should maybe research my scholarship I
didn't accuse you of anything I'm you
know you know Christian Christian I'm a
big charity guy you know scholarship
$10,000 giving away to young kids you
know even some you know kids from your
your Homeland Romania have have applied
that's beautiful so trust me I'm really
looking forward to the community today
and I'm looking I'd love to find some
you know strong talented chess players
so I can help support and achieve their
dreams no Absolut look I'm just telling
you because you didn't even know it's a
rest day so now I'm kind of telling you
there's a community I'm trying to help
I'm trying to help that's all no no no I
I don't worry don't worry don't worry I
don't don't worry I'm only messing with
you guys I love commentators I love
podcasters Here We Go Again H thank you
very much we'll see you tomorrow after
tomorrow thank you thank you Hans for
bringing Christian down about five
notches and just keep it up I love it
the momentum I felt the momentum you
felt the momentum shift I don't remember
seeing other players so excited about
Community we're going to take a break
and we're going to leave you with Sabina
having a very nice conversation with
with a defending Champion Jennifer youu
we'll see you on the other side of the
break loved it Go
H Jennifer thank you so much for joining
me today uh tell me a little bit about
your chess upbringing um so I first
learned how to play chess in chess club
at school U my parents told me I should
go so I went and I liked it at first
just because if you won they would give
you little keychains little chess key
chains so I I really like that and then
eventually I started competing um so I
don't think I had a very like strictly
like oh we should play chess like like
ever since I was young I just kind of
did all sorts of different things and
chess was one of them and eventually I
just kind of got a little better at
chess so it was like oh if you get
better you have to put more time into it
so that's just kind of what happened
with me and then um I so I kind of feel
like I just grew up playing in this game
did you spend a lot of time as a kid U
studying from books or were you already
at the time where things were available
online so you spend more time training
online when I first started I would just
do tactic books like puzzle books
honestly the main way I trained my whole
life was just puzzles like I that was
the main thing I like to do so I whether
or not I should have focus on other
things I just really liked it so um
eventually it was like when I was
growing up there was like tactic I
trainer is really popular in chess.com
so I would just do so much tactics
trainer every single day but that was
how I kind of worked on the game for a
very long time very nice and you won
this Championship two times so far and
you're the defending um Champion how uh
do you feel about getting into this
tournament like I know you mentioned
you've struggled with um you know your
fulltime student you're going to Harvard
how are you able to still find time for
chess and getting ready for the
tournament uh I never really know how to
answer these kind of questions because I
think I'm constantly trying to get
better and learning like I don't think
I'm the best at handling it I I
definitely it comes in waves like last
year I think I did an all right job but
also at the same time last year there
were times where I slept like three
hours a night cuz I was writing a paper
you know before a game so it's always
something I'm working on like this year
I have to take a midterm at the
tournament um I'm being proctored by a
TD like after the game so I don't know
how it's going to go um um but I'm
trying my best so we'll see you've been
able to manage things really well last
year and and you're always very focused
when you're playing a tournament do you
also uh so you go to school but do you
are you able to combine uh also a
healthy lifestyle so that you're able to
have enough energy to deal with all of
these tough situations in your life yeah
um it's really important for me to like
personally like stay active and also be
social like I really love spending times
with like my friends and my roommates so
um that's something I value a lot so
sometimes when you have to pick between
This and like studying that's also its
own challenge but I you don't need me to
talk about that okay no but what about
um in school besides school are you
involved in any projects like any clubs
um at school anything else that you're
doing besides studying and chess yeah so
I was part of a lot of different um like
extracurricular like Prett professional
organizations and a lot of different
other clubs on campus over the last
couple of semesters and um so something
I'm doing a little bit different this
semester is I'm putting a lot of it on
the back burner and mainly just focusing
on school and like try to do some chess
just because I felt like I was being
stretched very thin but you know I
learned a lot of different things from
my experiences in those organizations so
that's just that's the that's for like
the future for whatever career I end up
doing are you still deciding on which
career you might be going um after
graduating um yeah I yeah it's it's
still in the process for Recruitment and
a lot of different other things but yeah
like I I think I changed my mind quite a
few times over the last few years so so
we'll see how it goes how many more
years do you have I'm a junior right now
so this year and then last year next
year sounds good well I hope you've been
able to balance everything well and
you're going to do well during this
tournament I'm looking forward to seeing
you your games thank you so much
Jennifer and good
[Music]
luck yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping Ground Schools and they've just
grown the game so much across the UN
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American chest in
general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr juny
singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that sing has Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it send a hope
that the game of chess will always stay
AF flat by the mere fact of its
existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's bestag ERS become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess hf.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
Val educational tool learn more about
our Scholastic programming by visiting
St Louis chess club.org
education St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the worldclass
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Cub Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your member membership
[Music]
today hello everyone and welcome back to
our live coverage of the 2023 national
championships is coming down to the end
at the wire if you will and Fabby versus
darush darush just coming down about 10
seconds and he just made a big blunder
Christian we were as we were coming on
air we were looking at Knight D4 we
didn't consider F5 how bad is it it's
losing according to the engine so we're
going to have to wait and see how the
players are going to react to this one
we're expecting taking on F5 followed by
this transition after the move Bishop to
A7 so take take Bishop A7 now you have
to get ready for Bishop takes B6 so you
have to follow up with Knight D4 take
Knight to B3 but now I just simply go
King to E3 and I'm getting closer and
closer to uh you King to G4 for example
Bishop to C7 this is going to go down to
the wire uh and I'm not trusting the
engine that much in this one because you
really have to calculate this position
very accurately so we're still waiting
maybe Darius is calculating better than
the engine we have here in studio with
us but even so he made this last move
with three seconds on his clock no right
now he has 33 seconds so for the
remainder of the game he will have to
make every single decisive decision with
only few seconds on his clock and I have
to say I'm surprised with F5 because if
you have Knight against Bishop you don't
want to open up the position that much
right you don't want to be trading
pieces or pawns yeah no in this case I
here was the uh Pony I was writing uh
Knight D4 uh because I thought Bishop A7
was essentially Unstoppable right and
instead of playing this F5 business I I
was thinking I was GNA go King here play
for G4 and play for Knight D2 and let me
just stop myself because we saw a very
very Swift uh capture there Christian
take on F5 and to F5 time trouble uh
time pressure is what it's all about
Bishop A7 and now you're more more or
less forced to go Bishop a exactly and
I'm more or less forced you have to play
okay Knight takes B3 and once again
we're in this situation where you can
come back with your king of probably
we'll play Bishop C7 angling for King E4
all right knight4 is on the board and he
should play these moves faster so that
he builds some time on his clock I don't
know if that was a glitch in the in the
video there but it looked accelerated I
when they play Bishop takes B6 and
Knight takes B3 that was uh some very
very fast hands all right back to 1
minute and 42 seconds that's a big big
um addition agree
King E3 as
expected uh Kate if you were a betting
lady and you were in this situation I
mean whites for choice no question about
it but do you think it's winning I think
it's going to be very difficult to be
defending this when you have only minute
on the clock exactly right if Dar had 15
20 minutes I think he would be able to
defend if it's possible right but with
one minute it's so easy to make one
inaccurate move and game over exactly
and exactly how
is he supposed to defend this one uh
Christian it's not is he going to go
King
G4 and put his faith I think he has to
G4 G4 no no no trying to build a block
no no no that's not the way to go
because I think Bishop to C7 now or you
don't you don't want to kick the K
Knight out of the way Bishop to C7 but
Bishop to C7 what do you do next what do
you play what's your next move I I'm not
sure I mean am I supposed to play King
E6 just King E6 King E4 or King D3 then
yes I you're right now I'm starting to
have some hope
but where am I what he had to do was
King to G4 it seems like and get the
king to H3 and only after go for this G4
idea well I agree with that
wholeheartedly because the the point is
is after G4 I'm in zukan Bishop C7 every
move I make if I move my knight I lose
my Pawn if I move my king I lose
territory and the king is going to come
either to E4 or F4 um a minute and 3 is
it winning now is it just winning again
I don't trust the engine too much the
engine is saying yes winning but I don't
trust this particular engine too much
mhm by the way before Fabby makes the
move maybe let's just switch quickly to
Talia cantes and Alice Le game because
is getting a lucky break she is about to
win her game exactly she's a rook for
pawn and we know there's nothing and
there's no contest here and we were
saying that she was struggling a bit
because she lost two games she made one
draw right uh what very sad ending for
Talia who had amazing Advantage
yesterday but only drew the game and now
uh it looks like she's going to lose it
it it's terrible like quesa can really
punish you right uh you don't win a game
you should have won won then the next
day you come and you end up losing and
it almost feels like you're giving away
points uh I don't know if we're going to
see a handshake here I'd like to go back
but we do recognize and acknowledge that
uh Alice is about to win and we do have
Bishop C7 and exactly here everything
that Faby was playing for taking
advantage of gish's time trouble uh
trying to needle him with these uh
questions and he's just played the move
Bishop C7 looks like zukon to me King E6
on the board as uh as we're I think
we're about to see King F4 take us
through the line uh Christian King F4
Knight D2 King F4 unfortunately forano
is not a good move because of King to D7
gotcha right so the idea is that I'm
trying to free my knight exactly and you
from the defense of that pawn on a five
that's an important PA right so Bishop
to B6 I follow that Bishop with a king
C6 and you just keep Bishop I follow
that Bishop with you keep hitting the
bishop gotcha so I guess I'm going to
after the move King E6 I'm going to go
after your knight something like King D3
with the idea of that's right yeah let's
go King D3 that's the best move in the
position and then after King D7 Bishop
B6 I can TR I can trade surprisingly
after the move King to D7 Bishop
E5 traps the Knight Bishop oh he plays
King E4 okay he played King to E4 so
King to D3 King to D7 Bishop E5 was a
winner yes but King E4 is this also a
winner not clear now Knight to D2 seems
to be the best move in the position but
this is not an easy move to make because
you have to start calculating completely
different positions King where do you go
after Knight F1
KN but this one king
E2 you have to go King D7 now that's not
an easy wow this is almost study like
and by the way are you in time it does
seem like you're in time after King F1
King
c72 on the board he found it he played
it wow remarkable and King D3 very very
quickly yes uhoh and Knight went back to
B3 okay that was not the move though was
it was it Knight F1 not the move Knight
F1 was the move but he's still not
losing because you don't have that move
Bishop to E5 to trap the Knight the
Knight always have some Escape squares
right now for example if you go King C3
I go Knight D4 you take the pawn on A5
and I go Knight D2 check and I pick up
the pawn on G3
gotcha so okay so can we go Bishop
d8 with the idea to if you go King D7
I'm going to go Bishop F6 and trap the
Knight KN MH yes yes yes that's a nice I
like that idea
that's that's a good way to try to
confuse your opponent for sure well I
find the position very confusing I want
to play Knight C1 check I don't want to
let you play Bishop F6 okay so I go King
E3 King E3 and then I'll go back well
the thing with Knight C1 in this
particular case is that you also Bishop
F4
okay and let's see uh sorry I'm just
going to refresh my board and get to the
current position everyone we expect a
very quick Knight to D4 right something
happened there that was scared me uh
Bishop to F4 sorry yes now KN Knight to
D4 right absolutely so Bishop D2 Knight
C6 and I'm I think I'm I'm not sure I'm
not sure cuz I Got King E4 then I the
pawn on G four is so vulnerable I know
what about Bishop E3 exactly I think I
like the pawn in game right after King
E5 do you oh by the way by the way knew
C5 okay now I understand what's what's
the
situation uh this is
a is it a win okay one two three four
five six I mean how fast are you yeah
this is a draw it is a draw wow it's a
draw one tempo
draw not on B3 don't go to check good
point I just needed to get the king out
of the way but not uh not that way but
it's still a draw yeah and we make a
draw by a
Tempo that's crazy but imagine having to
calculate all of these things with no
time how much time does he have like 20
seconds I I'm I 47 seconds 45
okay but Knight D4 is forced is it
because Bishop E3 is trapping the Knight
oh
yeah yeah yeah Knight E4 is completely
you can do king F5 and after Bishop E3
King E5 and now I check oh sorry King C3
Knight Knight D4 I take and King D3
sorry that's a wow that's a winning Pawn
in a game for the
audience please tell me what you just
discussed King F5 what we're expecting
Bishop E3 yes
what and then we're expecting King E5
correct correct no but this is over why
what is this what king F5 Bishop E3 King
E5 King C3 Knight D4 I take and King D3
ah this is the tempo but guys I have
King E4 after King C3 aha oh than thank
you
Kate I'm going to play for a win now let
us show
Christian but I'm not sure you are
are we I should be right because now
Knight D4 is much
stronger uh just a second so we move the
bishop Knight D4 is much stronger why
explain it to us Bishop takes Pawn takes
King you have to go you have to go D3
you have to go D3 D3 yes right because
King F3 I I'm I'm faster right D3 but
that's the end game that was a draw
before no okay yes yes I think you
transposed to the
very wow
nerves nerves of Steel to play this with
no time on the clock King F5 oh
remarkable move what Bishop
B3 yes King E5 yes and Bop to
H6 get lost to tackle you from behind if
you play the move Knight to D4 is the
winning move
okay that's very
difficult if he finds it I mean what by
the way that's a study like uh move that
Bishop H6 move that would be crazy move
and by the way it's not even over at
that point you go King
F6 yes then finally I go King E4 and we
play this position and then I'm I'm
ready to uh play King D5 oh this is wow
this is an incredible end game Bishop E3
King to E5 immediately played okay let
me just refresh I'm sorry Bishop H6
Bishop H6 he found it immediately so he
saw it the movie before that is some
dark magic right now wow and for darush
if he hadn't seen that with a minute on
this clock that is quite the shocking
move yes yes that's a shocker right
there Bishop
H6 You' almost convinced yourself I've
got the draw in hand right you're just
about to play Knight D4 and transpose
into those drawn King and pawn end games
that we've been witnessing King
F5 all right King F5 now Bishop G7 now
this is the idea was to tackle this
Knight to prevent the knight from coming
to D4
unscathed what an important game for
Fabby remarkable yeah no I mean this
would be huge guys I mean uh wow uh he
would have the wind in the sails
uh going into tomorrow's free day and
just be feeling like thank you taking
care of Mishra stopping that runaway
train and uh clear
First bishop to G7 is the key move right
now okay but he played Bishop H6 with
intention of playing Bishop G7 played so
he just doesn't need to rush he has
about five minutes so double check he
can make sure that that is the best move
in the position by the way I because I
think this is over right now why okay
why is it over after Knight C1 once
again sorry knight1 I go King King
D2 King D2 of course of course you do
excuse me uh AP just trapping the Knight
indeed that's exactly right and anytime
I force the Knight to go to D4 I'm going
to grab it and have a winning pwn in
game indeed
and by the way just to uh take a look at
the lady section Alice is winning she
has a rook for a pawn Rook takes G5 and
uh Rook takes G5 as an opportunity Talia
Talia realizes she just doesn't want to
look at it at the position Rook takes G5
and Rook G6 skewes The Rook uh nothing
to discuss back yep there we go she
plays it and Talia knew it of course yes
and stop the call that's the resignation
there we go um back to uh Fabby Knight
C1 was
played Knight C1 King D2 Knight B3 back
now he has to go King E3 yeah it's like
a an an amazing
triangulation there just to wrong foot
the the black
king that move G4 o G5
G4 that really how you calculate those
positions with 30 seconds on the clock
that's the problem that's the you cannot
allow yourself to get down did you to do
it no to 30 seconds twice in the same
game right right and I have to say I
mean King E8 at that point when he could
have played Knight to D4 to block
everything and transition into that
Queen end game no that would have been
that was the moment yes you play Knight
D4 I think that's more or less over I
don't think there's any tries after that
exactly but this I mean tip of the hat
to Fabby for finding that move Bishop H6
that as you you very well described it
dark magic yeah something wow to be
alert that alert at this late stage of
the game and if he wish to win this win
this game uh Kate so leader so leader
How Sweet It Is nine seconds for Darius
needs to make a decision King
G6 King
G6 and now Bishop to
C3 or Bishop to E5 I like the bishop to
C3 because that way I keep an eye over
the A5 pawn and but can I also do Bishop
B2 just not allow any jumps whatsoever
and then go King D3 King C2 I like it
because I also like I love this idea of
being able to play King E4 so if you go
Bishop B2 and just say okay your turn
your turn what would you like to do and
that's what done love it Bishop
B2 and Bishop and saying zuk Swang your
turn your turn and he's done here we
go love it any King moves I can I don't
have to come over this way I can simply
run my king up the board and squeeze you
out of territory extremely accurate play
by Fabiano caravana here yes he has
played this very well indeed
wow this this was just a matter of will
right and I remember a game also from a
usj championships between himself and
Ray Robson right it was a very similar
end game something extremely minimal and
he took him all the way until the last
few minutes the last few seconds that's
when he uh produced The Magic because
that's exactly what happened that was
the game when he uh promoted to a bishop
if you remember
oh yes mind over matter I mean what can
you say I mean the
determination is simply extraordinary
and we do see King G5 and I think we're
about to see King E4 in a
triumphant entrance of the white king
the problem is the Knight cannot go to
C1 because then white can simply capture
the pawn on A5 or Bishop
D2 oops don't not oh wow yeah that's
even better and now with the King on G5
but this is the whole point you're
running out of territory if you move
your king I can go here King
G6 uh King D5 but also King F4 is very
very attrative right now do you go king4
and King is that I go king4 yeah I think
I do too King F4 looks really
nice King F4 King H5 and King F5 right
yes besid say so King F4 I don't have
anything oh Knight D2 oh King F5 KN
D2 okay and he's done this is his last
Cheapo look at that that is a very
impressive Cheapo that is so funny a
stal mate
wow
okay so King of4 King H5 on the board I
wonder if he's about to spot it so maybe
just like Bishop King F5 King F5
allowing Knight D2 don't tell me that
this game can be drawn it's still a win
it's still a win because of Bishop takes
A5 Bishop takes A5 KN because the king
is so badly placed right yes oh but you
have to go KN D2 option at this point I
want to see Fabiano's face after 92 on
the board has py got up from the board
no no no he's at not yet okay but Knight
D2 that is maybe he did that is a real
visual went away yes maybe he did go
away I mean you have to play Knight D2
that's the thing you don't see Knight D2
but then you get up from the board you
walk by a monitor and you see it
from you know the perspect a different
3G perspective and you go oh my gosh
what about Knight D2 right right right
no he surely saw it he must have seen it
the thing is okay 92 it's sort of easy
to calculate after Bishop takes A5
Knight C4 and Bishop C7 that defends
everything really the position you want
to have when you have the bishop right
you're seriously defending upon you're
attacking and you're going to escort and
Knight C1 see1 okay that one doesn't
have as
much uh going forward as Knight D2 yeah
you're not even taking a pawn anymore
he's looking to play no but then I go
Knight Bishop C7 of course course and
the bishop C but with the extra Pawn on
C4
exactly yeah
wow what a game truly and what a
game Knight D2 and darush has four
seconds but he made E2 and we do expect
uh Bishop C7 Bishop E1 okay but Bishop
C7 just simply defending the pawn on G
G3 that's all it takes and it's a Aon
train the Aon
Express yeah wow what a game very very
very impressive the determination that
that was the of Bob
incredible wow no he just realized that
okay abiani just lost I can go into this
rest day the first rest day a very
important restate actually um as a Soul
Leader
right and we do have 94 check on the
board by the way expecting King
E4 and Knight C6 well it's all about the
Aon also Dar had a lot of issues with
time right he was under pressure before
move 40 now he was under pressure that's
always easier to play for Fabi here when
he manages to really kind of have the
discipline to have a lot of time on his
clock
never be stressed out I jinxed him I
said that if he makes the first time
control that's it right there's no way
he loses that right now I feel
bad by the way it's just me but that
that white King on e4 is not perfectly
centered Shad Shad who in the world
cares well Sam Sean might pick up
White's King and you know like hey man
your King's busted try to decapitate the
King still one of the alltime
classics so we can go and capture
another Pawn King D5 you can definitely
do that yeah but why not move the
pa6 B4 I guess A5 Knight B4 and then
Bishop D6 I love it you know just go
after this guy yeah Knight A6 and King
F4 oh you are
no told me you're you're a mean
lady that's not nice by the way the the
engine of Val went from 55 to 63 thanks
to your king of four that's
really uh killing it King F4 no
yeah King
D5 let me just refresh my board and
bring to domination y of black species
right now ouch and that King on H5 it
just feels so forlorn right I mean no
entries nothing and it's all gone
y next
is7 followed by guys another amazing day
of uh chess here at the Championships
again warning everybody that tomorrow is
a free day otherwise we will be back on
Tuesday same time so same channel all at
120 Central East Central Time uh lots of
decisive results in this one as well two
decisive results in the open section
three decisive results in the ladies and
uh this is a big victory for Fabiano
right now it it's
huge and we have in studio Alice Lee uh
Christian please do the honors Alice
first of all uh congratulations for your
first victory of this year's campaign
this was not an easy one up to this
point this tournament I mean you lost a
couple of games you draw the first one
you drew the first one but finally you
got that elusive Victory congratulations
how do you feel right
now uh yeah I mean this game was
extremely like crazy uh I think I was
like winning I had a really good
position out of the opening um and then
like after that I just somehow I managed
to thunder and then I I was like
completely losing right before time
control but I managed to then be winning
again and I was able to win but I mean
for me it's really great uh to finally
get like a win because uh obviously the
start wasn't so great for me and uh it's
just good for me to go into the rest day
uh on a positive note we always talk
about confidence we always talk about
momentum in chess uh what did you do
after those difficult losses to get back
psychologically into this tournament
uh I mean I just did what I normally do
I'm I didn't do too much because uh I
find if I adjust my routine sometimes it
goes like uh it backfires so um yeah I
just did uh like my normal preparation
and uh trying to make sure that uh I I
mean when I did the preparation I didn't
do as much as I did for the previous
rounds um because I think sometimes at
the end of the games I got like slightly
tired and made on necessary blunders um
but yeah I didn't do too much but I'm
glad that at least in this game it was
able to work and just to discuss the
game and the critical moments of the
game when did you feel like you're
finally taking
over I mean so I played like night G4
and then um it was like it was uh night
G4 at some point um and then she played
H3 actually after I played night G4 I
was think that towards the beginning of
the game right toward the beginning so
like after she played uh H3 I was pretty
happy because uh here um actually when I
play night G4 I thought she could play
F3 and then I hadn't calculated that and
that definitely was something that I
should have calculated um I mean I was
thinking maybe I could take on H2 um but
still something to calculate since the
Knight gets trapped right um but after I
played like Knight G4 H3 and got the
Knight to E4 I thought my position was
at least like a preferable to play
because um my knight on e4 can't really
be hooked Away by F3 uh and now it's I
just win an exchange but then something
went wrong was it was you you assessed
it correctly it was winning yeah
something went run and I
mean I kind of missed this like C4 I
definitely miss Bishop takes C6 um yeah
so here of course if Queen Tex C6 she
would play Rook T B5 and uh Rook B7 so
uh Ken C7 I think also she has Rook
takes B5 and then I knew like I would
have to be losing it just transposed but
then she play Queen A5 because I suppose
it's like an immediate uh win it's like
unless I have a ky 5 and she probably
miss KY 5 um otherwise I'd be completely
losing wow wow and you saw this King D5
from afar you were definitely trying to
play um against her clock as well
because she only had 40 seconds she was
making those last few moves and she was
only playing on increment at this point
so King to D5 and finally you felt safe
with a king on e4 we kind of were
laughing about the journey that the king
engaged in right you long castled went
back to AA now back to E4 like exactly
how are you feeling when you finally
landed that King on e4 and realized that
she doesn't have a
Checkmate I mean yeah after I play KY 5
calculated like um that she probably I
didn't see any immediate checkmates so I
was like okay actually I should probably
be winning and then I mean I think I
mean this decision to go into the end
game was more like because I mean I Pro
I might have had something else but um
it's just very safe and with the King
for I think it's a good decision to go
into the end game I applaud that
decision
Alice Alice congratulations guys any
questions quick question for you Alice
just in the moment uh I think it was
move uh 20 it was a bishop
C5 and Kate and I were very enthusiastic
about an exchange sacrifice I Rook takes
H3 you decided to snare The Rook why
didn't you sacrifice The Exchange Rook
takes H3 right there wait so instead of
Knight takes F1 yeah well instead of
Knight D2 yes that's
right yeah I I think I considered um Rus
H3 because um I mean of course I was
like considering all the attacks against
the king but I think after uh I thought
like 92 should also be winning so like
why not uh and then I kind of like I
didn't realize how much initiative she
had still after um because I was like uh
planning to sorry I was planning to like
uh take the bishop on C5 until I
realized that maybe it wouldn't be as
good um yeah and then here something
went wrong and then things went wrong
all right Alice well enjoy your rest day
and uh welcome back to the
tournament thank you absolutely as once
again let's take a look a refresh
everybody for the results now that round
four is in the history books standings
for the ladies yeah after round four
right before the rest day we have a
two-way TI for the first place Karis and
begim to janova three out of four and
then there is a
yes for thira crash Anna zatonski nazzi
p and t Abraham with two and a half
points and we still have ashita esan who
is trying to get that start to the
tournament ouch and in the uh open
section who leads in the open section we
have a change in the leader right now
the sole leader is Fabiano Carana with
three points out of four and then there
is a three-way tie for the second place
Sam shangan Hans nean and amanu Mishra
with two and a half points and we're
hoping that Bobby will join us as we
complete our broadcast for this the
round four uh we'll get just get him set
up in studio Fabby is amazing
determination Christian absolutely and
he is in fact with us right now Fabiano
congratulations welcome back to the show
it felt like there's no difference
between you two guys after 40th move and
all the way into the end game how did
you create that separation when did you
know that you finally achieved that
separation yeah it was it was rather
silly because I played the opening in a
terrible way as I as I often do in this
Italian I don't know why I keep playing
it but I I got a slightly worse
position uh like just slightly worse and
it kind of reminded me a bit of the game
we played last year where I was slightly
worse for most most of it and then when
he gets into time trouble he makes some
rather questionable decisions like I
thought Rook E7 was a very strange
decision because I'm slightly worse and
also I can't do anything and then he um
well he allows me a pretty like
risk-free position I don't I didn't feel
like I was any more in danger at play
this point yeah yeah like queen7 or
something
yeah he just changed the structure with
no time which I understand he wanted to
release attention because okay it's a
tense position and we he had 30 seconds
but it's clear black is maybe slightly
better maybe much better but certainly
not worse and after Rook E7 I'm
definitely not worse anymore y um that's
what I felt then I started to play more
or less for win because I have I have
more time and and I didn't feel like I
was worse then of course it was a dead
draw uh and he made the time control
with this last move G5 Knight D2 h
and Knight takes E4 how did you see your
chances of uh winning this game at this
point like
1% like the position it's the problem is
that his Knight is so good that I can't
really create threats and not only that
my king is also vulnerable so I thought
the position is a dead draw and uh I
didn't even feel like white can really
play this position like it felt if
someone's playing for a win it's it's
just as much black as white like neither
side can really play for a win I thought
if he wants to force a draw the easiest
was before King E8 yes uh Knight D4 is
just okay I was that's what we were
expecting as well yeah yeah I mean here
I I can't uh I I have to take and the
point is these Queen ands can sometimes
be trick okay this is just immediate
Perpetual they can sometimes be tricky
tricky if his Queen is is on for example
D7 but on on H5 he can go to G4 if he
wants he can go to h8 if he wants so I
kind of have to take on D4 um and then
he played King E8 and I was actually for
like five minutes I was thinking okay
I'll play Queen D5 and make a draw and
then suddenly I like saw Bishop F6 is uh
is still risk- free oh sorry King
G6 is is kind of risk-free and it's a
little bit tricky for him because first
I thought okay Knight D4 should be a
dead draw but then I thought Bishop D4
Queen
D7 King F2 well CD4 also King F2 Queen
D7 King F2 so I think Queen D yes if CD4
then then King F2 as well uh and here
okay Queen D4 I get a a winning Pawn end
game and if CD4 I play this at least I
to much winning I mean um and CD4 I play
E5 and it's like a little bit unpleasant
he got into time trouble and he didn't
want to play his position like I play
Queen E4 Queen D5 I get my queen in the
king kind of blocks the D Pawn it's
risk-free I mean okay probably a draw
there's something to play for right yeah
there's something to play for suddenly
and then I thought his last moment when
like I thought his idea so it was
interesting when he played this queen H5
move this is when I actually had um some
hope because if he wants to play Queen
H3 then it forces Queen A8 Knight f8 and
I realized that this position is like
Queen H3 here for
example instead of Queen H5 Queen A8 he
has to play Knight f8 to avoid losing
Queen and Bishop B7 Queen H2 uh is a
draw mhm que King F3 MH Queen H1 it's
very important he goes to H1 mhm uh King
G4 and queen
D1 maybe oh wait maybe F5 is is
dangerous but but in any case like he
doesn't risk because my Bishop on E7 is
loose so my king doesn't really have
anywhere to go right so when he played
Queen H5 I realized that he wanted the
only reason to put the queen on this
square is to play King G6 so you don't
lose the queen and I I started to feel
some hope in this end game because it's
very very tricky I don't know I guess
it's a draw but it's a very tricky draw
after Bishop E5 I mean with no
like you know white doesn't risk he to
go into this he played it well and I
think it was this moment when um he
played the move
G4 which gave you some clear chances
King to G4 seems to have been the better
move but again with only a few seconds
on the clock the clock winding down the
problem is this is this is not easy this
is a race right like I play Bishop C7
and then I bring my king he takes G3 I I
mean uh King D3 yeah like okay G4 I
guess the race is fine for him but yeah
yeah King C3 Knight D4 Bishop A5 King G3
Bishop B6 like hey white doesn't risk
right yeah um Knight E6 yeah Knight E6
probably probably he missed this move
which is is important and then he's in
time yeah so okay yeah it's it's drawing
margin is high but uh it's it's easy to
miss these type of moves of
course or
miscalculate yeah this is kind of how
how it starts to
to sort of snowball when you it's a draw
it's a draw and then suddenly you have
to like make one difficult decision and
then suddenly it's uh it's not a draw
anymore and we call this uh final moment
when you played this move I believe it
was somewhere around I'm trying to find
it Bishop H6 you play this move Bishop
to H6 at this point and we call this
dark magic because it's in fact I
believe the only move that wins this
position you found it very quick quickly
how did you do
that yeah I kind of saw it in advance I
I realized that once my Bishop is on C3
it's just his Knight is cut and he no
longer has any checks like his his
checks don't lead anywhere so Bishop on
C on C3 is ideal then my king goes to E4
and he doesn't have any um anything like
he's both tied to the pawn and his King
also gets cut off and like after King E4
there's no longer Knight D2 which was
kind of what was saving him with the
bishop on C7 right he had this Knight D2
check yeah so I just wanted to get my
Bishop there I and okay I kind of
quickly saw that this route is uh is the
way to do it and King F6 then then the
King goes to E4 right so um oh sorry
King F6 King C3 yeah so it's it's
um not no wait no sorry no no King
Bishop to no King E4 is fine oh yeah
King E4 okay I I even forgot what my
intention was but I guess I guess King
E4 was my intention yeah yeah um yeah
once the king is on e4 then he gets like
Bishop on E3 and then he gets cut his
King gets cut off so yeah it was a tough
game what can I say tough game but very
good result for your campaign and your
chances to defend the title
congratulations as you go into the rest
day Katherina do you have any
questions um didn't have any question
but let's ask some now you are a Soul
Leader Fabby you probably did not expect
it uh yesterday to be so leader after
today how do you feel
yeah of course excellent I mean things
couldn't have possibly gone better like
I really shouldn't have made two points
from the last two games I mean uh one
point would have been normal from the
positions uh maybe maybe one and a half
but uh but two is definitely really uh
unexpectedly good and um yeah it's it's
a bit up and down for everyone else I
mean obviously uh there's a there's a
lot of people who are close and it's
just start getting started so it's not
like um not like I'm you know getting
ahead of myself yet but it's it's of
course very good to win this
game absolutely fabul happy to be your
wingman on this ending uh amazing
determination there was just one brief
moment at the very very very end King fi
and it was this moment that caused us a
little bit of Mirth but did you see the
move Knight
D2 at the very
end just had to ask oh my God
is this still winning it's still yes
it's still winning it's still winning I
assure you but it was a it was a nice
moment it was a very Mo
moment no but this is like almost
spoiling it yeah I have to play Bishop
A5 Knight G3 King E5 right Bishop A5
Knight C4 Bishop C7 Bishop C7 oh wait
what am I I I'm hallucinating I thought
okay no you are winning you are winning
the KN D2 fun at the moment I I'm really
hallucinating everything I for a second
I thought the Knight on D2 could take
could take G3 I thought this was like a
super I was getting really worried like
this Knight Knight takes G3 check is
also a threat anded right no at the at
the moment I'm I'm I'm kind of uh
hallucinating things so so let's not
talk about Chess anymore go get your
rest uh congratulations and we'll see
you on
Tuesday thank you absolutely night D2
that would have been fun that would have
been fun he didn't see it no neither did
darou all right how are we doing there
uhoh
all right it's that's that's that's good
that's good just a
second a lot of tournament left okay
terissa look at you B look at you I'm
doing well doing very nice and in the
open how are we doing that's what we
want to
see that was tough uh final thoughts uh
bring down the curtain for us well what
an amazing uh fourth day of Chess here
at the US West chess championships a lot
of decisive results and it does seem
like once again the players are ready to
fight but I have to say Fabiano's game I
mean kept us on the edge of our seats
all the way until the last moment and it
feels like every single day we have one
of those type of uh games that keep us
here in the studio and keep us on the
edge of our seats and I have Sam I'm
enjoying every second of it because the
games are fun the players are showing
incredible fighting spirit and
incredible quality of moves and this is
exactly what we're going to see here at
the US championship for the next 10 days
guys it's been a pleasure absolutely the
ter the determination of Fabby is only
matched by the determination of our
commentators what a team we are what a
team thank you for joining and sharing
your day with us everyone we will see
you not tomorrow but we will see you
Tuesday have a wonderful
day
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited